The State Board will be called to order and for our day session and the first item today is a waiver consent calendar.
We have on consent waivers one through 17.
We will present 18 separately.
So I'm looking for discussion or a motion on waivers one through 17.
I move.
Go ahead.
I move the consent.
I'll second.
Moved by Board Member Holiday, seconded by Board Member Burr.
Is there any public comment on these?
There is public comment on 18.
Yeah, I'm on 1 through 17.
Sorry.
All right.
No public comment.
Is there any board discussion on these items?
If not, all those in favor, raise your hands.
We're going to need a unanimous vote.
We do.
Okay.
Waiver 18.
We're going to have a presentation from the State Department of Education by Cindy Chan.
Good morning, Board President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
I was, I think I'm just doing an update on the errata.
If you want me to present the entire waiver, I can, but I was just going to point out a couple of... Yeah, just the errata.
Okay.
So for waiver 18 and waiver 19, there are some things that you need to consider when, in this one, because it affects the recommendation.
So for waiver 18 only,
In attachment one, specifically for waiver request 16-12-2016, which is a request from Mottol Unified School District on behalf of Mottol Valley Charter, Eureka City Schools should be added as a district of location for the following resource centers.
And Mottol actually requested a waiver for eight resource centers, but only three are affected.
We're asking that you add Eureka City Schools as a district of location for
the resource centers at 1539 F Street, Arcata, 2020 Campton Road, Eureka, and 2120 Campton Road, Eureka.
And then for both Waiver 18 and Waiver 19, in the recommendation section, the CD is actually recommending
five conditions and that was reflective in the waiver policy that you adopted in March, but only four of them made it into the item.
So we are asking that you add the fifth condition and I'll just read it.
If the authorizer has not visited the Resource Center identified in Attachment 1 pursuant to Education Code Section 47604.32, Subdivision A, Paragraph 2,
require the authorizer to visit the resource centers within a reasonable time frame.
So those are the two errata that you need to add to your recommendation.
And just for clarification, I just want to state for waiver 18 only, this is just to clarify, attachment is correct, but for waiver request 37-12-2016, there was some correspondence sent in because I think there was some confusion on what the district was actually requesting.
and it's because they sent in two letters and both letters were posted to the website.
So what Whitmore Union Elementary School District is asking on behalf of Northern Summit Academy is requesting a waiver for one resource center at 2877 Childress Avenue or excuse me Childress Drive in Anderson.
And that is correct in the attachment but in the letters there was a lot of
verbiage in there.
And in the end, they really only wanted the one resource center.
So it's just clarification purposes, mainly for you and for the public.
And that's it.
If you have any questions, I can answer them.
Public comment on this item.
Come forward, please.
Megan Macy with Lozano Smith here today representing Anderson Union High School District, Cascade Elementary District related to the Northern Summit Waiver and Redding and Shasta High School District related to the New Day Academy Waiver both submitted by Whitmore Elementary.
It's the position and there were letters submitted, hopefully you've had a chance to look at those, that these should be taken off the consent calendar and addressed individually.
There are some significant concerns related to the waivers themselves and there's opposition by all four of the school districts.
Fundamentally, neither of the waivers were appropriately approved by Whitmore in an open public meeting pursuant to the Brown Act.
And we also don't believe that either of the facilities at issue in the waivers were already existing and operating.
We have correspondence to that effect from the district.
So these are essentially new facilities.
So we would ask that these be taken off the consent calendar and addressed individually.
Thank you.
Next public comment.
Good morning, I'm Jeff Rice with the A Plus Personalized Learning Network Association representing 60 personalized learning public charter schools serving 60,000 K-12 students throughout the state of California.
We're here to express our appreciation to the staff's excellent work on these waiver requests and that we are in support of the staff recommendations to approve these waivers with the conditions as stated and would appreciate your yes vote and support as well.
Thank you.
Lisa Corr with Young Medine Corr here on behalf of New Day Academy.
I just wanted to let you know New Day did submit a response on Friday to the letters by Lozano-Smith.
They did have, in fact, an existing facility that was providing special education support and testing centers for students.
Then Lozano-Smith sent them a cease and desist in a threat of a lawsuit.
They held operation
for the time being, they postponed operation there while they submitted the waiver.
And now Lozano Smith is using that basis as a reason to ask that you not grant the waiver.
We'd like the year to transition those centers appropriately.
We need the year so that we can submit locally to Shasta Union High School District and that is our plan to do so.
Thank you very much.
And also just want to let you know that I am aware that there was a publicly held meeting at the district to consider the waiver.
Thank you.
Good morning, ladies and gentlemen.
My name is Adam Ferber.
I represent the Visalia Unified School District and the Tulare Joint Union High School District with respect to the waiver request attachments 46 and 47 of your agenda.
And I would, on behalf of the districts, I would like essentially to make the same argument that Ms.
Macy made, and that is that the Stone Corral Elementary School District that is seeking the waiver did not hold a public hearing in advance
of their waiver request.
And for that reason, we also request that the items be removed from the consent calendar and discussed.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Centre, in support of all of the waivers.
Okay.
Is there any further board discussion on this?
If we have a motion, it would have to include somehow the comments made by CDE.
So we could call that the CDE recommendation, I think, as amended by Cindy Chan.
Board Member Rucker.
Well, first of all, I want to begin with saying you may recall at the last board meeting in March where the board approved a policy to address the transition of these centers in settlement and in implementing a court decision.
There was a lot of concern and not only about the timeline,
but about how the process would work to create a transition.
So I believe we did the work in March to create both a process and a waiver process that would allow for a very smooth transition with a reasonable amount of time for these centers to work with the LEAs and the districts that they would be collaborating with for these services.
What we have in front of us today is a collection of waivers that have, that were submitted in support, in recognition of and in compliance with the waiver policy that we put in place in March.
I want to let you know that the staff did a lot of work in both contacting the centers and in working with the districts, not only to understand the location issues, but to make sure that due diligence was exercised in the execution of these waivers.
The changes that were requested by Cindy were simply just, were simply the additions to make sure that all the conditions related to the approval of these waivers would be met based on our policy.
So today I'm going to recommend that a motion that we approve the waivers that are on the consent calendar with the addition of the information that was provided by Cindy to add the additional fifth condition as aligned to our waiver policy.
Okay.
Is there a second on that?
All right.
Any further board discussion?
If not, those in favor, all raise your hands.
Okay.
Those waivers are completed.
So now we are down to item 16.
This is a... W21.
Pardon?
W21.
Okay.
On my sheet.
All right.
Who is presenting on that?
Good morning again, Cindy Chan, Director of the Charter Schools Division at the California Department of Education.
Item 21 or W21 includes requests by the Dehesa Elementary School District on behalf of two charter schools to allow these non-classroom based charter schools resource centers to operate outside of the boundaries of the authorizing school district but within the county.
Again, I'm going to note that this one also needs to be added.
The condition in the recommendation needs to be added.
I'll kind of state it again at the end.
But this one also needs that condition five about the authorizer visiting the Resource Center.
So I'll add that in my recommendation towards the end of my presentation.
Just a little background on this one.
If you recall, Board Member Rucker mentioned the waiver policy in March.
The background for that policy was that there was in January a third district court of appeals court opinion of the Anderson Union High School District versus Shasta Secondary Home School decision that became final that held that geographic restrictions in the specified statutes applied to non-classroom based charter schools operating resource centers.
Thus, in order to ensure compliance with the court opinion, a non-classroom based charter school resource center must operate within the boundaries of its authorizing school district unless an exception applies.
Additionally, the charter school may establish a resource center in an adjacent county.
The major timing of the decision's final status, however, was thought to be problematic for some schools to come into immediate compliance this year.
Thus, in March, the State Board approved Waiver Policy 17-01 entitled Non-Classroom Based Charter School Resource Center Location.
Consistent with the State Board's policy, Dehesa Elementary School District and the two charter schools submitted the following information as detailed in Attachment 1.
The address of each Resource Center, school district in which each Resource Center is located, date each Resource Center was established, and the number of students attending each Resource Center.
Also for each Resource Center subject to the waiver request, discussion of the need for the waiver.
CDE staff reviewed each waiver request and additional information provided.
We limited the request in the item to only those that we determined provided responsive data and information pursuant to the waiver policy.
However, in our review of the address of the resource center and the school district of location submitted,
With the waiver request for these two schools, we determined that a school district of location was not identified for some of the resource centers.
We reach out to the district a number of times.
We had they had responded on a couple on a couple of occasions, but the last confirmation we didn't hear from them.
And so we have added the other districts into the attachment.
So specifically for waiver request 722017 Community Montessori Charter, the school is requesting a waiver for five resource centers.
We have added a school district of location to the following resource center only.
The one at 9580 Carlton Hills Boulevard in Santee, we are adding the Grossmont Union High School District.
And for waiver request 3212-2016 for Dehesa Charter School, they are requesting a waiver for six resource centers.
We have added a school district of location to the following four resource centers.
At 367 La Vida Avenue in Encinitas, we're adding San Diego Union High School District.
At 1441 Montiel Road, Suite 145 in Escondido, we're adding Escondido Union High School District.
At 1800 North Broadway, Escondido, we have added Escondido Union High School District.
And at 5305 Sweetwater Road in Bonita, we've added Chula Vista Elementary School Districts.
The added districts are already noted in attachment one with a single asterisk.
Since all of the school districts in question are within San Diego County, we have also added the San Diego County Office of Education as one of the LEAs that should receive the transition plan as noted with a double asterisk.
We believe that the addition of the school districts and San Diego County Office of Education is prudent to ensure maximum transparency for the affected requests.
So if you can please refer to attachment one in order for your consideration today.
The CD is recommending that the request from Dehesa Elementary School District for each charter school and resource center identified in Attachment 1 and consistent with the State Board's Waiver Policy 1701 be approved with the following conditions.
Number one, require each charter school's governing body to approve a transition plan that details how the charter school's resource centers will come into compliance with the Anderson Court decision.
Two, pursuant to Education Code Section 33051B, each waiver shall expire on June 30th, 2018 and shall not be retroactive.
Condition three, require each charter school to submit the transition plan to the authorizing school district, county office of education, and to all school districts identified in attachment one, where the resource centers are located within 30 days after approval of the waiver.
Condition four, require each charter school to provide a status update to parents.
And as noted earlier, this one isn't in the item, but we have also are adding condition five.
If the authorizer has not visited the resource centers identified in attachment one.
pursuant to Education Code Section 47604.32A.2 require the authorizer to visit the resource centers within a reasonable time frame.
These conditions are all reflective of the waiver policy.
So I can answer any questions you have.
Not thank you.
Any questions for Cindy?
Board Member Rocker.
Okay.
Well, we may have public comment.
I don't know.
Is there public comment on this?
Yes.
Jeff Rice, Cecilia Ewing, Tony Brown, Laura Sylvester, Roland Young, and Terry Novak.
Jeff Rice again with A+.
We are in support of these waiver requests and urge your yes vote in support.
Thank you.
Eric Premack Charter Schools Development Center again in support.
Good morning.
My name is Celia Ewing.
I'm the School Director of Tehesa Charter School.
Thank you for having us.
I'm a Hispanic woman born in California, a product of the California public school system and raised by public school teachers.
My mother wrote one of the first independent study master's degree programs granted by the University of California, Berkeley.
Her master's degree granted in 1974 empowered teachers to diversify and personalize learning for students.
The educational philosophy that I inherited from her promotes student-led learning and a promise that a solid education could and would lift families out of poverty.
What has happened to the California dream?
As educators, we know that instruction is not one size fits all.
The charter school movement has been an effective path for thousands of students.
In our current political climate, there are many misconceptions about charter schools.
Our school is not for profit.
We take all students and have a 10% special ed population comparable to the large districts in our county.
We serve English learners, credit division students.
Wow, that was fast.
Thank you so much for your time.
And I know you're all passionate about education, so thank you.
Hi, my name is Tony Drown and I'm a regional manager for Dehesa Charter School.
in Escondido and the educational facilitator for Ramon Balderas.
Ramon came to Dehesa after leaving his local high school out of frustration and being discouraged by the environment.
He felt teachers didn't care, the classes were so big, and he felt marginalized.
and that the instruction was impersonal.
As a result, Ramon fled to Mexico and told his parents, I'm not going back to school until you find me a different school.
His parents, who spoke a little to no English, discovered DEHISA.
We met to discuss the demands of an independent study program, and he agreed he could handle it.
Ramon attended four classes a week offered at the Escondido Resource Center.
to support him in his core subjects as he learned to take ownership of his learning.
He developed projects, participated in community service, work study, and concurrently enrolled in community college to study emergency medical technology, Hispanic culture, and criminal justice.
And he demonstrated a high level of achievement.
After graduation, he landed a full-time job and tech support to save money to continue to go to college.
Thank you.
Sorry.
Hi, my name is Laura Sylvester.
I'm the founder and executive director of Good Dog Autism Companions, but most importantly, I am mom to Elliot, a 16-year-old, minimally verbal, autistic, beautiful boy.
After five years of working with the Ocean Unified School District, we exhausted all resources.
My son met one IEP goal in five years.
We left and we found Dehesa Charter School.
He wouldn't leave the house for the next two years.
We worked with them in their individualized and openness to work with my son.
Now he wakes up every Thursday morning.
He says, let's go see Johnny.
Johnny is his specialized education teacher at the Resource Center in Escondido.
They worked on simple addition and subtraction and spelling of three words for years.
Now he is working on content and managing education at his school age level and beyond.
And this would never be possible without the open and individualized look at his education.
So I'm asking you personally, do not close these resource centers.
We will never leave Dehesa Charter School, but without the resource centers, my child will not get a fair and appropriate education.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Roland Young.
I'm the school director at Community Montessori Charter School.
As the CDE has just stated, we were pulled off the consent list because we did not notify Grossmont Union High School District of our Santee Resource Center.
And I just wanted to explain real quickly the reason why we didn't include it is because our Resource Center in Santee only serves students up to grade six.
Our research centers are not schools.
They're labs of learning for students and their parents to access Montessori materials.
Montessori method is an educational approach that most of our parents did not have access to.
And it's still a very expensive approach that is only available in private schools.
Without our resource centers to support our families, would we still be able to do our jobs to support our families?
And the answer would be yes, but it would be difficult.
more difficult.
And our goal I feel as educators is to really give our families and our students access to education.
Since our charter school does provides a countywide benefit to our entire county, our transition planning involves.
Thank you very much for your time.
Good morning.
The manner in which we have operated for the last 15 years with the blessing of the CDE has now been determined out of compliance.
So now we are tasked with the challenge of defining what a resource center is.
And to my knowledge, there is no official definition.
If what defines a resource center is the name on the lease or the mortgage, then you can forget all the addresses on the list because neither of the charter schools are on those leases.
If you believe the resource center is one used for full-time instruction, again, you can forget all of those addresses because none of them are.
If you define a resource center as a place which provides information, equipment, and support, then I need to go back to my office and I will give you
document that will look like the yellow pages.
Because for us, our resource centers are where our students gather to learn, be it restaurants, parks, community centers, senior homes, grocery stores, libraries, student homes, etc.
If you want to shut down all of our resource centers, you need to include Balboa Park Museum, San Diego Zoo,
None of our regions and either charter school is large enough to be a standalone school and really should be a countywide benefit.
Due to the politics of education in San Diego County, we would be denied without the option to appeal to the state.
Please approve the waivers today and support AB 950, which will open up opportunities for countywide benefit charters and put our time and public funds back to the students, not legal firms.
Thank you.
Does that conclude the public testimony?
Board Member Rucker, who was our liaison on these waivers.
Okay, so again, I want to make sure in offering to this waiver on Waiver 21 that I again commend the staff for the work that was done, not only to reach out to the districts, but to also check in with and work through with each of the resource centers.
And so they had a clear understanding of what all five conditions would be.
The CDE is recommending approval of this waiver with the added conditions that were explained by Cindy.
a copy to include a copy of the transition plan and to include the extra requirements for the fifth condition as well as to make sure that the plan is provided to each of the districts plus the county office.
So I'm recommending approval of this waiver.
That's my motion.
Second.
All right.
Any further board discussion of these waivers?
If not, those in favor, raise your hands.
All right.
That's unanimously approved.
I'm advised we cannot begin the public hearing till nine o'clock.
And so we will take a four minute break and resume promptly at nine.
And we're going to come back with agenda item 16.
Agenda item 16.
Yes, 16.
Okay, the board will reconvene.
I have six members and I understand that we had a
lack of clarity on our prior vote on one of the waiver issues.
So the, we have gotten a corrected motion, which satisfies the legal conditions in a more precise way.
And Board Member Rucker will read the amended motion to one we already approved to make sure it's legally precise.
And she will read it now.
And then we will ask for a revote.
Thank you.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
I'm moving a recommendation to approve Waiver 18 and Waiver 19 with the CDE recommendation, plus the ERATA that was noted and explained by department staff to include the correction of the Resource Center addresses and the districts that would be notified as part of the waiver transition process, plus the addition of the fifth condition of the waiver policy.
Second.
All right.
Any public comment on this motion?
Do we need?
Seeing none, all those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay.
It's now approved in an appropriate way.
And so now we're ready for item 16, the charter school concerning the Grossmont Union High School District.
And Cindy Chan will present for the board and the department.
So good morning again.
So we have six public hearings and all of them, each of them are very different.
And so I'm going to present, there's a few quite long.
This one is the only one of its kind today that's an establishment, which is the more common one that we usually present to you.
So this is
an establishment of a new school that was denied locally.
So item 16 is an appeal by Grosmont Secondary School to establish a new charter school, which was denied by the Grosmont Union High School District and the San Diego County Board of Education.
So pursuant to statute, petitioners for a charter school that had been denied at the local level may petition the State Board of Education for approval subject to certain conditions.
The CDE staff have received the Grossmont petition on February 1st, 2017.
We've reviewed the petition documents and all the information submitted.
And based on this review, the CDE recommends that the State Board hold a public hearing and thereafter approve with technical amendments and one condition.
the request to establish Grossmont under the oversight of the State Board for a five-year term effective July 1, 2017 through June 30, 2022.
The department's recommendation includes the following condition that the Grossmont Secondary School Board shall approve and submit a balanced budget to the CDE, which includes a 5% reserve as required by the State Board,
if the actual transfer of funds is not equivalent to the $600,000 of cash that is included in the Grossmont financial statements as presented with the charter petition.
So I'll give you a little bit more detail on that toward the end of my presentation.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools considered the Grossmont Petition at its April 5th meeting and unanimously voted to approve CDE's recommendation that the State Board approve the Grossmont Petition with the technical amendments and condition proposed by the CDE.
Grossmont will provide an independent study homeschool setting with a focus on providing personalized and rigorous academic experience for its pupils, hire, develop, and maintain a highly qualified faculty and staff, and provide a supportive and safe environment.
Grossmount proposes to serve 360 pupils in grade 7 through grade 12 in 2017-18, its first year of operation, expanding to 520 pupils in grade 7 through grade 12 in 2020-21, fourth year of operation, in an independent study homeschool program.
Grossmont proposes to operate three resource centers located within the boundaries of the Grossmont Union High School District that currently operate under the Charter School of San Diego, a charter school authorized by the San Diego Unified School District.
So as noted in the earlier discussion of the waivers resulting from the Anderson decision, in order to ensure compliance with the court opinion, a charter school resource center must operate within the boundaries of its authorizing school district.
So that's the case for this one.
This is an existing resource center program that's operated by another charter school in order to come into compliance with Anderson.
providing a petition to Grossmont in order for that resource center to be compliant and continue to operate within the district boundaries.
So the petition was submitted to Grossmont in October 2016 and was denied and then moved forward on appeal.
We reviewed the gross MUT petition and supporting documents and find that it meets the standard and criteria requirements and provides a reasonably comprehensive description of the required elements with our recommended technical amendments.
And looking at the budget, we reviewed the multi-year fiscal plan, which we note included unsubstantiated resources.
So specifically a $600,000 beginning cash balance with no details or narrative.
And just to note,
On when we do our fiscal review, we do an independent review of the budget and we use assumptions and on how we look at the fiscal, different fiscal documents.
We typically exclude what we would call soft money.
So things that aren't entitlements, things that are unsubstantiated resources as this could inflate the charter school's financial position.
So we have a more, I think, a little more conservative approach to the budget usually.
For Grossmont, excluding the cash reduces their projected reserves and fund balance to a level that's not fiscally viable for the first year of operation.
So in response to that, before the ACCS meeting on March 30th, the Board of Student Success Programs Incorporated, which is a DBA for Adeo Charter School, the Charter School of San Diego, and Laurel Preparatory Academy, approved a resolution that upon confirmation of the listed resource center's positive net balance of funds and the granting of a duly authorized charter petition,
Gross amount shall receive no less than roughly 1.4 million dollars.
We find that the condition which we have actually modified from the ACCS item, it was a little stronger and we've modified it now to kind of recognize this board resolution in part.
But we still feel that the condition we're proposing is necessary.
It's because the transfer of funds we find is contingent on both the granting of a charter petition and also that the positive net balance of funds from the Charter School of San Diego's resource centers must be confirmed.
In a review of the Charter School of San Diego's prior year annual financial audit report, the individual resource centers are not identified separately, only the charter school as a whole.
So even the audit doesn't recognize the resource centers as separate entities from the school.
Confirmation of the net balance of Charter School San Diego's funds for the period ending June 30th of the current year would be confirmed presumably after the end of the current fiscal year.
And additionally, if Grossmont is approved by the State Board, the effective date of the Charter School begins July 1, 2017.
Thus, Charter School does not exist for the transfer of funds to occur at this time or prior to that date.
So for the purpose of fiscal prudence, the department's recommending the condition requiring the Grossmont Board to approve and submit a balanced budget to the department that includes a 5% reserve if the actual transfer of funds is not equivalent to the $600,000 cash that's included in the Grossmont financial statements.
In summary, we find that the Grossmont petition is consistent with sound educational practice.
The petition provides a reasonably comprehensive description of the multiple required elements, noting that some do require a technical amendment.
However, we did note that we find that Grossmont may not be demonstrably likely to successfully implement the program because it's not clear that the financial plan presented by the petitioner includes a sufficient reserve in the first year of operation.
As I've noted, the first year budget is dependent on the transfer of cash, which may not be confirmed and may not occur until after the end of the current fiscal year.
So therefore, we recommend that you hold a public hearing and approve the petition to establish Grossmont under the oversight of the State Board with the proposed condition and technical amendments.
I believe the petitioner, the district and the county are here to address the Board.
I can answer any questions you have.
Thank you.
Okay.
Are there technical questions?
The way we run these hearings is that we first hear from Cindy, as she just did.
Then we have technical questions from the board.
Then we open the public hearing for 10 minutes of each side.
Then we hear the public comment after the public hearing and then we deliberate on our decision.
So are there technical questions here that from our presentation that anybody would like to clarify just to make sure we understand what she said?
Hearing none.
Okay.
Then I'm going to declare the public hearing open.
Both sides have 10 minutes.
And so we'll start with the Grossmont.
You're the group that is submitting the petition, right?
Correct.
So you'll begin and then we'll have the opponents.
We'll have 10 minutes later.
Good morning, President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson and board members.
My name is Wade Ashbrenner and I am the lead petitioner for the Grossmont Secondary School.
I'd first like to thank the CDE staff and ACCS for their recommendation to approve this charter.
We agree to the technical amendment and have put a process in place to cure the one condition.
The Grossmont Secondary School was developed as part of a comprehensive compliance plan and the petition was submitted in September of 2016 to the Grossmont Union High School District.
Is the slide advancing?
Okay.
I can't really tell where it is.
Let me see here.
There we go.
All right.
Thank you.
As I said, all three resource centers contained within the petition are in the boundaries of the Grossmont Union High School District.
The resource centers were operating during the Charter School of San Diego's last renewal in 2012.
The Charter School of San Diego established the resource centers within the Grossmont Union High School District boundaries in compliance with CDE guidance on the location of non-classroom based
charter school resource centers, and at no point was there a definitive law expressly prohibiting the location of resource centers prior to the Anderson decision.
The Grossmont Secondary School will be governed by the Board of the Audeo Charter Schools Corporation.
Audeo Charter Corporation is an independent 501c3 nonprofit organization that directly operates its charter schools.
The Audeo Corporate Board is directly responsible for the success of its charter schools and within the scope of oversight of the State Board of Education.
Audeo Corporate Board further complies with the Brown Act in its meetings, the California Public Records Acts in its document, and the Political Reform Act in its conflict of interest provisions.
For several years now, our schools have disaggregated our financial data by resource center in order to calculate a net result of operations for each resource center.
To clarify the financial plan for the Grossmont Secondary School and part of the process for clearing the condition, the governing board of the Charter School of San Diego has passed a board resolution to transfer the net result of operations for the two resource centers
in the petition to the Grossmont Secondary School to continue seamless operation of the Resource Center.
As Ms.
Tan stated, approximately $1.4 million.
And I have a copy of the resolution for the board members.
Financial and compliance audits have consistently found no exceptions since the Charter School of San Diego's founding in 1994.
And the school has consistently earned 100% funding under SB 740 for multiple cycles.
In 2015, members of the Grossmont Secondary School team were instrumental in the Charter School of San Diego being awarded the Malcolm Baldrige National Quality Award in the Education category.
This is the nation's highest presidential honor for performance excellence through innovation, improvement, and visionary leadership.
This was the first time the award was presented to a single school, and most importantly, a charter school in the Baldrige Award's 28-year history.
The Charter School of San Diego began serving students in the communities of East San Diego County in 2002.
In the fall of 2009, the leadership of the Charter School of San Diego submitted the Magna Carta charter petition to the Grossmont Union High School District.
The Grossmont District denied the charter.
At the time, legal interpretation supported the location of the resource centers within the district boundaries, so no appeal was sought.
In 2012, the Charter School of San Diego was renewed by the San Diego Unified School District for a fifth charter term.
In fact, the Charter School Office for San Diego Unified School District sent a letter of good standing to Grossmont Superintendent Timothy Glover in support of the petition.
As far as our students are concerned, from 2011 to 2016, the Charter School of San Diego decreased its overall dropout rate from 4.6% to 2.5%.
This is an outstanding achievement given that the majority of our students enrolled behind in credits, not on track to graduate in four years.
Some of them are two grade levels behind in English and up to three grade levels behind in math.
The current year information for dropout rate on DataQuest by the CDE is that the Charter School of San Diego is posting a 2.5% dropout rate for school year 2015-2016.
In addition, the demand in East San Diego County has shown that we have served over 500 students annually for the last five to six years.
And currently the enrollment at the two resource centers is over 300 students.
We are a non-classroom based independent study program designed to support students, develop confidence in their abilities and lead them to a successful high school experience.
To do so, we have a six year Walsh accreditation at the Charter School of San Diego, comprehensive course lists approved by both the University of California and the National Collegiate Athletic Association.
This allows the school to fulfill its mission to transform lives.
Students choose to enroll with us for many reasons, mostly because they've not been successful in the traditional school system or they're looking for a personalized education plan.
Our student demographic trends indicate that about 65% of our students in middle and high school are credit deficient, 73% are socioeconomically disadvantaged, 76% represent a minority student population, and additionally, 19% of our students have IEPs or identified as special education.
Some of our program highlights is our comprehensive English language development program with both an integrated and designated ELD program components.
The integrated ELD program is designed to ensure that English learners can access core curriculum, build literacy skills while engaged in a rigorous curriculum aligned to common core standards.
All courses are customized based on student skill level and interest and curriculum is scaffolded and language supports are embedded in each course.
The designated ELD program is designed to ensure that our English learners are developing the critical English language skills, knowledge, and abilities needed for content learning in English.
Our six courses are fully aligned to the California ELD standards.
So what are our results?
The majority of our English language students enroll in grades 10 through 12, several grade levels behind in reading and writing skills.
Approximately 95% of our English learner students are at high risk of becoming long-term English learners.
These are students who have not met progress and proficiency targets for reclassification given six or more years of ELD instruction in a traditional setting.
Our results show that 61% of our long-term English learners attained a level of proficiency on the latest CELT results.
The focus of the Grossmont Secondary School is to improve student learning, offer safe learning environment, and provide a highly qualified faculty and staff to our students.
Guiding the design were the lessons learned while the Charter School of San Diego became one of the most successful alternative school accountability model schools, or ASAM, in the state of California.
The Charter School of San Diego had the 23rd highest API score out of approximately 850 ASAM schools.
And in the last
three years of API, we were able to increase our API score by 38%, including significant increases in each of the subgroups published by the state.
The Charter School of San Diego also offers the California Cadet Corps.
The California Cadet Corps received the highest possible rating in state assessment metrics for 2016.
We realized that
The success of our students begins with our teachers, and their base compensation is 5% above that of San Diego Unified School District.
We provide 100% employer-paid medical and dental plans for teachers and all eligible dependents.
Our teacher retention rate for the past three years has averaged over 90%.
Professional development is a major focus of our school, and we have had a great partnership with the San Diego County Office of Ed.
Since January 2013, our teachers have participated in the excess of 10,000 hours of professional development at the county.
As far as community support, parents, students, and teachers have written letters, sent postcards.
You can see the postcards that have been delivered this morning.
We have about 1,500 postcards.
We have 55 additional people traveling to Sacramento today, but the flight out of San Diego this morning was delayed.
So, they're en route here.
So, hopefully, they'll get here before the end of the day.
All right.
So, that's a tremendous amount of support for the school and the program.
So, in closing,
I'd like to share a video of the comments made by Penny Pritzker at last year's Baldrige ceremony.
She's the U.S.
Commerce Secretary and I'd like to respectfully ask for you to approve this charter.
Congratulations to the 2015 Baldrige Award recipients.
Our four honorees have created efficient, effective organizations
that provide exceptional services to customers and support your communities.
As everyone here knows, earning the Baldrige Award is hard.
It requires an organizational commitment to excellence, driven by senior leadership with vision, accomplished by engaged employees, and enabled by a customer-focused culture.
But today's winners were willing to make that commitment.
As a result, they are creating some of America's best products and services that bring value to their customers every day.
To MidwayUSA, Charter School of San Diego, Charleston Area Medical Center Health System, and MidAmerica Transplant, I want to thank each of you
for your dedication and for your leadership.
Together, you embody the fundamental principle at the core of the Baldrige Awards, a never-ending quest for organizational innovation and performance excellence.
Congratulations on this prestigious honor and on your success.
Thank you.
Okay, 10 minutes on the nose.
All right.
So we will now have 10 minutes from the opponents of the charter petition.
Good morning, State Board.
My name is Dr. Tim Glover and I have the good fortune of being the superintendent in the Grossmont Union High School District.
And I'm here as a very grassroots effort to ask that you deny this petition.
Don't have a glitzy PowerPoint.
I don't have any of that here for you.
I'm not a corporation.
I'm not a McCharter.
I'm a simple school district with 17,000 students and an additional 5,000 students in two charters that belong to our school district.
We're very authentic and we're very grassroots.
I'm here to talk very simply with you today.
And it's really about transparency, local control of school districts and who we serve.
And when you hear this story about the charter being dropped off at the school district, yes, it was set on the counter at the front counter of the school district.
And at the time I received that charter, I immediately called the charter petitioners and said, hey, is there a way I could get an extension on the timeline to review this thoroughly and also to allow an opportunity for an elected board, a newly elected board to weigh in to approve it?
And what was very frustrating is all the conversations were positive on the phone.
And then the very first communication I received from the petitioner is a four-page, take a deep breath, a four-page litigation letter saying they're going to sue us.
So I want you to take a moment and think about collaboration, reaching out, being locally connected, and all of us serving our children.
And that's the first communication I get from the charter school that's petitioning to become a collaborative member of our school district in that.
We thoroughly went through the process of reviewing the charter.
We had a much different finding about the English language process.
The program they cited in their petition to us didn't even cover high school student age groups.
So it's very interesting to me to see how this has been evolving and being manipulated through the process.
So I would just ask to encourage you that despite what you see up there, that's not what we saw.
And I think it's also very interesting when both the school district, the county where it will be located, both deny it and then it comes here and it's all of a sudden going to be okay.
And then $600,000, if I didn't have $600,000 to be explained where it was coming from, there'd be serious questions.
And I hope you do take serious concerns about where that's coming from.
I'll turn it over to our Deputy Superintendent Scott Patterson and then our Attorney Dennis Wolverine-Kelley, Sarah Sutherland.
Thank you.
Good morning, President Kirsten, honorable members of the State Board of Education.
I am Scott Patterson.
I'm the Deputy Superintendent for the Grosmont Union High School District.
State Board of Education should deny the Grosmont Secondary School appeal for the following reasons.
The charter school has been operating illegally within our district boundaries since at least 2009.
The charter school was on notice of this fact back in 2007 from the California Department of Education and in 2009 from our district.
San Diego Unified, its chartering entity, has also required the charter to come into compliance with the law.
Grosmont Secondary School is simply a new name for the same charter they have been operating illegally with notice in an attempt to paper over this grave problem.
Grosmont Secondary School is not associated with the Grosmont Union High School District and its name is misleading at best.
Grosmont and the San Diego County Office denied the Grosmont Secondary School for good and valid reasons.
and a successful appeal granted by the SBE would be contrary and disrespectful of the detailed review and analysis conducted by the local agencies.
Those agencies who would be forced to coexist with a charter that's been operating illegally with notice and over our objection for nearly 10 years.
Anderson, the court case, has brought final clarity to an issue that had been intentionally misconstrued
by the Charter for this nearly 10-year period.
To thwart this clarity on an issue we have contended to the Charter all along and to reward the Charter for that disingenuousness is wrong and unjust.
Finally, I know from personal professional experience that trying to exercise oversight over a Charter which is simply a fragment of an overall corporate entity
not all of which is under the oversight of one agency, which this charter is, represents a fool's errand as it's impossible to clearly see the assets and the liabilities that are attributable to that fragment as they really belong to the corporate body without clear attribution or ownership by the charter being overseen.
Thank you.
Morning, President Kirst, members of the board.
I'll be brief.
I just want to point out that the petition entirely lacks transparency.
It's misleading and fails to disclose a multitude of details that are incredibly relevant to this board's ability to oversee them if approved.
This board is already an oversight agency for this very charter, but you can't figure out where the $600,000, your staff can't figure out the $600,000.
That's a problem.
They already have two oversight agencies.
They actually operate at 34 locations.
There's the Charter School of San Diego, Ardeo, Ardeo 2, Laurel Prep, then there's an Altus Network.
It's really unclear from the petition how all of these corporations interact with one another, how people's salaries get set, where the board meets.
There's no parent involvement.
There's no parent members on the board.
This petition was not
generated because there was a need in Grossmont that they were trying to fulfill with the Grossmont community in mind.
The story has changed between the time the petition was submitted to Grossmont in September to now, so I really would encourage you to, if you have not already, do a detailed review of the record and the findings that were made below because much effort went into that.
The last thing I will point out is
The lack of transparency creates many, many issues that we grapple with locally that I think are not visible from Sacramento.
And to the extent you are going to approve this charter, I think you need to come down and see what is actually going on because
We see here, Charter School of San Diego gets a Baldrige Award from the U.S.
Department of Commerce.
Well, is that Grossmont Secondary School or is it not?
Who paid for everyone to fly up here?
Where did that money come from?
If Grossmont brought all of its teachers up here, we'd have to do that at a public board meeting.
And that's not how decisions about financing are made here.
Their lead executive, who was on the board till January of this year, the petition proposes for her to continue to be on the board of Audeo, makes twice as much as Cindy Martin.
per ADA.
Almost $400,000 in 2015 was reported in income for her.
Although she didn't work for the charter school, she worked for their quote-unquote administrative provider, Altus.
So I would really encourage you to
scratch the surface and think about the transparency that is essential for public school operations that allow parents and students to know and participate in the process of deciding how their children are educated and by
changing Charter School of San Diego to Grossmont Secondary School, but it otherwise staying exactly the same.
It will do nothing other than create more confusion and entangle this board in substantial litigation that is already happening in the county over these very issues.
So on that note, I would encourage you to deny this petition.
These
Petitioners already have charter schools.
They already have authorization to operate charter schools under your oversight, under San Diego Unified's oversight, and another petition is entirely unnecessary.
They showed you a chart of their operations.
That was just part of it.
It really looks more like this.
They are showing you one part.
So how do you oversee?
Who oversees this?
No one.
That's the problem.
We respectfully request for you to deny this petition.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'm now going to close the public hearing and we will have public comment.
Staff will call the list.
Thank you.
May the following people please line up at the podium.
Christopher Carpenter, Austin Webster, Felizna Steffens, Eula Steffens, Michael Hanna, James Flannoy, Sai Sagiano, David Gaiotti, Brooke Hatfield, Joe Peluso, Jeanette Perez, and Michelle Lynch.
Good afternoon or good morning, board members, President Kirsten and Superintendent Torlakson's representative here.
My name is Christopher Carpenter from Young Menin Corps representing Grossmont Secondary School.
I wish to make a couple of notes.
First, I wanted to express appreciation for staff and their thorough review of the petition and discussing with us any issues that may be there.
We are fully accepting of all the conditions and technical amendments there.
I wish to point out that we did not threaten to sue
Grossmont Union High School District, we provided the notice of the statutory timeframes necessary and the fact that if we were not heard, the school might have to be put out of operation for a period of time.
And we have hundreds and hundreds of students, thousands over the past years that have attended this school.
And our focus is to ensure that that education continues.
Lastly, the organization as presented in the petition is exactly as it exists now.
Ms.
Sutherland is operating on previous information or information that is incorrect.
I'll note that the district has never reached out to us for any clarification when we submitted our petitions and they did in fact try to sue us in 2009.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Austin Webster.
I've been part of the charter school of San Diego for a year and a half.
I am a senior graduate.
When I started in traditional school, despite having an IEP saying that I can have extra time on homework and assignments and on tests, I didn't find that I was getting the real help that I needed and started failing in all my classes.
So I decided to come to the Charter School of San Diego.
It has been the best decision I've ever made.
I'm supported by the teachers who have really helped me through my high school struggles and have gotten me where I am today.
Attending the Charter School of San Diego was the best decision for me because now I am able to go at my own pace.
And even when I stumble or take extra time, the teachers are there to help me get back on track.
Once again, I cannot thank Ms.
Road and Ms.
Frank and the rest of the staff at the Charter School of San Diego enough for everything that they have done to get me to the point where I am right now.
I hope that you will approve this petition so other students may feel the same way.
Thank you.
Hello.
My name is Valencia and I'm currently a special education student at Charter School of San Diego.
When I was at a traditional public school I couldn't focus in a hectic environment and my grades started to suffer.
That's when I started to hang around with the wrong crowd and knew I needed a change.
I yet again tried a traditional school but my family and I lived far away and it took four hours to get to and from school every day.
I was chronically late in my grades and started to fall.
That's when I found CSSD which I love.
It meets my needs and provides a better environment for me.
Thanks to the flexible schedule I can work independently.
I also have access to fantastic teachers who really help us meet our goals and find success.
I especially like the Pathway Program because it helped us find a path and success in life.
I am excelling in a quiet environment I'm still to share after starting out from behind that I would graduate this year on time.
Good morning.
My name is Eula Stephens.
I'm Felicia Stephens' grandmother.
Her mother and I thought that she would never make it through graduation.
Excuse me, I'm nervous.
but she got motivated when she found CSST.
It was her teacher's encouragement that inspired her to excel in school.
Without them, a lot of kids wouldn't be able to make it.
Would you please approve the petition to keep this school for the kids who are
or behind like my granddaughter was so.
They have the opportunity to make it like she did.
Please, you know, keep the kids off of the streets and then keep them out of trouble if you, you know, kindly, excuse me because I'm nervous.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Michael Hanna.
I'm the Military Advisor and the Cadet Corps Commandant for the Charter School of San Diego.
I just received an update.
I wanted to let you all know that our members who are on the flight are here.
Unfortunately, they're outside.
They're not being let in, but they made it, so we're happy they're here with us.
So our Cadet Corps program is an applied leadership program in which students become more aware of their potential and better prepared for the opportunities the world has to offer them by accepting challenge and having a growth mindset.
The Cadet Corps is one of the many tools that our school uses to engage our students and allows us to contribute to our mission of transforming lives.
As such, I've been fortunate enough to witness firsthand the transformation that these students experience.
As you'll soon hear from two cadets that I'm very proud of,
Our cadets have remarkable stories that illustrate how access to the Charter School of San Diego and the Cadet Corps program have changed their lives.
I believe that it is critical to these students and future students that they continue to have access to our program and I urge you to approve our petition.
Thank you.
Good morning.
I'm Cadet Staff Sergeant Flannery.
I've been attending the Charter School of San Diego since 2015.
And I came here for more individualized attention from teachers.
I came from a traditional high school where I was falling behind.
And I became a cadet in the California Cadet Corps in the same year of 2015.
And I'm more active in my community now.
And I care for others more than I can care for myself and my team.
And I've learned to never give up.
I learned that failure should be seen as motivation to get back up and try again.
The charter school has done so much for me, and these teachers have impacted my life in such a positive way.
They're role models that I can look up to and they can show students like me how to be young adults and how to live in the real world.
I'm proud to say that I've graduated and I'm following my career in the U.S.
Navy.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Saitupu El-Sangiel and I am currently a graduating senior at the Charter School of San Diego.
I've attended the Charter School of San Diego since the sixth grade due to the fact that my mom wanted me to go to a safer alternative for school.
But the Charter School of San Diego didn't just offer me a safety blanket.
It also gave me the opportunity to gain leadership skills.
I participated in the California Cadet Corps where I was able to push myself outside of my comfort zone and grow as a leader.
I competed in the statewide academic competition and won first place, the highest competitive award in the California Cadet Corps.
Without the Charter School of San Diego, my accomplishments wouldn't have been possible.
The teachers understand that not all children learn the same way or go through the same things.
And though it may not seem like it at times, we as kids appreciate this more than anything else.
The Charter School of San Diego has been a door opener for many kids and the last door open for some.
This school needs to continue to help children grow and succeed, as it has always done, no matter what obstacles we may face.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is David Goyette.
I'm a teacher with the Charter School of San Diego.
I'm proud to speak to you today in support of the Grossmont Secondary Petition.
In my 18 years as a teacher, I've seen firsthand how some traditional charter schools struggle to support their instructional staff and students.
By contrast, our CSSD support staff and professional development programs ensure that our teachers have all the tools and training to guide their students toward success.
CSSD teachers are compensated 5% above the local district's pay scale.
Our generous benefits package gives teachers and their families peace of mind.
Our classrooms are well equipped with the latest technology and materials.
As a teacher who began as a classroom assistant and has served as a teacher representative on our school's board of directors, I can attest to the robust support teachers receive every day in our program.
I'm thankful to be a part of an organization that honors its teachers so that we can put our students first.
Thank you for your time.
Good morning.
My name is Brooke Hatfield and I'm a second year education specialist and Teach for America core member.
When I decided to become a teacher, I wanted to be part of an organization that fought every single day for the undeniable reality that every student outcome matters.
That is why I joined Teach for America.
I quickly realized the strong alignment between what the Charter School of San Diego does for students and families and the mission, vision, and values of Teach for America San Diego.
At CSSD, we individualize every student's educational foundation and serve an entire population of exceptional, resilient students who simply require a unique educational option to achieve their personal and academic goals.
I am proud to be part of a team that works relentlessly to be stewards of educational equity and who maintains the unwavering conviction that every student deserves access to an education that will foster self-determined transformation and achievement.
Ladies and gentlemen, good morning.
My name is Joe Peluso.
I am not an educator.
I'm a retired Navy veteran of 52 years of service with the U.S.
Navy.
I served in submarines and naval aviation.
I am here with my grandson, Austin Webster, who you've already talked to, and I got to put my cheaters on to read this.
He's a graduating senior at Charter School of San Diego.
Charter School personnel I have interfaced with over the years, and my wife has been very active in this, are truly dedicated to the mission of providing a quality education to students that need more direct contact with their teachers.
as well as being able to study one subject at a time and concentrate on that.
Not every student does well in conventional schools.
He didn't.
Austin was one of those.
Charter School fills that gap for Austin and other students by providing the one-on-one assistance that students such as Austin need to be competitive and successful.
As they transition to adulthood, this, in my opinion,
is the core mission of Charter School of San Diego and they are meeting that resistance exceptionally well.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Jeanette Perez and I have been a teacher at the Charter School of San Diego for 23 years.
During this time, I've seen firsthand the opportunities this school offers students so they can be successful, productive students.
Just this week, one of my students became the first to graduate in her family.
This has been the case for hundreds of my students.
One month ago, one of my students who had been homeless for most of her life finally got her high school diploma.
Unfortunately, this type of situation
is not outside the norm with our student population.
One of the best things about CSSD is the design, resources, and special training we are provided which allows us to meet these students' needs and move them forward.
In fact, in March, I was honored to receive the 2017 Heart Vision California Charter Teacher of the Year Award.
Because of the great work we do at Charter School of San Diego, please approve the Grossmont Secondary Charter so that we can continue to transform lives.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Andra Donovan.
I'm General Counsel for San Diego Unified School District.
I heard someone say that we provided a letter of good standing to Charter School of San Diego.
I want to make very clear that is in no way an endorsement of the Grossmont Secondary School, nor is it an endorsement of the Charter School of San Diego, and it was not intended to be used as such.
During, it is true simply that we have authorized out of School of San Diego and we have not revoked their charter.
However, you also heard Mr. Patterson talk about the fact that we have identified self-dealing by the board president to the tune of close to $400,000 in salaries that she authorized for herself.
We identified property transfers publicly,
paid for property transferred to a private corporation that had to be refit first.
And we identified multiple illegal facilities that needed to be closed.
I've heard the phrase used repeatedly in this room, come into compliance with the Anderson decision.
The Anderson decision is not what needs to be complied with.
It is the law.
And it has been the law since 2002.
And for Trump to come here and tell you that they didn't know that is patently untrue.
Thank you.
Good morning, Lorraine Richards, California Teachers Association.
CTA opposes this petition.
Democracy is practiced at the local elections for school board and the school district represents those students.
Greater accountability and transparency with finances are definitely needed in this case.
Local control is essential to maximize the education of all students.
I would also like to mention the adjustment to one minute.
A public comment is unreasonable for many that travel to give support or oppose items on the waivers.
Thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
We have a 20 plus year relationship with the leaders of this organization and believe it's one of the best managed charter organizations that we've run into.
They also have some of the strongest balance sheets and financial management practices that we've run into.
We have zero concern about their financial sustainability and support the staff and ACCS recommendation to approve.
Thank you.
Good morning, Michelle Lynch on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
I just want to echo what Eric said.
We've worked with this organization for years.
We have strong confidence in not only their academics, but also in their transparency and in their finances.
They did a great job of coming in early to come into compliance with the Anderson decision.
The law before the Anderson decision was fairly commonly interpreted as even CDE interpreted as allowing these things.
So, we do believe it was a great practice of audio to come in or correspond to come in so early and submit this new petition.
We ask you to approve them today.
Thank you.
Can we have...
That's a new one.
Okay.
Does that conclude the public comment?
So let's have some board member discussion on this.
The board member charter liaisons may want to start this.
Okay.
This is a situation where
This organization has already been in existence.
They were resource centers.
They are coming into compliance with the Anderson case by creating a new charter school.
This is one of the transition ways that resource center type schools will be taking over the next year.
So we'll see, no doubt, more of these types of new creation of charter schools.
I think this is a sound petition.
The ACCS voted for it.
CDE has voted for it.
They have a very good track record.
To win the Baldrige Award is pretty amazing right there.
That's a real coup.
I don't have concerns about the financial situation.
I know that Cindy takes a very
careful look at it, and she's very well versed in the financial structures of these types of organizations.
So I have a great deal of confidence that this new charter school will continue to serve kids very, very well.
Okay, and a comment by Board Member Williams.
The only thing I would add is that, is that I don't think anyone, well, we weren't looking forward to all the changes and the waivers and the process that we were going to need to deal with, with the Shasta decision.
And I think that the policy that the staff helped put together and legal help put together was a fair one, a good one to give a year.
waiver for these schools to figure out what they were going to do next.
This is one of the first schools to come through and because of that, I think the CDE, in particular, with the State Board staff, looked at this very, very carefully.
because it would be a, you know, a first time that we've seen this kind of transition.
And I have absolute confidence in the staff's recommendation and their thorough review of this.
Okay, is there any more board member comment on this?
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
I have more of a question because it may be a very basic one.
One, my concern is never really with the heart of the school, which is the teachers and the students, but the structures that are coming before us are becoming a little more and more complex and it's harder for me to understand, though I work with charter schools as affiliates, you know, these are becoming a lot more corporate-like and it's always hard for me to keep up with what's what and who's who.
So, I would appreciate a little bit of a breakdown of how one of the flow maps that they showed the structure just looked humongous.
So, what is this charter school in relation to all those other pieces?
And then the five percent reserve, the set aside, again, this is maybe a basic question, but how long do we give them to show proof of that five percent?
Well, let me answer the second one first, because I don't have the actual chart.
I just want to say I don't have, we can pull up the org chart, but it didn't look, the one in the petition doesn't look like that.
So I, yeah, it's.
I'm not sure we'd have to look at the larger one.
I don't know if that one possibly is more of the organization if they're part of a CMO.
Maybe it's a bigger structure, but in terms of the one we looked at, the governance structure was a little more, it was smaller and a little more self-contained.
So we can pull up and look at what was in the petition, but just
Oh.
OK.
Yeah.
So this is one of Altus charter schools.
So that sounds like that's more of the of the larger organization.
So.
I just saw this one today.
Okay, so let me, we'll look at that and just get back to you on the first question.
What was on the reserve?
As far as that, I mean, we give a little more flexibility to charter schools in their first year of operation.
I mean, they're still trying to get their feet landed and the money hasn't flowing in.
And so we typically give them the year.
You'll see one at the end of the day where it's one of the newer ones and it's in a position now where there's a little bit of a struggle.
But we allowed it to operate a year to make sure that it did get its enrollment.
I mean, any new charter school to make sure that it's getting its pupils in, there's sometimes delays in opening.
So it affects the enrollment of the charter school.
We don't even issue, you know,
Usually it may be a lot of concern, but we kind of monitor their budget in phases because the law requires a charter school, just like school districts, to report at different times during the year.
So there's the interim reporting.
So we kind of track schools monthly, especially ones that might be struggling.
But typically we wait for a first interim, which allows a school to give a first look, maybe like a quarter to a half a year's look of the financials.
And again, everything is on an estimated basis until the point where a school can get its independent auditor in.
So we actually monitor those a little more closely, especially ones that are not at their enrollment level because that drives all of the funding for the charter schools typically.
I mean, the LCFF money is driven by attendance, ADA.
So if we see that enrollment is dropping or enrollment isn't at where it should be, then we monitor more closely and you'll see that in another one.
But in this case,
They're a negative reserve and they're not at zero by our calculations.
They're at about three percent.
So that's not bad, but it's not five.
And the State Board Memorandum of Understanding requires a five percent reserve.
So we would like the charter school in this case, if it's approved, we would want to see that five percent reserve at some point during the year as it's growing and that it can get there by the end of the year.
So we would allow some time, but
probably towards the end of the year, we would issue some sort of notice to them.
Yes.
So we'll go back and look at the org chart and we'll get back to you.
I want to make sure it's the one we looked at.
All right.
Other questions by Board Member Burr.
So first, I just want to say that reinforce, I think, what both Eric Premack said and Michelle Lowe.
This is one of our oldest charter schools.
It goes back to 1994.
It was started as the Charter School of San Diego.
And I think as witnessed by the presentation by the school, one of the most highly regarded one, and certainly by the testimony of the students, one that is very responsive to the needs of the students.
So I just want to commend them for the work they've done over the years.
I guess what I want to talk about is this issue about these resource centers coming on appeal to us.
And Cindy or Nick, this is kind of a question for you guys.
That when I looked at how many waivers we put, I'm concerned about the expectation that we're going to see however many, 20 some odd
petitions come before the state board to be authorized.
And I think at some point, we reach our capacity to do this work in an effective way.
So I guess for me, it's more a statement about, and I've made the statement many times, charters are supposed to be locally authorized.
That's what they're about, to offer the opportunity in the community.
And I would just say based on the conversation between the parties here, there seems to be not a very healthy relationship or a positive relationship there.
So I understand how you got here.
But I just hope that for all of the other resource centers that find themselves in these positions and all of the other school districts that find themselves with resource centers located in their geographic boundaries, that they can find a way to make this work on behalf of students in their communities.
Yeah, I'll second that.
Karen.
So again, I commend the students who came today and spoke about their experiences and the positivity that you're experiencing there.
My question is more on the structure.
And when I think about local control, and I concur with Board Member Burr,
I'm looking at the governing board structure and I'm looking at how can you do local control based on that kind of a structure.
So I was wondering if staff could maybe clarify who the governing board would be and are their parents representing the decisions that are making, especially as we talk about different levels of funding and input.
So that's my question.
Did you hear my question?
Sorry.
And is it one governing board or is there a, what's the structure going to look like?
I can answer that one.
And when we looked at the org chart that we have that's in the petition is this one.
I mean, it looks like it's more because it's blown up, but really it is a mirror image of this.
So somehow these three and the charter school might need to come up and explain that.
These three aren't connected in terms of the chart.
The one that we looked at, the one that's in the petition, is this one that's under Adeo Charter School or Adeo Charter School Incorporated.
And then the new gross month secondary falls under that.
That is a government structure that's in the petition.
This other one, we can't explain this.
They'll have to explain it because there, it looks like maybe there's a common
denominator within the three, but the organizations aren't connected at least into this chart.
They don't connect to each other.
So they'll have to explain that.
But the one we looked at is a component of that.
And then what was the second question?
Oh, there are.
I mean, let me read.
But we do have a technical amendment in that area.
So in the governance structure,
they what they presented was a board of directors and they also have a an area on parent involvement in governance and we didn't feel that it was as robust as it should be so we're asking as a technical amendment specifically how the school ensure that parental involvement in the governance of the charter school beyond what we see are maybe it's a little more limited than what we might see in other petitions
that's currently stated.
So we're asking for them to add a little bit more in terms of parent involvement.
So there is some involvement, but we feel like it maybe should be some more.
So that wasn't a no in that area.
It was more, we think that it was more technical amendment where they can add to that because they already have something there.
We just want it to be explained a little more and expanded a little bit more.
So in terms of the other, I think the Charter School should come up and explain the larger structure because that isn't what's in the petition.
That isn't what's before you today.
Could I clarify one thing on the answer that you just gave?
Is it one board over all of these entities or is there a separate board for the new Grossmont?
Oh, it's, yes, yes, they can explain it.
It looks like there is a board.
I don't know what yes is.
That there is, it's not this other, this other big chart.
There is a separate board that's over the charter school that's actually author over three separate charter schools.
Sweet, this Sweetwater one, Grossmont one, excuse me, is being, is one of them.
Yeah, go ahead.
Hi, Christopher Carpenter, Young Meeting Corp.
representing Gressmont Charter, Gressmont Secondary School.
I want to note that the organizational structure sheet passed out by DWK was created by DWK for their purposes in trying to tear down the school.
It does not reflect the current organization of the school.
Rodeo Charter School is a 501c3 nonprofit corporation, standalone.
It does not have any related board members on it.
Marianne Bixby does not sit on this board.
The Audeo Charter School Corporation will oversee three schools.
That's Audeo Charter School 2, which is approved by this board last year, Grossmont Secondary School, if approved, and then Sweetwater Secondary School, which is also coming up on appeal at your next meeting.
Those three schools will be overseen by Audeo Charter School Incorporated.
The remainder of the organizations are overseeing Charter School of San Diego.
As was referenced, the Charter School of San Diego is an organization that operates Charter School of San Diego, Laurel Preparatory Academy, and
a DAO charter school within the boundaries of San Diego Unified School District.
They are authorized by San Diego Unified School District, those three schools overseen by one board.
So it's a similar structure, just like different petitions, different organization, different board members as well.
Again, the chart before you from DWK with big DWK letters up in the corner is not accurate and does not reflect the current operations of the organization.
Yeah, let me, well, we can question this, but I also want to have the district people come up and explain what Alda's Charter Schools is.
What is that?
I mean,
We're dealing with Odeo.
You know, that is not before us, Altus Charter?
No, Altus Institute does not operate these schools.
It's not an organization involved with these schools.
The school is operated by the school, Grossmont Secondary Charter School, is a part of the Odeo Charter School Corporation, which is the 501c3 corporation that operates that school.
So the
the org chart that's before you that lists just the three organizations with the Adeo Charter School, those three board members, that is the total and complete organization on this petition before you.
Well, I'd like the school district to comment on this since they handed out this chart.
And then I think board member Williams is next and maybe board member Rucker.
Go ahead.
Yes, I will attempt to thank you.
I appreciate the opportunity to respond to your question.
We attempted the petition before you doesn't disclose any of that information, but we were aware of it from being there and knowing who the players are.
And so there is the purpose of the org chart that we developed, which is this was accurate at the time.
It's now changed.
In response to probably findings made in response to the charter.
But what we were trying to illustrate is they, they proposed the charter that just showed the board this.
But then the board doesn't get to see any of this.
And that really impacts a school district's ability to oversee operations.
Altus is a corporation that it was at one point the sole statutory member of all these underlying corporations, which means they get to add and remove board members, merge the corporation.
And they did all have common board members.
And at least until January, Mary Bixby, the lead administrator of this, did sit on all the boards.
In the petition before you, she is
the board president.
That's what it says in the petition.
And so she may not be that now, but that's one of the issues we've been facing is that it's a constantly moving target with information changing.
And every time we try to figure like student success programs was created just last summer.
to separate some of this and this is going to be run by Audeo, but Audeo also operates in San Diego Unified under student success programs.
You know, so that's the confusion that we're having locally trying to figure out who is operating what and when and which students, you know, all the students that came today are at the Charter School of San Diego.
There is, they can, it's an independent study school, so they can continue to do that.
So anyway, that is the problem is that it is very confusing and they represent that it is just this one arm.
But if you do research on the organization, it is not this one arm.
It is this entire organization that no one body is overseeing because the charter has taken the position that the oversight agency only gets to see from here down.
And so if you only get to see from there down, that's how $600,000 goes missing.
because you don't know when it gets transferred up, how it got transferred and then how it gets spent among their various organizations.
And so they're not desegregated in the way that they're representing.
And this chart is made from public information that we could glean that's not in the petition.
Okay.
Thank you.
Board Member Williams is next.
Well, this conversation has gone off in a direction that was different from what I originally raised my hand for.
But I will say in response to member Burr's comment first and then I'll say something here in response to member Burr's comment about
what might happen with all of the resource centers that applied for a waiver.
My understanding is there's a wide variety of approaches that they will take.
They're not all capable of turning the resource center into a new charter appeal or don't necessarily even want to do that.
They may relocate, they may move a different building, they may combine students at a building.
I am not at this point in time, unless Cindy tells me that, unless Cindy knows something I don't know, I'm not expecting that 20 of them are going to come up with, you know, with new petitions for new schools.
So that's not something that I'm concerned about.
I do hope given this conversation that just occurred that either the school or Cindy can address the current organizational chart.
I do know that the word corporation sounds like a private for-profit business, but it is clear on this that it's a 501c3.
It's a non-profit organization.
that is at the head of it.
I see that there are three different possible schools here.
Cindy, do you have anything that you want to add to that discussion about the organizational chart?
It may well have been, I'm going to speculate here,
It may well have been that once the Shasta decision was made and this group needed to make a decision about how it was going to address, come into compliance and still serve its students well, that it did some restructuring in terms of board members and the sole statutory and that kind of thing.
So that could be, well be the difference between what the district saw before and what we're seeing now.
I think the only difference on this one, this one handout is there's one of the board members is not missing from what we looked at.
So there might have been a change in structure.
But again, it's been months and months since that petition was submitted locally.
So there might have been a change.
Other than that, it appears to be the same, even this larger one.
I mean, these are separate 501c3s that appear to be operating their own network of charter schools.
And then I think the chart is finding a common denominator between them.
But the one that the petition before you is part of Odeo Charter School.
So that would be the one that actually controls the school.
And that's what this one looks like.
So what's in the petition we found to be sufficient.
other than the parent involvement.
But again, you know, it's part of oversight.
If it's approved, we definitely will keep our eyes open to this and ask a lot of questions on the governance.
So we are finding more complicated, I think, compositions.
Yes.
Board Member Rucker.
Okay.
So we have several more hearings today.
And I thought this was going to be the easy one.
I was, I thought I understood this charter until everybody started talking, arguing about it.
So I do have just a couple of questions and I think they are simple yes, no questions.
So I do have a question for the charter, for the Audeo Charter School representatives.
Okay.
So I do think this is a yes, no question.
You have, you do have a school, you do have a governing board.
Yes.
Are there parents on your governing board?
Not at this time.
So that's a no.
There are no current parents of students, but there are parents.
All right.
No parents of current students.
I'm lost.
No.
All right.
So... I missed it.
I don't know what he said.
What did he say?
Yes or no?
He said not at this time.
They are parents, but they're not parents of students at the schools.
Ah, okay.
Is that correct?
Correct.
All right.
So you do have parents on the board, but they're not parents of the students who are attending the schools that are being governed by this board.
And you said not at this time.
Does not at this time mean in some way you're addressing what we heard Ms.
Chan say about your governance plan concerning parent involvement?
Could you, in like a couple of sentences, say what that plan is?
I don't need a dissertation.
I just want to know, are you planning to make sure that parents end up on the governing board?
They currently have input through the LCAP process, decision making for finances.
I'm not always impressed by that, but go ahead.
So there is mechanisms in place and then that working with CDE and staff to cure that technical amendment, a way for there to be parental input on the board will be created.
And who is it that actually has composed the members of this board?
Were they appointed?
Were they selected by the parents in these schools or by some other way?
They are appointed.
By whom?
By the board member itself, but it... Wait a minute, wait.
Yeah.
Who are you?
My name is Selena Lippi and I didn't mean any disrespect when I asked that question.
So for those who thought I was being smart, but I was not.
What is your position?
Yes.
I'm the chief business officer and the treasurer of the corporation of the Odeo Corporation.
So you said for the people who are on the Odeo Charter School, they were appointed by the board?
They are the board itself.
They are recruited.
By whom?
by the leadership of the Odeo Corporation.
And then they submit their information, their resume, and then it is discussed by the board members and the board members accepts the appointment.
Okay, so what are the qualifications?
Qualifications are minimally going to be expertise in either education, business, HR, something that would positively affect the organization, and then a commitment to promoting and carrying forth public education in California through specifically operating public charter schools.
So do those qualifications have to be altered in some way for you to be able to appoint a parent from one of these, of one of the children at these schools?
No.
Okay.
Any other questions?
Are we ready for a motion on this?
All right.
Karen Valdez.
I'm new at this second day on the job.
But my question is at the local level, when we've had petitions come to my district, if you will, we could only really base everything on the petition itself.
Is that still how this is that the description?
So, for example, of your board, whatever you've described in the petition is what we're discussing today, not promises for future.
Is that still correct?
Except for the conditions.
Yeah.
Okay.
I just wanted to understand.
Thanks.
Right.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
No questions for you.
Just a general request that I've been asking.
I need tutorials.
I need handouts.
I need something that teaches me about these new structures that are coming before us so that I could better frame my thinking when I'm reading these proposals.
It's getting increasingly complicated.
to really understand how this is an issue or a matter of local control, who's involved.
Again, my concern is never the students.
Obviously, clearly they're benefiting and the teachers have the passion for it.
But just understanding how this takes place in a larger context structure is becoming increasingly difficult.
And I think that as folks that are tasked with approving these charter schools, we should have that understanding very clearly and upfront.
Thank you.
Yeah, I would add maybe we need our liaisons to work on sort of a primer on the non-profit organizations and how they're just what is not what all, you know, and how they govern and all that sort of thing.
We have a hand for one of your liaisons.
Yeah, hand.
So, what we do though is we look at each individual petition that comes before us
in its own right, in its own merit.
We are not making generalizations about a whole host of organizations that represent or work with charter schools.
We are looking at each petition individually.
And therefore, as we do that, each of the various configurations of back office support or of various governance structures, we have to examine
as individual cases before.
In this particular case, I do believe that the final chart, the chart that's a part of the petition and the one that was passed out to us is the official one.
And if this charter is approved today by us, that is the governance structure that this charter school must live with from this point forward.
And if it does change from that, it's a material revision and would have to come back before the board.
Yes, I was not speaking about this petition.
And I don't know how to, and I don't think you were either.
No, this has nothing to do with this petition.
It has to do with understanding the law and some of the aspects of it.
I think, you know, nothing to do with this petition because I think members are getting more confused about
about this issue and how it operates.
We don't want to mix it up with this petition.
That's correct.
That's what I'm trying to do is not mix that discussion up with this.
Yeah, exactly.
Right now where I'd like to make a motion and that motion is to approve the Gross-Mott appeal.
I move the staff recommendation with all the conditions and technical amendments.
I second.
All right, is there any further board discussion?
Not all those, raise your hands.
Okay, we have... Do we have six?
Yes.
Okay, so we better call the roll here, yeah.
Okay, Bruce Holliday?
Yes.
Nikki Sandoval?
Karen Valdez?
Olivia Sison?
Yes.
Trish Williams?
Mike Kerse?
Yes.
Eileen Strauss?
Sue Burr?
Yes.
Felice Ortiz-Lacon?
Yes, with a condition, correct?
Yes.
And Pat Rucker?
No.
We have eight.
We have eight, so the petition is approved.
Okay.
So we want to take a break or?
Yeah, maybe we better.
Okay.
The board will take a 10-minute break and reconvene at 1025.
A little less than 10 minutes.
So the board will reconvene and we're now ready for
Item 17 concerning the Celerity Dyad Charter School.
Cindy Chan will present for CDE.
But this one is going to be a little bit longer than the last one.
So, yeah, this one is the more difficult one.
I think it's a little more complicated.
So this, we've gone through one of six today.
Before you, you have four renewals and this is one of the renewals that you'll hear.
And this one was denied locally.
So again, Cindy Chan, Director of the Charter Schools Division at the California Department of Education.
Item 17 is an appeal by Celerity Dyad Charter School to renew the charter school which was denied by the Los Angeles Unified School District and not considered by the Los Angeles County Board of Education.
Therefore the charter school appealed to the state and the CD received the appeal on December 12th.
Based on review of the petition documents and the information submitted, we are recommending that the State Board hold a public hearing and thereafter approve with technical amendments in six conditions.
The request to renew celerity dyad under the oversight of the State Board for a five-year term.
Effective July 1, 2017 through June 30, 2022.
So as part of the approval, I'm going to read through the six conditions that we are recommending.
So Celerity Educational Group, which I'll refer to as CEG, may only continue to contract with Celerity Global Development, which I will refer to as Global, for goods and or services if CEG and Global agree to timely respond to all CDE inquiries into CEG's and Global's operations, including but not limited to
Management, Fiscal, Personnel, Procurement, Facilities, Operations, Facilities Financing and Programmatic Services in accordance with Education Code Section 47604.3 and fully cooperate with any investigation into their operations conducted pursuant to Education Code Section 47604.4.
Condition 2, CEG will provide drafts of all proposed management and vendor contracts between CEG and Global.
Any affiliate of CEG or Global or any other related party to CEG or Global for CDE approval prior to execution.
Condition 3, CEG will provide drafts of all proposed loans including but not limited to interagency loans with full detail of the purpose of the loan, loan repayment,
and interest and the method of how the loans are secured for CD approval prior to execution.
Condition four, CEG will provide drafts of all proposed transfers of assets or liabilities including but not limited to interagency transfers with full detail of the purpose and allowed uses of the transfers for CD approval prior to execution.
Condition 5, CEG will contract with an agency approved by the CDE for a comprehensive management audit.
In addition to reviewing the operations of CEG, the audit also will review the operations of Global as they relate to the services and support that Global provides CEG and the use of the funds CEG provides Global for those services.
CEG will provide the CDE monthly updates from the auditor on the status of the audit.
And upon completion, the auditor's final comprehensive report on the day the auditor provides the report to CEG.
Within one month of its receipt of the auditor's report, CEG will provide the CDE with a plan approved by its governing board to resolve any audit findings.
And lastly, CEG will adhere to the terms and conditions of a memorandum of understanding between Solarity Dyad and the State Board.
So at the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools meeting on April 5th, the ACCS considered this celerity diet petition and due to concerns of recent information about CEG, the CDE had not formed a recommendation at that time of the meeting.
That's something very, very rare that we do.
We usually have a recommendation formed for the board at the ACCS meeting, but in this case we didn't.
We had posed a number of questions that were intended to encourage a discussion at the Advisory Commission amongst the commissioners that we believe would help us to form a recommendation for the State Board.
However, since the questions were not provided to the commissioners and petitioners in advance of the meeting, there was very little discussion around our concerns.
It was a very long discussion, but we had specific concerns that really weren't addressed by the dialogue.
So after the discussion and questions that the commissioners had of their own, the ACC has voted to recommend that the state would consider the following elements.
So this is the motion that I'm going to read to you.
Number one, that the commission applauds the academic success and accomplishments that Solarity has achieved, which is by law the most important consideration for renewal.
In order for this commission to conceptually support renewal, we would insist that the school adequately answer all the questions posed by the CD staff to the CD's full satisfaction.
And if and only if those questions are answered to the full satisfaction of the CD staff, such that CD staff makes an affirmative recommendation for renewal, then we conceptually support that recommendation for renewal.
And conversely, if the CD staff does not get adequate answers to their questions that fully answer their questions to their satisfaction, then this body would support recommendation for denial.
And the motion passed with six votes and one abstention.
So I'm going to give you some background and kind of jump to, this is going to connect to our condition and concerns at the end.
But because it's a chronology, I thought it'd be important to kind of just briefly go through some really key events and things that happened that kind of led us to where we are today with our condition and our concerns.
So I'm going to start with the November 2016 State Board meeting.
And if you recall, petitions for the establishment of Celerity-Himalaya Charter School and Celerity-Rolos Charter School were approved at that meeting.
These were to establish new charter schools under Celerity Educational Group.
We presented specific concerns with the governance structure of CEG and its affiliates, including but not limited to global.
At that meeting, both schools were approved with the following condition that was applicable to both charter schools.
And it's very similar to the one that we're proposing for this position.
CEG may only continue to contract with Global for goods and or services if CEG and Global agree to timely respond to all CD inquiries into CEG's and Global's operations including but not limited to management, fiscal, personnel, procurement, facilities operations and financing, programmatic services in accordance with the two education sections that I mentioned.
On January 4th, 2017, the scope of services in the agreement for limited services between CEG and Global was amended to include the condition that the State Board approved for the two charter schools.
So that was written into the agreement signed by both parties in early January.
In early January 2017, it came to our attention through various public sources, through media reports that were distributed out there, that there were allegations against CEG and or one or more of its affiliates of fiscal mismanagement, inappropriate related party transactions, and misuse of public funds.
On January 30th, CEG sent a letter to the CDE informing us of an investigation being conducted by the U.S.
Department of Education involving CEG and that agents had retrieved documents from CEG's administrative offices.
On March 2nd, the CDE sent a letter to CEG regarding the federal investigation of CEG and requested that CEG provide a listing, summary, and or description of all documents retrieved by the federal agencies from CEG, Global, and any affiliates of CEG.
and a summary of all related party contracts and transactions entered into by CEG Global, any affiliates of CEG and any affiliates of Global for the current and prior fiscal years.
On March 10th, CEG provided the CD with a response letter with a general description of the documents retrieved, including business records, financial and accounting records, and some miscellaneous documents.
Additionally, the letter provided a brief description of five affiliates and related party contracts of CEG and or global.
It's more detailed in the item.
It's fairly long.
On April 7th, the CDE sends a letter to CEG regarding requests for additional documents to address the questions CD expressed at the ACCS meeting.
So we gave them the opportunity, we presented the questions again, gave them the opportunity to respond so that we could look at information for, to present to the State Board.
On April 18th, CEG provided the CD with documents, response to the CD letter.
We reviewed the submission and on April 20th, we actually met with CEG and they brought with them a board member and staff from the organization, their legal counsel.
And we went through the documents that they submitted.
We had a long discussion with them about the documents, including their contracts, services contract with Global, CEG's dependency on Global, the appropriateness and the ability to sever CEG's contract with Global,
CEG Board's oversight of their contracts with Global, the reasonableness of the fees and amounts paid to Global for back office and other services.
On May 2nd,
This was after the board, the board item was posted.
CEG provided the CD with letters from the Compton Unified School District and Western Association of Schools and Colleges citing concerns regarding the federal investigation and other allegations that have been produced in the various media reports.
So as noted in the item, the April 26 letter from WASC to CEG was notification of potential withholding of accreditation status for all CEG schools for violations concerning substantive changes, integrity of member schools, and disclosure of information.
The WASC letter indicates they have reason to believe that the investigations of CEG and the search of its headquarters are related to suspicions of illegal activities at CEG.
WASC is issued in order to show cause as to why the accreditation
Status of all CEG schools should not be withheld.
Further, WASC has required CEG to complete an independent audit to verify CEG's stability, compliance with state and federal tax laws, and internal controls to prevent fraud, misuse of public funds, nepotism, and conflicts of interest if an independent audit has not already been planned or completed.
Also, CEG has been directed to provide the results of the independent audit and other requested information to us by June 2nd.
So kind of moving off of that, going into our analysis of the petition.
The first thing that we start with is looking at the renewal criteria.
So this is one element that's required that we have to perform, an authorizer has to perform that's over and above that for an establishment of a new petition.
So the renewal criteria, which we call the standard criteria for renewal, which is that which has existed for many years, consists mainly of the API data.
It's still relevant.
So a charter authorizer is required to consider increases in pupil academic achievement for all groups of pupils served by the charter school as the most important factor for renewal.
Pursuant to statute, a charter school that's been in operation for at least four years shall meet at least one of the five criteria related to academic performance.
They're listed in detail on page seven of the item.
We find that Solarity Dyad has met four of the five criteria and thus has demonstrated increases in pupil academic achievement and has met that requirement.
Statute further requires that we independently review the renewal petition and all the documents that were submitted to the local school district.
As part of our review of a charter petition, we must determine whether the petition sufficiently meets the required statutory requirements that include but are not limited to whether the charter school presents a sound educational program, that the petition contains reasonably comprehensive descriptions of the required elements,
and that the petitioners are able to successfully implement the intended program.
A lack of sufficiency in one or more area may form the basis for a finding of facts supporting grounds for denial.
The Solarity Dyad educational model offers pupils the opportunity to be challenged in a small, safe school environment where high expectations, academic excellence, and mutual respect will be non-negotiable and where parents and teachers work in partnership to meet achievement goals of pupils.
Solarity Dyad is proposing to serve approximately 700 pupils in transitional kindergarten through grade eight.
The Charter School provides a site-based matriculation setting with a commitment to increasing the achievement of at-risk pupils from communities in need within LAUSD.
Based on a review of the Solarity Dyad petition documents, we find the petition adequately describes the educational program and addresses how it will serve Solarity Dyad's target student population with the addition of some of our recommended technical amendments.
We also find that the petition provides an adequate description of the multiple required elements, noting that we have identified some or we're recommending technical amendment in that area.
Regarding the petitioner's ability to successfully implement the program.
For this particular criterion, the regulations contain a number of factors that must be considered.
One of these factors is the financial plan.
We have reviewed the petitioner's multi-year budget and after applying our assumptions and adjustments to revenues and expenditures, we find the plan to be reasonably sufficient to support the intended program.
Another very critical factor is the capacity of the petitioner.
We find that the Solarity Dyad petition presents a governance structure that may compromise the petitioner's ability to successfully implement the intended program.
So at this point, I wish I had a handout, but I don't.
So I'm going to walk you through the governance structure.
And you may recall this from the last time because it's not different, but it's very complicated.
So I think it would help to walk through it and try to describe it.
And it was the basis for the recommended condition that we proposed for celerity Himalaya and celerity Rolos.
Continues to be a concern because it's the same for celerity Dayan.
And please keep in mind that Solarity operates nine schools, seven of which are currently active.
The governance structure proposed reflects what the current practice is for all of the schools.
Okay, so we're going to start with the first, what I call the layer.
So we have the charter school and then the body that oversees the charter school is Solarity.
Oh, OK.
OK.
So, OK.
Charter School is the box.
And then above that, Celerity Educational Group.
The Celerity Dyad will be operated by CEG, which is a non-profit public benefit corporation.
The affairs of the Charter School will be managed and its powers exercised under the ultimate jurisdiction of CEG's Board of Trustees.
The CEG board will have ultimate responsibility for the operation and activities of Solarity Dyad.
So for example, I'll give you some of the board's major roles and responsibilities that they have.
Establishing and approving all major educational and operational policies, approving all major contracts, approving the Solarity Dyad annual budget, and also overseeing the school's fiscal affairs.
Sort of as background, real briefly, maybe for your study that you're going to do later.
Current law allows charter schools to elect to operate as or be operated by a non-profit public benefit corporation.
This form of governance structure we have found, we don't see all the petitions, we don't look at them, but this one is not uncommon where you have a non-profit public benefit corporation such as a charter management organization that operates more than one charter school.
Okay, so now we're going to go this next layer, next box, which is celerity global development, which I've been referring to as global.
This is the sole statutory member.
So celerity dyads governing bylaws indicate that global
another separate nonprofit public benefit corporation shall serve as a sole statutory member of CEG.
So as sole statutory member, Global's rights include approving the elected CEG trustees,
That's approving, not appointing, because I think that was a point of difference last time.
So approving the elected CEG trustees, removal of elected trustees, approving the disposition of all or substantially all of CEG's assets, approving any merger and its principal terms in any amendment of those terms,
and on any election to dissolve CEG.
So a comment that we have found that this form of governance structure does exist with other charter schools, but it's not as common.
It's not one that we see as often.
I think the one with just the CEG component is more common.
Okay, another layer, but now we're kind of going off to the side here.
So we have the sole statutory, we have CEG, and then we have the charter.
Now I'm kind of connecting the box to the side.
We have global still as a vendor.
So in addition to Global's role as sole statutory member of CEG, CEG contracts with Global for various services for all of the charter schools overseas, which would include the current ones that already died in.
These services include, but are not limited to, management, staff development, supervisory oversight, fiscal services, human resources, procurement, information technology, and facilities operations and financing.
As Global serves as the sole statutory member of CEG and is a contracted vendor of CEG as well, we have had concerns that this control affords, that affords one of CEG's primary vendors over the CEG board presents the potential for a conflict of interest that puts at risk the charter school's future operational health.
This was also a concern noted by LAUSD in the review of the charter petition.
So that structure, which we had the concern before, added to the recent concerns is kind of where we're at today.
So in addition to the noted concerns with the governor structure, the recent information that I provided to you through the chronology has elevated our concerns to a higher level.
And this is due to the recent public allegations, the ongoing federal investigation, and additional information provided by CEG.
And they've been very responsive, I want to note.
Of the numerous related party contracts and transactions entered into by CEG Global and their affiliates, we are concerned on how this may affect the ability of the petitioner to successfully implement the program.
However, since we do not have any official reports, I mean these are media reports, we have reached out to the Office of Inspector General who's been performing this investigation and it's, there's no information that's passed on from that.
It's an ongoing investigation and they're not in a position to have a dialogue about that.
So there's been no other official reports.
There have been no formal management reviews or have been no forensic audits that we have that we could bring forward that substantiate with factual findings that fraud or fiscal mismanagement exists within the organizations.
Therefore, we are at a point where we are recommending approval of the renewal petition, but with the conditions that we proposed.
We believe that our recommended conditions are prudent given our concerns of the governance structure and the relationship of the CEG board and global.
And the conditions are also intended to serve as part of our monitoring that we would have if the charter schools approved for our oversight of the charter school.
Therefore, we recommend that the State Board hold a public hearing to approve the petition to establish Solarity Dyad under the oversight of the State Board with the proposed technical amendments and the conditions that I've mentioned.
I know that the Solarity petitioner is here and also representatives from Los Angeles Unified School District are here to present to the Board.
So, if you have any questions, I can answer or... Here.
Am I here?
Yes, go ahead.
Board member Burr.
Thank you for walking through this so carefully, Cindy, and laying this all out.
It was very helpful.
And I do have a little graphic that I drew.
But I don't know what sole statutory member means.
And I don't and there must be some term of art there.
And I don't know if that's something that council wants to answer or
But it sounds like when you say here's a board of directors, there's a board that governs CEG, which I assume is some number of members, but then you go up to global development and you call it the sole statutory member.
What is it?
Is that a body composed of people?
Nick looks like he wants to answer this.
This is Nick Schweitzer, Deputy Superintendent.
So, yeah, I've looked into this a bit.
So, most corporate entities, they consist of shareholders.
Non-profit corporations, of course, do not have shareholders.
Instead, they generally have a membership.
In the case of a lot of non-profits,
they don't have a membership and said they have a single member.
So that's when we refer to a sole statutory member.
that means that global is the single member.
So, you know, for for-profit corporations, the shareholders get to vote on various issues relating to the governments and purpose of the corporation.
For non-profit entities that have a membership base, those members get to vote on
issues related to the corporation for the sole statutory member as is laid out in their corporate bylaws.
The sole member gets to exercise control over the actual board of directors as a membership base would for a non-profit that has a membership base or shareholders would do for a for-profit corporation.
Okay.
Board Member Rucker, then Board Member Williams.
It's my turn.
Thank you.
Yeah, it's the... Sorry.
So with this sole statutory member, I want to make sure I understood what you just said.
They have some oversight over the CEG board.
Is that correct?
Yes.
Do they appoint the members of the CEG board?
They do not appoint the members, but they do approve who is appointed.
So the board, the board itself appoints its own members, which is not uncommon.
Right.
For non-profits.
So the board itself appoints its own members and then CEGlobal.
Global.
To approve of those appointments.
Is global in any other way?
Have any other control?
Let me finish the question.
Have any other control over the policies or the decisions of the CEG board?
Not, not directly through, through their ability to, you know, appoint and remove or approve appointments and remove members.
They can remove members.
So the board has the authority to appoint them.
Global can approve them and Global has the sole authority to remove them?
I believe so.
Is that, yeah.
I believe that's what the bylaws are.
Does Global approve the,
budget for CEG's charter schools?
I do not believe they, they, they don't have data that
responsibility based on the bylaws.
It's the board itself.
Okay.
And the CEG board approves the contract that pays the consulting and all these other services that Global is the, it receives the financial remuneration for?
Correct.
And this is the board that Global can remove members from?
Okay.
I clearly understand.
Board Member Williams.
Trish and Eileen.
So this is for you, Nick, with that explanation of nonprofits.
I ran a nonprofit in California for 20 years.
And we didn't have we because we weren't a membership.
You talk about nonprofits having members and some do, you know, membership associations have members.
But a lot of nonprofits just have an executive director, staff, and a board.
True.
And so that's what we had and
So there was no sole statutory member.
It is true that nonprofit boards are self-appointing.
They usually are drawn to the mission of the organization.
They are brought on as the organization evolves over time.
We need a stronger finance person on.
We need somebody that can help us with marketing.
We need some donors.
You know, that's very, very common.
The thing I was not familiar with was this sole statutory member.
I know it's legal.
At least I've heard that it's legal, but it does appear, but I don't know what its purpose is in a charter organizational structure.
It must serve a useful kind of purpose.
It's not done often, but it's, we've heard of them recently.
It must serve a useful kind of purpose to do that.
Do you know what that would be?
I think where I've seen in sort of, you know, doing my own little bit of research on this, you know, I've seen it, it's useful when you have sort of several different organizations that are related to each other and supporting each other.
And so it sort of maintains that connection between the organizations.
So I, you know, I don't know whether that is truly necessary in this instance.
Board Member Strauss.
So I did also draw my own.
I think it looks a little different.
I tried really hard to write.
So that'd be helpful in the future when there's a lot of different or just to help us understand it.
But so I understand the CEG has a board and I understand and appreciate Member Rucker's clarification of the authority that Global has over CEG.
My question is who is Global?
Is that the CEO?
Is there three people?
Who is Global?
So Global has its separate non-profit, has its own governing board.
Presuming that that governing board would act on behalf of Global to approve the appointments to CEG.
And what's the role of the executive director?
Just works for that board like a non-profit executive director would work for a board?
I'm just trying to understand all the players here to clarify, kind of build on what Member Rucker was trying to, I mean, that's what we're trying to figure out is how all these pieces fit together.
Yeah, I, yes.
So that the executive director would be, act as the CEO of the entity.
Which entity?
Whichever entity they're the executive director of.
So executive director, president, whatever you want to call it, the CEO of the organization.
Okay, board member Williams, were you next?
So Pat, Trish and Karen.
And Baraka.
Who, does the executive director have a vote with the board members?
I don't, you know, I don't know what is the role of the executive director for Global.
I don't believe they have a vote for CEG, but I don't know that would not be the case, but I would presume it would depend on the bylaws of that entity as to what the authority and role is of the executive director or CEO of that organization is.
And these were the questions I had the last time when we had the meeting in November because the governing structure that as explained today was the governing structure that I understood in November.
But what I have never been clear on is what the authority the executive director has as an employee either of CEG or of global in contracting with global services.
If the C, if the,
Now the acronyms are beginning to get mixed up in my head.
If the chief executive officer is an employee of Global, but is doing the actual contracting of the work that CEG pays Global for,
That's one thing.
But if the chief executive officer is an employee of CEG and works with the board to develop the contract that goes back to global for the, that gives money back to global, and global is the one that both appoints the CEO and can remove board members, just as I did in November, I think I smell a rat.
So CEG and CGD both have separate CEOs.
Okay.
But who is the employee, who is the employer of the CEO?
for C.E.G.
C.E.G.
So the CEO of C.E.G.
is appointed by the board of C.E.G.
He's appointed by the board of C.E.G., the board that C.D.G.
can remove.
That's correct.
OK.
So, OK.
So by relationships, in the same way that my mother's brother is in some way related to me or my grandmother's brother is some way related to me, that would make the CEO
of CEG, an employee of Global as well.
If the board that appoints him, that person can be removed by Global.
Yeah.
Okay.
I got it.
All right.
I understand.
Who's next?
Yeah.
Board Member Williams.
Did you hear that?
No.
So, I think one of the things that I, I know that this, I have been told that the structures are legal.
But, and I'm sure they were set up by lawyers.
But, but one of the things I'm not familiar with, and I don't know how common it is, I think it's not common, is to have, is to have
the global, a group that provides services, that gets paid by the school to provide a variety of services, to have them have a sole statutory member that then approves or removes board members of the school.
It feels like it's kind of upside down to me.
you know, in terms of the vendor having that instead of the board and CEO of the schools.
Does it, what would your comment be on that?
Yes, it certainly raises a concern for us now as it did when the last two celerity charters
came before us or came before the board.
Certainly, we feel there is the potential for a conflict there, which, you know, which drove us or led us to initially impose the condition that, you know, that
both CEG and Global opened their books and opened their operations to us to, you know, if we feel like there is something going on there that needs to be investigated.
I think now that today, you know, given some of the things that have been in the press and this investigation, you know, while we, you know, cannot point to anything specific as to, you know, something inappropriate going on, you know, we feel like, you know, yeah, we, now is the time we need to, you know,
to, you know, have full comfort and confidence in this operation.
We feel like, you know, this needs to look, be looked into further by independent agency.
That's what has led to the additional condition.
Okay.
And just to wrap up, wrap up my question or comment, I, as far as I know, nothing has been found.
There's no findings issued, right?
And I think it's important.
Right.
or the federal investigation.
Yes.
But nothing has been found or released as a finding.
We just have a structure and an investigation that makes us feel very cautious.
Yes.
About the potential here.
Okay.
I'm going to call on a board member Valdez and then I think we need to move to public hearing.
It might illuminate some of these issues.
Mine's a technical question.
You answered part of it because you talked about a conflict of interest between global and global and the goods and services and the other part.
But the other piece is we're approving this today because of statutory timelines or making a decision of determination.
Is that correct?
Even though this investigation seems to be fluid and you do have concerns, but we're... Is that why we're doing this today?
Because of the statutory timelines?
Yes.
Okay, so I'm going to now open the public hearing and each side will have 10 minutes and we'll have first the petitioner for the charter school.
Good morning.
My name is Grace Canada, and I have the honor and pleasure of serving as the CEO for Solarity Educational Group.
And good morning.
My name is Nadia Shaik.
I am director of school services for Solarity Educational Group.
As you'll hear from Nadia in a few minutes, we operate in some of the toughest neighborhoods, neighborhoods where others fail, and yet we consistently succeed.
Our schools outperform LAUSD, the county, and state averages in English language arts and math on the 2016 CASP assessment.
And our students love to come to school, as evidenced by an astounding 97.31% in-seat attendance rate.
Dyett and Troika are no different.
Both schools have equally amazing results.
As you know, the ACCS conditioned their positive recommendation on CEG answering all of the staff's questions, remaining questions.
We did so, and we did so thoroughly.
And we are proud to have received their recommendation today.
And I really want to acknowledge and acknowledge staff's time and say thank you for the opportunity to collaborate.
We stand here ready and excited to accept the conditions recommended by staff.
As we've said all along, it's all about the students.
Our goal is to continue to provide the highest quality education to our stakeholder communities.
I've been a part of Celerity since 2005 as founding principal of Celerity Nascent Charter School.
Next to me stands Nadia Shaik.
She joined us in 2000, Director of School Services, and she joined us in 2006 as a first grade teacher.
One of the biggest honors I have is working with our amazing board.
Kurt Hessler has a stellar resume of public service and private industry experience.
He's worked for the President, the Supreme Court, and a laundry list of successful businesses.
And I am excited that you will have a chance to hear from him yourself today.
With Kurt are four members of the community who devote countless hours to make a meaningful difference.
Ron, too, is also here today, and you will have an opportunity to hear from him during public comment.
A question I often get is, how does Solarity Global support the schools?
Let me count the ways.
A robust performing arts program, curriculum development, special education, human resources, leadership coaching, accounting, facilities, public relations, grants, replication, data management, financial management,
board support, training, insurance, procurement, technology, financial reporting, recruiting, and more.
Global assists with all that so that we can focus on delivering a top-notch education that each Celerity student deserves, day in and day out.
I'm proud to share with you a little bit about Celerity Dyad, a school I taught and worked at.
Almost all of Dyad's students are socioeconomically disadvantaged, fully 90%.
Solarity's educational program is designed to meet the needs of these students, Latino, at risk, and who have had a consistent lack of educational choices.
Our students face enormous hurdles to academic and life success simply because of where they live, South Los Angeles.
For example, they're surrounded by high unemployment, low incomes, and high crime rates.
And all of the schools that Celerity Dyad would otherwise attend are currently in program improvement.
The other schools have simply not been able to overcome these high hurdles.
They consistently do far worse than LAUSD as a whole.
We have had great success in closing the achievement gap over the past nine years.
Under the law, increases in academic achievement at a charter school shall be the most important factor in a charter renewal and Celerity Dyad has been closing that achievement gap in South LA.
Despite the very real disadvantages and hurdles that Dyad students face daily, they consistently outperform their resident, their district, their county, and even state averages, and they continue to improve.
This is Dyad in orange in the orange bar.
We are outperforming everyone on the charts, the state, county, LAUSD as a whole, and in particular, the schools that our students would otherwise attend.
Just look at the gap between Dyad's Orange Bar and the median of the local schools around us, the bar to the right.
And this isn't just school wide, it's by student group.
For instance, in the most recent CASP assessment in 2016, 33% of dyads English learners met or exceeded standards in English language arts compared to 3% at LAUSD.
For math, 36% of our English learners met or exceed standards compared to 6% at LAUSD.
Simply put, celerity dyad is the best result for the students who attend our charter school.
If the charter for celerity dyad is not renewed, our students will attend schools that perform significantly worse on standardized tests.
And it isn't just test scores.
Dyad's suspension rate has steadily declined each year over the past three years.
And dyad has increased its reclassification rate of English learners between 2015 and 2016.
In our most recent parent survey, fully 100% of Dyett's parents believe that our school provides them the resources to support their child beyond the regular school day.
I want to take a second and thank and acknowledge the parents, students, former students, staff, and supporters who have come here today from Los Angeles.
Thank you.
Many of them you'll hear from today.
Thank you for your time and consideration of just how great a school Dyett is.
Good morning.
My name is Maurice Tsa.
I'm with Gibson Dunn.
I am counsel to Solarity.
For ease, I'm going to call CEG Solarity, and I'm going to refer to global as global.
I am here to assure you of two things.
The first thing is, after a thorough review of the documents, the board meeting minutes, interviews of management, and a deep examination of Solarity's operations, that the governance structure and the governance of Solarity is, frankly, has no par.
I would like to address right now an issue that came up in this last discussion.
First of all, with respect to Global, Global has never removed a board member.
Ever.
We have turned over all of the board meeting minutes.
If you review them, you will see that no one from Global has interjected themselves in the decision making of the board of Celerity.
And Celerity has consistently worked through its board to make the right decisions for the school, which has been demonstrated by the fact that the school has outperformed all of its competitor schools.
Second, as Celerity has always done, we are looking forward and moving forward by continuing to refine governance structures in order to ensure that Celerity becomes a model for governance for all charter schools.
So what I'm going to describe now is exactly what is happening and what has been done since this very last ACCS hearing.
The first thing is
The board has met and has passed a number of resolutions, which I'm going to describe to you now.
It is no mystery that there have been questions raised about global.
We expect to hear more of them today.
We welcome them.
Frankly, we feel the questions about global are entirely appropriate, and we have strong answers for all of the questions that you may have.
But let me say this.
All the services that Global provided, a suite, were particularly important as Solarity began to develop its operations and grow through what is now seven schools.
However, as Solarity has matured over time, it has become clear that there are many opportunities to review that relationship.
And that is exactly what Board Resolution No.
1 does.
The Board has directed CEG management to analyze corporate formation and structure,
and the contractual relationship between CEG and Global, including possible termination.
And again, let me emphasize, this has been completely public and well discussed within Celerity and within Global, and Global has been behind this effort 100%.
The fundamental goal of what we are here to tell you today is that more than anything, all of the stakeholders in Solarity and Global want to keep the seven schools open.
That is the fundamental point for board resolution number one.
Time is up.
Ten minutes.
So now we'll hear from the people that oppose the petition.
Good morning, Board President Kirst and Deputy Superintendent Price, board members.
I'm Robert Perry, Los Angeles Unified School District.
I come representing Superintendent King and the board.
I have with me today from our fiscal team, Amy Long, and from our Office of the General Counsel, Devorah Navarro-Reed.
I've come to speak to you today
to appeal to this body to uphold the unanimous decision unanimous decision of the LAUSD board to deny the two charter petitions before you today.
Our team has been involved in the oversight of the schools in this group of charters for over a decade.
While we acknowledge the achievement of students
that attend the schools, our findings delineate the serious concerns that are borne by the decisions made by the school's leadership and governing board.
Our concerns align with those noted in the CDE's report today, where they said, due to the recent public allegations, ongoing multi-agency federal investigation
And additional information provided by CEG of the numerous related party contracts and transactions entered into by Solarity Education Group, Solarity Global Development and their affiliates.
The CDE notes concerns on how this may affect the ability of the petitioner to successfully implement the program.
Those were our concerns.
Those were our concerns in November.
Those are our concerns today.
At its November meeting, this board approved two new schools for this organization after being presented with specific concerns that the CDE had regarding, and I quote again from the documents you have before you from the CDE today, they had concerns on the governance structure of CEG and its affiliates.
The board, this board approved the schools with a condition.
that the organization would fully cooperate with any investigation into their operations.
It's a condition that's given today.
It was a condition in November.
After that meeting, we set up a meeting with CEG's leadership to seek the same level of transparency and cooperation that had been committed to this board.
We met on November 10th, 2016.
As a starting point, CEG was asked to provide finally a complete, transparent, as promised, total governance structure, affiliated entity structure, and we got it in a timely fashion on December 15th.
only to find out this past week in reviewing CDE's public and published report for this agenda, we discovered entities that we did not, were not given on the transparent document.
There is, you've talked about global.
Global is not the only entity.
There's celerity development, LLC.
There's Attencher.
There's Orion Schools.
All of those provide services to CEG.
On attention, we found out from the CDE's document that, first of all, that attention was a for-profit entity and we didn't, weren't aware of that at that time or at least it wasn't on this document.
Additionally, we learned that there were entities such as the Roan Group and Student Learning Pathways that were not on this chart.
this transparent chart.
The chart shows that Orion Schools operates a private school.
This chart says it's in Pasadena when in fact it's 30 miles away in Chino Hills.
The transparent chart according to the conditions.
Our question for this board is when will we ever get to the truth about the interconnectivity?
We've had promise after promise after promise.
We're not there.
We talk about Solarity Global.
We know that $2.2 million approximately was transferred from CEG into Global.
That can happen with the sole statutory.
That wasn't talked about a few moments ago.
Part of our job as overseers of the public trust is to monitor public funds
watch where they go, hold the entities accountable for them.
If the State Board continues to approve organizations with such complex and intricate structures,
In a de facto way, it's making it a tacit approval of those.
And it makes us on the ground have an even more difficult job to oversee.
Because we believe you can't oversee what you can't see.
And I'll turn the rest of my time over to Ms.
Long and Ms.
Navarro-Reed.
Good morning.
I was going to share with you what I shared before the State's Advisory Commission on Charter Schools, but I really wanted to address some of the questions that I heard earlier from the board, which is with regards to the governance and the structure of it.
So, as Ms.
Sing Chan said earlier about the boxes, right, with the charter school and with there being CEG and above it being something global,
I just want to let you know that if you were to go to the California Secretary of State website and you look up these Solarity entities, you will find that for Solarity Global Development, which acts in the capacity of a sole statutory member and a vendor of Solarity Educational Group,
lists Bianca McFarlane as the CEO of Solarity Global.
Now, Ms.
McFarlane is also the former CEO of Solarity Educational Group.
We have also been informed that, by CEG, that Ms.
McFarlane is also a board member of Solarity Global Development.
Okay, so that's the sole statutory member and the vendor.
Now if you look at the other Solarity entities, if you look up their information on the California Secretary of State website, Solarity Development LLC has one member, Ms.
McFarland.
She is the CEO.
Solarity Development LLC does business with CEG.
Solarity Contracting Services also discloses Ms.
McFarland as the CEO.
Solarity Contracting Service also does business with CEG.
A Tenture LLC also discloses Ms.
McFarland as the CEO of that entity.
They also do business with Solarity Educational Group.
So I want to apprise the board of this information, which is public information, so that you have everything you need to make the decision today.
Thank you.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Devorah Navarro-Reed.
I'm Chief Education Legal Counsel for LA Unified School District.
CDE and the State Board already has our findings of fact related to these two celerity schools.
I would just like to take an opportunity to highlight some of the critical findings.
In 2012, Solarity Educational Group created unilaterally, without the approval of LAUSD's Board of Education, Solarity Global Development, which has already been ad nauseum said is the sole statutory member of Solarity Educational Group.
As a sole statutory member, it affords global the following rights.
The power to elect and remove CEG's board members, dispose of CEG's assets, merge CEG with other corporations, or the power to dissolve the corporation.
Even though it's been represented that CEG has, Solarity Global has never done that, or is not going to do that, those are their rights under the California Corporations Code under Section 5056.
So regardless of what the representations are, those are their corporate rights.
In addition, CEG entered into an affiliation management agreement with Global, delegating day-to-day management of CEG schools to Global, which calls into the question what the board has been discussing this morning regarding local control.
CEG also transferred $2.3 million to Global.
To date, there are no answers regarding the rationale for those transfers.
There were also checks to Global for the amount of $5 million and $5,021,000 to the LLC for $334,000
and to Celerity Contracting for $321,943 back in 2016.
As part of oversight, the Charter Schools Division requested information regarding those amounts and rationale and none was provided.
We are requesting the State Board to uphold our findings, the LAUSD's findings regarding these two schools.
There's no standard anywhere in the Charter Schools Act indicating that fraud needs to be substantiated in order to find, make a finding of non-renewal.
I would also like to take a moment.
Time.
Thank you.
Okay.
We'll now have the public comment.
Oh, usually we proceed to public.
I would prefer to wait till after public comment.
Okay, public comment.
Pardon?
Close the hearing.
Hearing is closed.
Would the following people please line up?
Tanya Elizabeth Duke, Hilda Torres, Patrick Strickley, Guillermo Hernandez, Kurt Hessler, Ron Ben,
Yehuda, Marbella Gill, Lubia Elizabeth Duke, Vania Garcia, Jeanette Davila, Rocio Perez, Ladi Omarez, Erica Ramos, Iman Khalil, Yuri Ria de Jesus Ramirez, Paula Carcamo, Karina Acosta, Carla
Labradores De Ruiz, Michelle Lynch, Ken Burt, Eric Primack, and Lorraine Richards.
Hello I'm Tanya Duque.
I am currently an 8th grader at Solarity Dia Charter School.
My time there has been amazing.
The dance shows that we participate in are fun and they teach us students how to work with others.
They help us gain confidence because we perform in front of many parents.
The teachers are also very helpful.
If you have a question you can go to them.
They motivate us to do the best we can be.
All in all this is a really great school and I hope you allow it to stay just as it is.
Hi, good morning.
My name is Hilda Torres.
As a single mother of a student attending Salary Diet, I am pleased with my decision to choose a school that fits best for my family.
I am a firm believer in public charter schools.
My son is an energetic fourth grader who is very smart, friendly, and outgoing.
He has earned honor roll on a yearly basis.
My son loves the school, his teachers, and looks forward to going every day.
It's a hard fact that public charter schools are a lifeline for dozens of Southern California families, including mine.
Before charter schools arrived, if your child was sworn for a charter school and you couldn't afford private school or to move, you were trapped.
Thankfully,
Charter schools such as celery diet were introduced as laboratories of motivation and parent conversation, collaboration.
Our school is making a positive impact in our community and I wouldn't like my kid to go to a low-performing school.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Patrick Stickley and I'm the principal of Celerity Dyad Charter School in South Los Angeles.
Our area is viewed throughout the world as a rough and tumble neighborhood.
Gangs and homelessness abounds, yet Dyad thrives.
This is proof that the residents of this neighborhood understand that education is the bridge to a productive life.
In partnership with our parents, Dyad is that bridge that their children cross daily to close the achievement gap.
In addition to the packets of letters of support that I brought, I would like to share a letter of support that our area school resources police officer wrote for us.
He states, of the 63 other schools in my patrol area that I work with, Celerity Dyad is the only one that consistently goes out of its way to maintain a good and informative relationship
with parents while also seeing that its students are educated and well-rounded in every way.
It's the kind of place that I would send my own child.
I can assure you that this is a school that needs to stay.
I feel that the community would suffer greatly if this school was no longer allowed to function.
In conclusion, you have the power to partner up with Solarity Dyad.
Time.
Continue to let Dyad Bridge be the bridge that our students use to close the achievement gap.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Guillermo Hernandez and I'm a product from Solarity NASID.
I'm currently attending Northeastern University in Boston as a fourth year studying electrical engineering as a Gates Millennium Scholar.
At Solarity, it wasn't just about the education, it was more about the support system.
I remember Celery as a community of teachers that cared about me.
Before Celery, I attended a public school where it was easy to blend in.
Teachers never expressed an interest in challenging me past the curriculum.
At Celery, it was different.
I noticed students wanting to spend their lunchtime with their favorite teacher.
That was foreign to me.
I remember Mr. Graham, my math teacher from seventh grade, told me to come by during lunch to recognize my achievement and encourage me.
Encourage my leadership potential with my peers.
I said it again with my A4A teacher, Mr. Watsman.
In the classes I did struggle, my teachers took the extra step to help me.
When I think about celerity, I remember my teachers.
I'd like to thank them for showing me the definition of what a teacher is.
Today, I'm asking you to keep the celerity diet open for the generations after me so that they can learn in a place that both challenges and cares for them.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Kurt Hessler.
I'm the president of the board of CEG.
I've been on the board for 11 years.
We have five members, obviously all unpaid professionals.
members of the community.
One of them, Dana Walden, has been out 11 years, as I have, and is really responsible for the Performing Arts Education Program and the whole thing.
Julie Stern was the Chief Operating Officer of Oprah Winfrey's movie and TV production company.
It's one of the biggest.
She's been there for eight years.
You'll see Ron Ben-Yehuda, who's one of the best intellectual property lawyers in California, partner in a major firm.
And Francisco
Morris, who is a senior HR executive at the Screen Actors Guild.
That's the board.
We're totally independent.
Global has never said a word to us, and we wouldn't listen anyway if they did.
We're the boss of the management of CEG.
The management, you saw those two women who stood up, are just unbelievably amazing.
They've been there from the beginning.
When I joined in the CEG, there was no Global, and it really doesn't matter.
We're happy to meet all of the conditions that were imposed on us.
Good morning.
My name is Ron Ben Yehuda.
I'm one of CEG's board members and I'm also the chair of the Audit and Compliance Committee of the board.
Like the other board members, I am and have always been a volunteer board member.
I currently practice at Paul Hastings, and a large part of my practice is advising companies, including startups, established mid-market firms, and Fortune 100 companies.
I've also served as a general counsel of two different software companies.
I joined CEG's board about two years ago because I was inspired by the enthusiasm that I saw from everyone I met about educating children, and I was also incredibly impressed by the spectacular success that CEG has shown, providing incredible opportunities to children that lack options.
If I didn't believe in Solarity's mission to bring great education to, you know, needy communities, I wouldn't be here.
I wouldn't be on the board.
And doing that is something we're really succeeding at.
As you know, our schools, including Dyad and Troika.
Time.
Thank you very much.
Good morning.
My name is Marbea Gill.
Over the past five years at Solarity, I've experienced a charter school that sets the bar high for their staff and students.
I chose to teach at Solarity Dyad because of all the positive things I had heard.
The management and the operations are excellent and the teachers are highly trained and committed to their students.
We work hard to provide an exceptional and rigorous education to the children of the South LA neighborhood.
The proof can be seen in the students' achievement.
Our parents support us and value being able to send their children to an accomplished school and the families in the community should have the opportunity to provide their children with a good education.
I also truly appreciate and enjoy being part of this school.
From our engaging lessons to the beautiful performing arts shows, we are a great school to attend.
Our 690 students deserve to continue receiving a high quality education at Dyett.
Thank you for your consideration.
I'm just going to translate what she says.
She says her name is Luvia and she's the daughter of a student who has been able to excel since the first grade to eighth grade and she has been in honor roll.
uh
She says that her daughter has even had the president send her a certificate and that means that the school must be doing good all thanks to the
the to the teachers and the principal and she has come in representation of the fathers and mothers who haven't been able to come assist and present.
She knows that this is the last year of her daughter at this school, but she's going to keep supporting the school because of the students that they're still teaching.
Ellos son los que necesitan a su escuela y maestros que han dado la enseanza y el apoyo de estudiar.
Ellos estn creciendo con la misma escuela y la escuela podra
Si la escuela cierra, la escuela podra... Time.
El futuro de... Yeah, you can finish that translation.
Go ahead, translate.
Okay, so the students are the ones who need the schools because they are growing and with the same school.
And if you close the school, they could change their future that they have planned along with their teachers.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Vanya.
I was a previous alumni here at Dyad, and coming to this school empowered me to achieve and excel beyond my limits.
The way the teachers taught allowed me to develop a growth mindset rather than a fixed mindset.
Each teacher worked with the students' needs one-on-one, which really allowed the students to progress with everyone at the same time.
Around a year ago, my previous high school was shut down almost overnight.
And going to another school for the last year of high school was very troublesome.
I had to reestablish my college plan because I was at a new school.
And coming closer to the end of the year, I was
I have progressed and I am in my new school and controlled my situation as best as I could.
It was a result of this school that I was accepted into Humboldt State University this up and coming fall.
It was because of schools like these that allowed me to become first generation college student for my family.
I am who I am due to the foundation that I was exposed to here at Dyett.
And I would really love it if they could continue on for generations after myself.
And I really do love that.
Thank you.
Thank you for your time.
Good morning.
My name is Janet Davila.
I have two kids attending Celeric Diet, and I'm hoping my third child could get an opportunity to attend to a school where teachers and staff show them that they care for them, to get a quality education, and to actually succeed in achieving it.
For me, it's amazing to see how my kids are growing on their level of learning skills, where they are not surrounded by a lot of opportunities to succeed in life.
Please don't take away my choice and opportunity for my children's education and the only school they ever know.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Rocio Perez and I am a teacher at Solarity Dyad.
I'm here on behalf of Solarity Dyad.
Solarity Dyad educators thrive in scaffolding the education and nurturing our scholars to success and high achievements.
Solarity Diet is not just a school, but it's a family made of caring teachers, staff, parents who support our students' success daily.
If our school is to close, you will be displacing 690 of our students, their extended families, and their staff.
You will be taking away choices and resources from families who don't have many.
I urge you to please support our students, our staff, and our parents to allow Solarity Schools to remain open.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Lydia Almaraz, and I'm an alumni from Solarity Diet.
I first came to this school from an LAUSD that wouldn't give me the opportunity to excel my education, knowing that I needed extra help in coming to Solarity Diet in 2005 as a third grader and getting the help that I needed.
has paved the way for my education.
And so and that is my brothers are going through the same thing that they need to be part of the IEP program.
And being part of the IEP program has helped me a lot.
It has furthered my education.
I go to a high school now that accepts IEP and in the fall I will be attending a university that accepts IEP as well.
And being an IEP to me has motivated me to work harder and be motivated to further my education and know that even if I have a setback in my learning disability, I will still further it.
And I really hope that Celerity Diet doesn't get closed so my brothers could experience the same thing.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Erica Ramos.
I am the mother of Gloria Aparicio.
She's a second grader at Dyad.
I am a single mother who grew up in South Central.
Unfortunately, I did not graduate high school.
I have the ability to send my child where she has an opportunity to get dance classes that are offered to her at the campus without no out-of-pocket charge to myself.
she has experienced a more self, how do I say this, her self-esteem got raised because they had a bookmark contest which she won and she got first place and they recognized her and that gave her the opportunity to
thrive and try new things for herself.
She wasn't really wanting to do it.
And she has been an honor roll and has gotten citizenship throughout her short time.
Thank you.
Hi, good morning.
My name is Iman Khalil and I'm one of the fourth graders, fourth grade teachers at Solarity Dyad.
At Dyad, we're a group of professionals dedicated to meeting the learning and developmental needs of all of our students.
CHU supports its teachers with ongoing professional training using research proven strategies and a rigorous curriculum.
Additionally, CEG provides its teachers with experienced educators and curriculum specialists to support and guide.
Individualized instruction, highly qualified and trained staff and educators, integration of technology, and a whole load of love and dedication for our scholars and their families is at the heart and mind of Celerity Dyad.
Together, Celerity Dyad, its eager students, and its involved families are a powerful team that have positively shaped and impacted this community.
We look forward to continuing our efforts.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Yudidia De Jesus.
I am a parent of a current student at Celerity Diet Charter School.
My experience with Celerity has been the best.
My daughter has grown tremendously both in math and English compared to when she attended a public school for pre-kinder and kinder.
I noticed a big improvement by the second week at Celerity Diet.
Celerity Diet has offered my daughter a small smaller class which allows her teacher to help her in the areas she struggles with the most.
My daughter is much more confident and motivated to learn each day.
I myself attended public schools throughout my school years so I know how hard it is to find a great school academically.
We all want the best for our children, and Celerity Diet has offered my daughter the best resources, dedicated teachers, and a great staff.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Paola Carcamo and I'm a mother of a first grader attending Celerity Diet.
I feel Celerity is a gem in our community.
My son was diagnosed with mild autism at one and a half years old and he attended school ever since.
I feel no other school before Celerity has given him the same level of attention and dedication.
When my son started first grade, he had trouble adjusting.
His teacher would constantly reach out to me.
She would express any concern and ask what my son's preferred method of learning was and what she could do to help him not only academically, but also emotionally.
She has gone above and beyond to make sure my son reaches his academic goals.
Through his IEP, we were able to come up with a strategy that would help him navigate his daily routine, and it has paid off.
He was on the honor roll in the first trimester and continues to excel.
I am happy that if any concern arises on either end, we can always text each other.
All the staff at Celerity are committed to making students' days fulfilling and ready to help whenever needed.
Celerity has been great for our family.
We see the improvements in my son and we couldn't be happier.
Good morning, my name is Karina Costa and I'm here to honor to support the renewal of Slurry Diet Charged School.
My son is in second grade and as a parent I want to give the best education for my son and Slurry Diet is the option.
I graduated from Thomas Jefferson High School in 2006 and witnessed the rise among students black versus brown.
I did not have teachers in the classroom to sit down and learn.
The lack of education from the Unified District School I struggled during my college degree.
Fortunately I was able to receive my BA in history in Costa Dominguez Hills in 2012.
Therefore I would not like to my son to suffer the same struggles I faced attending Unified District School.
Solarius is a school that gives love support and attention to the students parents and community.
Thank you.
Hi, good morning, everyone.
My name is Karla Lavadores.
I am a mother of two kids.
One is in second grade.
The other is in fifth grade.
And first, I would like to thank you for the time and the opportunity to tell you my opinion.
In case that you decide to close our school, you should know that you are taking away the opportunity for my children to have a better future.
Because as you can see, Celerity Diet is a good school.
For me, the best school in my neighborhood.
Let me tell you why.
My oldest son started at fourth grade at Dyett.
When he got accepted, his reading level was very low.
He was reading as a second grade level.
At this time, he's up to grade two level, and he's already reclassified as an English-only speaker.
I know that you are concerned about the education of our children, and if you really care about them,
Please do not deny them the opportunity to have a good education in a place where our children are educated with values and they are treated like a family.
Thank you.
Ken Bird on behalf of the California Teachers Association.
I have a request.
I don't want it to come against my time.
I'm going to speak on 17 and 18.
I'd like my two minutes now.
Is that And you can't come back?
Okay.
I promise.
All right.
If you guys vote no right now, I'll leave.
Okay.
Go ahead.
That's a deal.
All right.
Thank you.
The cart is before the horse on this item.
The idea that if this charter school does all these things to satisfy all these conditions, the department will determine X is the case.
That's entirely wrong.
The facts should be brought forth.
It should be done in a public meeting.
You should have it.
We should get up and argue and say, did they really make the showing that there's not a problem?
I don't mean to be disrespectful, but when all the conditions were read, I almost said, well, maybe they should take a daily lie detector test too.
In other words, and then report back later to see if they continue to tell the truth.
The cart is before the horse.
The other thing is, I get calls from people in the legislature, and they ask me, I'll clean it up a little bit, what's the board doing?
Why did they act on this last thing?
What happened to common sense when you come to Sacramento?
Do you pack it up in a suitcase or what?
And so I guess all I'm really going to say is I wrote a fairly long letter going back to one concept, and mercifully, maybe the legislature will limit your authority in this area, and that is
the local school district, respectfully.
The local school district's in a position to know what's going on, and they have to work with these groups, and they have to work together.
And this is just out of control.
I guess the best way for me to put it together is, Sunday is Mother's Day.
And I don't know about your mother, but I remember my mother told me, if you fool me once, shame on you.
But if you fool me twice, shame on me.
Lorraine Richard on behalf of California Teachers Association.
CTA is opposed to the petition.
Similar to what I had expressed previously, local control is essential to maximize education of all students and democracy is practiced at the local level in order to elect those individuals to be on the school board.
Similar to Los Angeles Unified School District, those individuals were elected and they have denied the charter petition.
And as we know, there are other charters that are in Ally Unified, but this one is not meeting their requirements to approve it.
Also, fiscal matters of education need to be addressed.
We've heard great stories of success and successful students.
I'm sure the students work very hard and the educators work very hard at the school.
But there is also another side to an operation of the school and those are obligations of fiscal matters.
And since those need to be addressed, those monies are also being kept essentially from the success of the students.
So in this case, we've also have heard and have seen documents.
Is there clarity?
Sorry.
Thank you.
Good morning, Michelle Lynch on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
As you can see, this is a very high performing school with a lot of support in the community.
We want to thank the CDE for working with the school since the ACCS meeting and since they submitted this petition and for their willingness to continue to work with the school if you do approve it today to ensure these kids continue to be served.
We do ask today that you approve this appeal.
Thank you.
Eric Premack Charter Schools Development Center.
We support the staff recommendation and commend both the staff and even LA Unified for their hard work in trying to understand this complex corporate environment.
While it is complex, it is increasingly common in the charter sector and it's extremely common in the large-scale nonprofit sector generally as well.
It does raise a lot of interesting questions about
transparency, how deep do we look, how do we build the capacity of authorizers to do that complicated work when we rely on districts, many of which don't have the staff to do it, to do it.
And we do need to resolve those issues, but I hope that that won't hold up the approval of a charter here that's from an excellent organization with a strong track record and very sophisticated board and management.
Thank you.
And that ends the public comment.
All right.
I think this is a good time for the board members to get your lunch.
We're going to bring them back into the room.
So we'll adjourn and reconvene at 12.07.
All right, the State Board will reconvene and at this point, we're ready for board comments.
Typically, the liaisons to the charter school area and the people that attend the advisory committee on charter schools lead off.
So, I'll see if...
It looks like Bruce would like to make a comment.
Yeah.
I think I will pass at this moment because there were a number of outstanding questions I think the board members wanted to have answered.
Okay.
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
First of all, I want to thank the parents and the students and the teachers that have joined us today.
We actually have something that we share in common.
We both want quality educational opportunities for our students, in particular students in some of the most neglected communities.
But we're also looking at different things, right?
I'm looking at the entire structure that was presented today, not just the school site level.
And it's great that you have a positive experience.
That is what's expected in any school.
I have a question about everything else that's happening above the school.
And
And I really have to just lead with this federal investigation and some of the allegations.
And I want to know what are the allegations and how are you responding to those allegations?
How are you explaining this to parents, to community members, to all of those who have entrusted you with their students' education?
Thank you.
Thank you for the question.
First of all,
Again, I'm glad we have the opportunity to address the question.
I don't think your mic is on.
The red mic is on.
You should be good.
You're okay.
Go ahead.
Okay.
We really do welcome the question.
We feel it's important.
It's important to our board members.
It's important to our stakeholders.
Let me give you a little background on the investigation that I think is important.
First of all, the questions that were originally raised and presented to Solarity were presented in the beginning of June of 2015 in connection with an LAUSD OIG audit.
That audit took place for about six months and I know personally because I was involved in responding to the questions that the district posed.
The district sent staff and auditors to Solarity's administrative site.
They went over all of our documents and records.
I've heard them say here today that there has been a lack of transparency.
I find that mystifying because we have answered questions, we have created charts, we have created spreadsheets for them in response to their questions that were originally all arose out of the OIG audit.
After about six months, we had asked whether or not we would have the opportunity to take a look at a draft audit report, and they said no, which was okay.
We expected that, but then we never heard anything.
We didn't hear anything in connection with the OIG audit, and we never have.
There's never been a draft audit.
There have never been any negative findings, and many of the same questions that I've heard them say today were raised now over two years ago.
We fast forward to January 25 of this year, when we first became aware that there was a federal investigation through the Department of Ed Office of the Inspector General.
This issue was raised last time we were here in front of the ACCS.
And standing at this very podium, I said the same thing that I'm going to say now, which is, it is our understanding from our communications with the US Attorney's Office that LAUSD is the complainant in that investigation.
And I said at that time, back then, I asked the ACCS commissioners to ask LAUSD, are you the complainant in connection with the federal investigation?
Or they can come up and deny it, and they never did.
We believe that the district actually, not having successfully convinced their auditors to receive a negative audit report, presented the same allegations to the US Attorney's Office.
For what it's worth, I'm very familiar with this US Attorney's Office.
I was a federal prosecutor myself for 11 years.
I was the Deputy Chief of Public Corruption and Government Fraud, the very section that would be responsible for this investigation.
if I were working at this time.
And I myself have supervised, in fact, conducted many United States Department of Education Office of Inspector General cases, criminal cases.
And I can tell you that from our understanding, we are continually communicating with the U.S.
Attorney's Office.
In fact, we did so just as of yesterday.
There have been no subpoenas.
There have been no interviews.
We have no reason to believe anybody at CEG, any of its board members, any of its officers, are targets of this investigation.
They have our documents and records, which we would be happy to provide them, and we have been providing them with information, and we'll continue to cooperate to resolve this investigation.
So, I mean, I have to say,
We take the existence of any investigation with great gravity.
But I think it's also worth knowing that this appears all of the things that you are hearing about from the CTA and other comments have followed on the existence of the federal investigation.
The federal investigation began.
Then there began LA Times articles.
Then after that,
Compton asked, well, what about the LA Times articles?
And then WASP asked, well, what about the LA Times articles?
And ACC asked, well, what about the federal investigation?
And we're addressing it here today.
We're happy to do so.
We're happy to deal with specific issues that arise with it.
But if LAUSD is the complainant,
And it is the same things that they raised two years ago, that we don't have a negative audit report.
That also should factor into your consideration as to whether or not there is evidence of fraud or anything else.
And let me say this.
I heard somewhere in the presentations that there are, that there are, quote, allegations of fraud against CEG.
That could, that
is completely untrue.
The search warrants that took place, all the affidavits are all under seal.
But there are no allegations of fraud against anyone at this juncture.
None.
And if there is any, I invite whoever is saying that there are allegations of fraud to come up and explain specifically where they have heard those.
Because I am in constant communication with the very assistant U.S.
attorneys that are running this case.
And they haven't told me that in response to direct questions.
So, in terms of communication, we have tried to communicate what we can about this.
And, you know, we are still going to work through this.
We believe all of this is resolvable.
And we believe that in many ways this is a waterfall, a waterfall, the head of which actually began with LAUSD itself.
But let me leave that point aside for a moment.
I do want to emphasize one overriding message to the board, and that is celerity is not wedded to any corporate structure.
We are not here to say we have a corporate structure in the past.
We want to keep it.
Nothing could be further from the truth.
We actually would want to work with you to have direction from you as to what you would like to see.
And leaving aside what is legal, what happens in other nonprofit settings, leaving all of that issue aside, we'll do, in essence, what is necessary to keep our schools running.
That, plain and simple, we are not here to argue about legality or how a statutory sole member structure works for other nonprofits, even though it is a common thing.
We're not going to point out, well, other charter schools, in fact, have the very same structure and they've been approved.
And we don't even have to get to the point where LAUSD previously approved this very same structure in connection with Himalayan Rollas.
We don't have to do that, OK?
We are here to tell you we're happy to change.
And frankly, one of the things I didn't get to mention is we passed two, the board passed two resolutions.
The second resolution was specifically an Audit and Compliance Committee.
The Audit and Compliance Committee of the board has been charged with, among other things,
managing and supervising the management audit that was one of the conditions that the recommendation, staff recommendations to the board, and they will manage that process.
In fact, Ron Ben-Yehuda and Kurt Hessler are on that subcommittee.
And there's a, there's an actual auditor, Francisco Mares, who's on that committee too.
So, what we are trying to communicate to the board is that since the time that we had our last hearing, there have been enormous steps forward.
We are not wedded to having global provide services.
There was a time in the beginning of Solarity's
building of its structure when it was not only appropriate, but it was necessary.
But as I said before, as we have matured through our organizational growth, we can look at
hiring those individual services out, and we have.
I mean, we have now issued RFPs, or we actually are about to issue RFPs for specific services.
We're advertising for specific employee positions that would cover some of the global services, and we are actively pursuing all of that.
With respect to transparency, we are about to make live a tab on our website that's going to post all the documents that we've posted to staff there so that anyone can see them.
So we're going to have a transparency website.
I'm going to interject because I don't believe that you answered my question.
But I want to make sure that my colleagues also have an opportunity.
I was part of the yes vote in the previous two and I had a lot of concerns back then.
And I continue to have some of these concerns.
I don't believe that I got an answer from what you said, but I'm glad that there is some steps towards transparency.
I think that there is a little bit of perception here.
You know, I was looking at your fiction and facts really quickly.
And the first one, I had a question about Ms.
McFarlane.
And then I was wondering, where is she?
You know, where is Ms.
McFarlane?
And people identified her in different places in this org here.
But what I think what's interesting about the fact versus fiction is that her salary being compared to Dr. King's salary and saying, you know, it's apples to apples.
One had to oversee less than 4,000 students.
The other has to oversee about 500,000.
That's not apples to apples.
And so just looking at that fiction fact, that perspective alone just kind of shows me a little bit of how the lens that's being used to look at this.
Thank you.
Yeah, I think she has no further questions.
So, and let me discuss a little procedure.
You're dismissed.
Thank you.
About, it seems to me that we ought to let LA Unified respond to these kinds of comments immediately.
If I go through the queue, we get sort of off of it.
And I think it's only fair since a lot of allegations were made about LA Unified that they have a chance to respond to this.
Thank you, President Kirsten.
I think the first allegation or statement that was made by Mr. Suss that LAUSD is the complainant regarding the federal investigation, we would just like to clarify.
We are here today regarding the findings of fact made in October of 2016 regarding these two schools.
Those were based on oversight findings by the Charter Schools Division.
The OIG is an independent agency, independent body from LA Unified School District.
It's a statutorily independent investigatory agency, and we do not have information regarding the investigation.
I am not sure what the relevance is, whether or not LAUC is the complainant or not.
I'm not a white criminal defense attorney like Mr. Suh is, so I actually do not know how to respond to those allegations.
Any other comments you want to make about anything he said?
You have a question for them?
That was the primary one.
One other comment that was made was that LA Unified School District has approved other charter schools with sole statutory members.
That's absolutely correct.
The big differences in this case is that in those charter school organizations, they have either proactively come to us to discuss the governance change and the creation of a statutory member,
We have had the opportunity to vet those affiliation agreements that they have created.
We have established parameters regarding the relationship between the Charter Authorizing Governing Board and the sole statutory member.
And in other instances where they have already established a sole statutory organization, we have not had any pushback regarding
obtaining information documentation of the sole statutory member corporation.
And that's the problem with that organizational structure, is that, you know, many times when things were asked previously of Solarity, it was, you know, we're a different organization, they're not a part of us.
But as you can see, they definitely are.
And the sole statutory member is definitely connected.
And we can't trace the money there because they're not public agencies.
They're non-profits.
They're not, we don't, so we can't get an audit.
Now, many of our schools voluntarily give us audits of the sole statutory, but we can't demand that.
So once money is transferred over into that, it's kind of like a black hole.
We don't know where it goes, and it's public money, and that's what concerns us.
And what concerns us even more is that we're talking about seven schools today.
And we've already spent hours trying to understand the management of seven schools.
I don't wrap my head around it.
Hey, who's next on the queue?
Pat Parker.
Patricia.
Okay, I have a question for you.
In your presentation, you enumerated three corporate rights that Global has concerning the fiscal management of CEG.
Did you enumerate with those three corporate rights?
I'm sorry.
Yes.
Yes, the first one is the power to elect and remove celerity educational group board members.
The second is to dispose CEG assets.
The third is to merge CEG with other corporations.
And there's actually a fourth one, the power to dissolve corporation.
Merge with other corporations.
dispose, merge, and dissolve, basically.
You're welcome.
Who's next?
Pardon?
Okay.
LA, please stay.
It's just a follow-up and I'm not sure if you're the right one to answer it, but I am mystified by this sole statutory member.
What is the purpose of establishing that?
It's a question that actually the Charter Schools Division, the district, our board has grappled with.
And our understanding is, I mean, let me start by saying that it's actually in the California Corporations Code, Section 5056.
So it is a legal statutory right to establish these kinds of corporations.
When I've drilled down in discussions with other counsel for charter management organizations as to what the purpose is for a membership organization,
there are various reasons.
One is to basically, as stated by CEG today, is to separate the local kind of governance of the group with fundraising duties of a higher organization.
I'm not saying that that's the structure that Global and CEG has.
That's one of the reasons that's been provided.
Another one that has been stated is something that I am not wholly familiar with, but has been provided to us as a rationale, which is related with IRS regulations regarding nonprofits.
Those are some of the reasons.
But as we've been pretty public about our position regarding sole statutory memberships, we do have concerns.
Nonetheless, we do have these organizations and we're trying to work around their corporate structures.
and making sure that we have oversight over the dealings between the charter school and the sole statutory member.
We have introduced legislation limiting the powers of sole statutory memberships vis-a-vis the charter schools.
We do not think that it's wholly aligned.
Unfortunately, that legislation has not come to pass, but we have been pretty public about our position, our legal position regarding sole statutory membership.
And we have added language in our petitions for those schools that have it, that by virtue of the charter itself grants us more access.
I have a question.
Yes.
I think it's going to be a back and forth deal.
So, I want to make sure I know who I'm speaking with.
Could you identify yourselves?
My name is Greta Proctor.
I'm an attorney at Procopio and we represent Solarity Educational Group.
And again, Maurice Sa from Gibson Dunn.
And you're representing?
Solarity.
So, both of you represent Solarity, but can you speak on behalf of or answer questions that I would have concerning the authority of Global?
Absolutely.
Okay.
So,
My first question is, I heard you say in response to questions from board member Ortiz-Licone, that you are already pursuing contracts or agreements with other vendors that would supplement, supplant or altogether replace some of the agreements that you have in place with Global.
Is that correct?
That is correct.
And moreover, we have just passed... Okay.
I just want to, let me stick with that.
And so in doing that, would any of those changes be a material revision in what's actually written in your charter right now concerning your organization and governance structure?
And because of the potential that changing the corporate structure and or the contracts could create a material revision, we've reached out to LAUSD and CDE as authorizers to go through that process collaboratively, which is why the board hasn't taken firm steps yet.
Okay, so he said no, and you said to the extent it could, you're going to take some other steps.
So it's either yes, it's a material revision, or I don't know, or no, it's not.
That's not exactly accurate.
There's a fourth answer, which is maybe.
It depends on how much of the services are contracted out to other entities.
So, to the extent that you're pulling out a small piece of what Global does and putting it to another vendor, that's not a material revision.
To the extent that you're pulling out all of the contracted services, I think that that probably would be a material revision, but we'd want to talk to the authorizer about that.
Okay.
Is Global actually able, since Global has these enumerated corporate rights over CEG,
And okay, so before I ask these next couple of questions, let me just be transparent.
I was the no vote in November concerning approving the other charter that you had before the board.
So in asking these questions, I'm not posing them to propose a condition for approving your
charter today either for item 17 or item 18.
I want to understand going forward what changes could be contemplated by you to address the serious concerns we have about your governance structure.
Is global actually able to relinquish or nullify their power to elect and remove the board?
Is Solarity actually able to pass a resolution demanding that global do that?
Is Global actually able to nullify or surrender their power to dispose of CEG assets?
The relinquishment of the sole membership would relinquish the rights that are provided under statute, which have been misconstrued a bit.
But yes, that bundle... Okay, in regards of whether they've been misconstrued, is that something that Global is able to nullify or surrender as a right?
Yes.
And is that something that the CEG board has to take action to request or can Global just simply do that?
level can do that.
But again, it creates a material revision issue, which is why it has not been done up to this.
Since November, it has not been done.
You knew this was an issue that was raised by the board in November by me in particular.
And you're coming back to this board today.
And that is not something that you addressed or discussed up until the moment it was asked by board member Ortiz-Lincoln.
And now you're telling me that this is something you could do, but it just hasn't been done.
I want to be clear about the timeline.
As soon as we left this board meeting, the CEG board openly and transparently discussed at a board meeting in early December changing the structure.
However, changing that structure midstream while an appeal is pending would mean that this board couldn't have heard the appeals for these Dyett and Troika charters, which were non-renewed
Well, that's not true.
This board has been very flexible in working with a lot of charters that have had to make some changes that the local and the county offices could not consider.
This board has been very flexible in working with charters
that have come up to the board on appeal and you have made both technical and very material revisions.
Well, I don't mean you, but some of those charters have made both technical and very material revisions as part of the conditions that the board approved for approving those charters.
So, that's not actually accurate.
So, a similar, another charter school made a similar change midstream while on appeal and that was determined to remove this board's jurisdiction to hear the appeal.
That was the authority.
I understand what you're saying, but it's just not true that it hasn't happened.
This board has actually done some of those changes as part of the conditions for approving the charter.
But again, I'm not asking those questions to suggest another condition.
I just want to be clear on exactly what kind of autonomy the CEG board actually has from global.
And I heard you saying, I know you want to answer this question, so I'm going to come back to you so you can answer it.
So you're telling me the CEG board actually can contract with other vendors even though the funds, it seems like the control of the funds to pay for those contracts belong to Global.
What I heard you say is you all are in the middle of contracting for some of those services that will go away from Global?
What I was saying, to be clear, is that we have formed
The board has formed an audit and compliance committee as well as passed a resolution to look at finding other resources that Global is currently providing and that they have developed RFPs and advertisements for those very positions.
And they are going to find the most competitive economically and best services to prevent any interruption of services to the school.
So I want to, this is a yes-no question.
So what you're telling me is you believe the CEG board has the autonomy to do that type of contracting and remove that contract and those services that currently flow from CEG to global and make a decision independent of that.
If you mean autonomy from global,
The answer is yes.
If you mean autonomy from all regulatory bodies, of course we would work with all the regulatory bodies.
In other words, if your questions deal with, well, can global put a stop to that, right?
Then the board, as it has passed its resolutions and is moving forward, has acted and will act completely independent
of global.
And while I'm on that, I want to correct two fundamental misstatements about global's authority over CEG.
Global does not have the ability to elect CEG board members and does not have the ability to dispose of CEG assets.
I mean, that
You just said they did.
That's why I asked the three questions I began with you said that.
They said those rights have been misconstrued.
Corporations Code Section 5056 sets out exactly what member rights are.
And when it comes to the disposition of assets, the right is actually to approve or disapprove
the CEG board's decision to dispose of all of its assets, all or substantially all.
So in the event the CEG board wanted to dispose of all of its assets, that is when and only when global's right as to assets would come into play.
It is not a broad right to dispose of CEG assets at will.
And I'm real clear that you can't elect the board members, but you do have the power to remove them.
Well, it's not us.
Yes or no.
You do.
Global does have the power to remove them.
Global has.
Yes or no.
Yes.
Thank you.
It has never happened.
The board has acted completely independently.
I understand it's never happened, which is why I asked the question.
Would they be willing to nullify that authority?
And you said yes.
And it's the same rights that the other charter schools around the state who have sole members.
It's the same rights that those members have.
And it's not because these rights were crafted by the entities to give power.
I understand.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Board member Williams.
My question is for the L.A.
team.
While we're on the subject of organizational structures, I'm curious about how common it is for a school district's OIG to conduct audits and investigations of its charter schools.
And what is the relationship of the OIG to the charter division within LA Unified?
How would that those relationships flow?
my understanding of an OIG and correct me if I'm wrong because I'm not a, you know, a master of this, but they were more like internal affairs to conduct audits and investigations and inquiries internally in an organization.
The statute regulating the OIG's existence is actually very specific to LAUSD.
So respectfully, I cannot answer how common it is for other school districts to use an Inspector General's office for the purposes of an audit.
The Inspector General's office has broad range of authority within the operations of LAUSD, including investigating and auditing our third party contracts and our
policy including the district required language that's contained in every charter petition indicates that they are subject to OIG audits and investigation.
So it's very transparent and it's, the OIG has conducted investigations and audits on charter schools in the district.
Not just Hilarity.
You said the statute, state statute?
Yes, the California Education Code has a statute on the LAUCD Inspector General's Office.
And just a little bit of follow up.
How long have, when did, have you all, has LAUSD, as long as you know, how long have they used the OIG for charter reviews and inquiries and investigations?
Is that relatively recently or is it decades or?
I can only speak from my experience.
I have been assisting the Charter Schools Division for approximately eight years and through that the OIG has assisted in audits and investigations.
Board member Williams also.
We do our oversight first and when things rise to a certain level in the specific instance, and we've shared this with you guys before, we got credit card statements that were redacted.
And that's what really began to raise the radar.
And we began to dig into it.
And we have forensic level accounting people on our team.
They begin to dig into it.
And when they reach a place that we feel like this is beyond the scope of oversight, then we may speak to the, we work through our Office of the General Counsel and we may speak to the IG.
Okay, and one last question related to this, and that is, and again, correct me if I'm wrong, I might have misinformation here, but isn't the OIG's work, its investigations, its inquiries, confidential?
Yes, investigations or confidential audits are eventually made public.
Okay.
So during an investigation, then if it was an investigation of a charter school, whatever, about whatever operations or anything else, they would not be privy to what was being looked at or asked or charged or alleged or?
Or wouldn't.
That's what I'm asking.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you.
Board Member Holliday.
I was trying to go back over some of the ACCS notes that I took.
I think you were asked about whether or not you were concerned about any form of nepotism in this organization.
And I can't remember the answer.
I apologize, but.
I don't recall nepotism from the ACCS meeting.
I do recall the mentioning of conflicts.
with overlapping of board members or officers and the related entities of Solarity.
Can you explain that please?
Sure.
Like I mentioned earlier on when I was up at the podium is that, you know, the former CEO of Solarity Educational Group.
She's now the current CEO of Celerity Global Development, the sole statutory member, as well as a vendor of CEG.
She's also a board member of Global.
She's also the CEO of Celerity Development LLC, Celerity Contracting Services, and Attenture, as far as we know.
Could there be other entities?
Sure.
But those are some of the overlap.
Okay, thanks.
Is it your understanding that CEG uses Global for financial back office services?
Yes, so we're aware currently, we're aware of two service agreements that CEG has with Global.
And that is a limited services agreement and a miscellaneous services agreement.
Both contracts state in there a per-pupil fee.
One, I believe, has a pupil fee of $799 per pupil.
for limited services.
The miscellaneous services contract charges $649 per pupil, which includes back office services, such as budgeting, financial support.
Yeah.
At the ACCS meeting, though, I believe someone from CEG indicated that Global actually subcontracts out the back office work.
So that was something that was very puzzling to me as well when I was looking over this is that Solarity Educational Group utilizes Solarity Global for back office services.
Solarity Global then has a contract with CSMC as a back office provider for their services as well.
So that's all I can say with regards to that.
And CSMC is also headed by the same person?
No.
Okay.
Who is CSMC?
You use these acronyms.
I'm sorry.
I don't.
Yeah.
Well, I don't.
I think I got the logic of it though.
Yeah.
Let's stick with that.
One of the.
Okay.
moments at the ACCS meeting that some of the commissioners were thinking about discussing was the fact that there is evidently a contract between Solarity Education Group and Global for back office services.
But at the same time, Global subcontracts out the back office services to this other organization.
That other organization, as far as we know, has no connection, no intertwining with any of these others.
They're just a back office provider that they hire.
All right, who's next?
Yeah.
Bruce is next.
Is that it?
No more?
No, that was it.
Okay.
Next.
There's no one else.
I just have one.
I have another question.
Just to...
try to understand the interweavings of all of this.
The attention, and maybe this is a question for Cindy or Nick, so feel free, I don't either.
One of the organizations that's described in our item, and this is on page, I don't know the page number, but it's under the affiliates and related contracts is Attenture.
Interestingly close to Accenture.
And that it's a technology support organization
And its member and manager is an entity called the Roane Group, R-O-N-E.
And it says the Roane Group is a tax blocker corporation owned by Global in order to protect Global's tax-exempt status.
What is a tax blocker organization, for gosh sakes?
Yeah.
Go ahead.
Yeah, right.
Yeah, how do we get these?
Right.
So, I think probably, you know, Solarity Council is probably better to answer this question anyway.
But I believe Accenture is a, or has been represented to us by Solarity.
Accenture, sorry.
As represented to us, Accenture, because it provides software and IT services, federal tax law,
tends to view that as a more of a for-profit sort of activity.
So they can't establish it as a non-profit.
They can't see, because global is a non-profit, global can't do it.
So they got to create this other organization and set up as a for-profit to do it.
And I believe there's a middle, an organization in between global and this,
you know, for-profit entity.
Now, they've represented to us that, yes, it's a for-profit entity, but all the profits go because Global is the member of that or the
the shareholder, the only shareholder of that entity, all the profits would go back to the benefit of global.
So that's how they've explained it to us.
But the actual workings of this sort of tax blocker, I think, you know, someone more expertise in tax law would need to address that.
So I mean, I'd sort of like to know on an intellectual level, but I don't think for purposes of this conversation, I need to have the specifics.
But I just want to say how troubled I am by all of this information.
And I didn't have the benefit of talking or attending the ACCS meeting, but
When I read the ACCS recommendation, which I tend to take with a lot of consideration in making my decisions, the ACCS is an entity that wants to do what's right by charters.
And we see that in almost all their recommendations.
When I read their recommendations, they were a very tortured body in trying to come to a conclusion about this charter petition, which says to me we have a major problem here.
And so I, you know, as one of the strongest charter supporters on this board, I am very, very troubled by where we've ended up with this organization.
We had a very, you know, robust conversation about it in November.
But additional information has come to light that gives me even greater pause about this.
And while I appreciate
how hard the department has worked to try to figure out how do we go forward with this.
I just feel like the recommendation sort of asked the board to take a leap of faith that at least for me, I'm not willing to take.
Okay, that's I think we're heading towards a recommendation by somebody.
And unfortunately that falls to me.
I sincerely want to thank all the people who traveled so far to come here today to provide testimony.
And I know that all of the board members have listened very, very carefully to all of your statements.
It's clear, however, I think that the board has significant concerns about this appeal and that the CDE as well.
So in order to make a motion that will actually fit charter law and this appeal law, I will simply state that I'm trying to take all of the concerns that I've heard and put it into the phrase of
a motion that I believe that the petitioners are unlikely to successfully implement the educational program and I move denial of the petition.
Do you second?
Yes, with a heavy heart I second.
I second that motion.
Okay, let's call the roll on this then if we're ready for the vote.
Bruce Holliday.
Okay.
Nikki Sandoval.
Yes.
Karen Valdez.
Olivia Sison.
Yes.
Trish Williams.
Mike Kirst.
Yes.
Elaine Strauss.
Sue Burr.
Yes.
Felicia Ortiz-Lujan.
Patricia Rucker.
Yes.
Okay.
It was unanimous.
All right.
That charter petition is denied.
Okay.
The board will reconvene and we're now ready for item 18, the Oxford Preparatory Academic.
19, sorry, 19.
Oxford Preparatory Academy.
So Cindy Chan, where?
So another very difficult item that we'll be probably presenting to you, item 19.
Again, this is Cindy Chan at the California Department of Education.
Item 19 is the third of four renewals that you're going to be hearing today.
It's an appeal by Oxford Preparatory Academy, Chino Valley to renew the charter school, which was denied by the Chino Valley Unified School District and not considered by the San Bernardino County Board of Education.
The CDE received the OPA Charter Appeal on January 31st based on a review of the petition documents and information submitted.
We are recommending that the State Board hold a public hearing and thereafter deny the request to renew OPA Charter under the oversight of the State Board for a five-year term effective July 1, 2017 through June 30, 2022 based on the CDE's findings.
that the petitioners are not likely to successfully implement the program set forth in the petition because of the petitioner's history of fiscal mismanagement, that OPA charter has presented an unrealistic operational plan,
And the OPA charter budget cannot be deemed viable due to the potential of undiscovered contracts, transactions, extended liabilities, loans, and obligations, and the lack of valid audit reports.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools considered the OPA charter petition at its April 5th meeting.
The ACCS moved a recommendation that the State Board approve the renewal of OPA charter contingent upon the charter school engaging with and maintaining an ongoing relationship with a third-party fiscal services organization such as the Fiscal Crisis and Management Assistance Team or FCMAT.
or an entity recommended by school services to ensure that all FCMAT audit findings and other concerns are resolved.
Five votes are required to move an ACCS recommendation forward to the State Board.
The motion did not pass by a vote of four to three.
Therefore, there is no ACCS formal recommendation before you.
OPA Charter currently operates a transitional kindergarten through grade eight school.
The mission of the charter school is to work collaboratively to develop lifelong learners in a safe and caring educational environment where pupils are challenged, scholarship is expected, and differences are valued.
OPA Charter's program is specifically designed to prepare pupils to enter competitive colleges and universities worldwide.
The petitioners proposed to serve 1,226 pupils in transitional kindergarten through grade eight in all five years of its renewal term, 2017-18 through 2021-22.
So I'll kind of briefly walk through the first set of criteria for renewal, which is academic achievement.
Again, the charter authorizer shall consider increases in people academic achievement for all groups of pupils served by the charter school as the most important factor for renewal.
In using these standard criteria for renewal, the charter school has to meet at least one of these five criteria related to academic performance, which again is mainly the academic performance index.
They're described on page four of your item.
In detail, we find that OPA charter has met four of the five criteria and has thus demonstrated increases in people academic achievement.
We also considered alternative measures that were presented for OPA charters pupil academic achievement and that's pursuant to statute that says alternative measures that show increases in people academic achievement for all groups of pupils schoolwide and among significant subgroups.
So we reviewed their academic data and found that they met and exceeded for four significant subgroups for 2012-13.
They met their target and that they improved 89% of their pupils maintained or improved their proficiency level from the interim to the summative assessment of the 2015 administration of the CASP, the California Assessment of Student Performance and Progress.
So to sum up, because OPA charter met the standard criteria for renewal, an analysis of alternative measures was unnecessary.
Nevertheless, we did look at more recent data due to the fact that the API data is a little outdated.
So then moving forward and looking into the petition and the multiple required elements.
We performed the independent review of the renewal petition and all the documents that were submitted to the school district.
Again, in terms of what we're looking for, and that could form a basis for a finding of denial, we looked at the petition, determined whether it met the criteria of presenting a sound educational program, that the petition contains reasonably comprehensive descriptions of the required elements,
and whether the petitioners are able to successfully implement the intended program.
Based on a review of the petition documents, we find that the educational program is adequately described and that the elements were sufficiently met, noting that there were some we identified as needing a technical amendment.
I want to point out, while we found no issues in the petition with the charter school's community outreach plan to reach racial and ethnic balance, at the ACCS meeting commissioners had expressed concern that the charter school does not participate in the frame reduced price meal program.
In looking at the data, we are also concerned that the decision not to participate in the program has likely been a significant factor in the disparity of socioeconomic levels that exist in the district and the charter school.
In looking at the data that the CDE has on their public website,
The district's percentage of students eligible for free and reduced price lunch is double to that of the charter school.
The charter school is at 22% roughly and the district at 43%.
So that was a discussion at ACCS and we went back and looked at the data in support of that.
So I'm going to focus more on the one area of finding the petitioner's ability to successfully implement the program.
For this particular criterion includes a number of factors and one of them is the financial plan.
We looked at the budget and all the financial statements that were provided.
And although they have projected positive ending fund balances in its multi-year budget for fiscal years 2017-18 through 2019-20, we have concerns about the fiscal operation of the charter school based on the FCMAT audit findings.
based on a notice of violation issued by a district of one of their other schools, which is
and also findings noted in the fiscal year 2015-16 independent audit report.
Another very critical factor of this criteria is the capacity of the petitioner.
And as you can tell, even with the last items that we had reviewed, this is a more difficult one.
I mean, when we look at the educational program and the elements in the charter, we have the documents in front of us.
So we're looking through paper, we're looking at the vision, at the plan.
Capacity requires a little bit more than that.
We have to also look at what's not in the charter petition.
We have to look at what the petitioner is bringing to the charter school and whether they have the capacity to implement that program and ensure that that school is going to be viable for the full term, in this case would be for five years.
So that takes us to one of the pieces of evidence that we looked at in terms of trying to determine whether they could meet this factor.
And it was the FCMAT Extraordinary Audit Report.
So I'm gonna go into quite a bit of detail on this one.
The audit report's quite long, so I'm not sure if you've read it, but I'll hit the kind of major pieces.
The background of the audit, and then the scope, and then the findings.
Pursuant to Education Code Section 1241.5c, a county superintendent may review or audit the expenditures and internal controls of any charter school in the county if there is reason to believe that fraud, misappropriation of funds, or other illegal practices have occurred that merit examination.
On November 23rd, 2015,
The, excuse me, the district superintendent expressed concerns in a letter to the San Bernardino County Superintendent of Schools regarding allegations of conflict of interest and self-dealing by Oxford Preparatory Academy.
So this is the, would be the CMO of the charter even though they have a similar name.
So I'll just refer to that as OPA.
The allegations included multiple fiscal irregularities, questionable expenditures, and inappropriate related party transactions at the charter school based on a preliminary investigation conducted by the district.
Due to concerns that the allegations may have violated various statutes related to fraud and or misappropriation of assets,
the county superintendent initiated an investigation to determine whether sufficient evidence of criminal activity exists to report the matter to the local district attorney's office for further investigation.
In July 2016, the office of the county superintendent entered into a contract with FCMAT to perform an assembly bill 139 extraordinary audit
of OPA's charter regarding the alleged fraud, misappropriation of funds, and possible illegal activity in the OPA organization.
FCMAT began fieldwork in August 2016, which included interviews, data collection, and documentation review.
They performed interviews that were conducted with county and district staff and the OPA charter executive director and executive team.
meetings were conducted with business office staff, current and former charter school employees, the charter school's back office provider, and the charter school's independent auditor.
FCMAT also reviewed, analyzed, and tested records that included but were not limited to audited financial statements, financial records, support documentation, board minutes,
memorandums of understanding, emails, contracts, payroll records, and other documentation from independent third-party and governmental sources.
FCMAT also identified the following OPA organizational entities, affiliated organizations, and executive staff that include, but not limited to, OPA, a non-profit public benefit corporation formed to manage and operate the two charter schools, OPA Chino Valley and OPA South Orange County, which is authorized by Capistrano Unified School District.
OPA Schools, a non-profit public benefit corporation formed in 2013 as the charter management organization over OPA.
OPA Alliance, OPA Schools was renamed OPA Alliance and Enlighten Learning Solutions.
OPA Alliance was renamed Enlighten, the CMO and sole statutory member of OPA.
Epic Youth Services, limited liability company, a for-profit company that provided financial and consulting services to Enlighten.
Educational Excellence, LLC, a for-profit limited liability company that provided services to Enlighten, whose founder is Brian Roche, Sue Roche's son.
And Sue Roche, former
founder of OPA, former chief executive officer and former executive director of OPA and Enlighten.
And Barbara Black, CEO and executive director of OPA, who resigned effective December 6, 2016.
So the audit report is lengthy and it contains a lot of audit findings.
I'm going to kind of just mention the probably the more significant ones.
So as a result of the fieldwork completed, FCMAT's final audit report identified findings that include the following.
So this is not all inclusive.
Occupational fraud, the lack of internal controls at OPA, and relationships between the founder, relatives, and close associates, and the founder's other nonprofit public and private corporations created an environment that made it possible for fraud to occur, including motivation and opportunity.
Conflict of interest.
Conflict of interest exists at OPA with charter officials participating in the decision-making process and exercising considerable influence that had major financial implications without full disclosure to the governing board.
Multiple transactions involve self-dealing with the founder's nonprofit public benefits and for-profit corporations that allowed the founder, relatives, and close associates
To gain financially from these decisions and contracts, these individuals participate in subsequent actions to contracts, including signatory authority and approval of payments on behalf of the charter schools.
California Corporations Code Section 5233.
Affiliated and related party relationship exists between the founder of OPA and her nonprofit, Public Benefit Corporations, and for-profit corporations that provided services through a daisy chain of companies evidenced by contracts, master agreements, and consulting arrangements.
The founder, several relatives, and close associates exercised significant personal involvement and financial interests violating conflict of interest statutes, the memorandum of understanding between the charter school and the school district, as well as their own board policies.
related party transactions significant influence in self-dealing.
The founder created a complex structure of charter management corporations that exercise significant influence over transactions and contracts between these entities and secured considerable financial benefit through contracts that charge management service fees up to 10% funneling funding from the OPA charter schools.
Affiliated and or related party organizations were intentionally created to divert and launder funds from OPA and conceal the use of these funds from the oversight agency, Chino Valley Unified School District, the OPA independent auditor, and all others that relied on the financial statements and independent financial audits.
Presenting the affiliated entities and related parties as simply vendors circumvented the district's agreements contained in the charter petition and MOU.
OPA management intentionally hid the related parties by failing to disclose in management representation letters to the auditors and the district, concealing the true nature of related party relationships and misleading independent auditors to file incorrect financial statements and audit reports.
Enlighten Learning Solutions.
Enlighten declined to cooperate and make its financial records or access to personnel available for purposes of the FCMAT audit.
So that is still pending.
Pursuant to OPA's amended bylaws, Enlighten as both the CMO and sole statutory member of OPA has broad legal power and ultimate control to remove any director with or without cause within the OPA organization.
Ed Leighton has a material economic interest in OPA, which OPA pays substantial CMO management fees to Ed Leighton.
From January 2013 through June 2016, OPA charter schools paid management fees of $4.3 million to Ed Leighton.
Of this total, OPA charter paid $2.4 million.
Enlighten's only source of income are fees mainly from OPA.
Enlighten uses OPA and its status as a CMO to move money from a public charter school, asserting that the CMO expenditures are not required to be part of the FCMAT audit.
Employees are leased between OPA and Enlighten as part of a master agreement for personnel services.
And then lastly, the Academies of Oxford Prep accounting record identified records identified loans totaling $376,000 from Enlighten to this organization using fees collected from OPA schools.
Gift of public funds.
FCMAT found several examples where expenditures for Enlighten health premiums, equipment leases, travel costs and other payments were paid with OPA's school funds, invoiced to the CMO and subsequently reimbursed.
These payments made on behalf of Enlighten are prohibited by the California Constitution as a gift of public funds.
Related party organizations were intentionally created to divert and launder funds from OPA and conceal the use of the funds from the district, the independent auditor and others that relied on the statements and independent financial audits.
The final FCMAT extraordinary audit report dated November 22, 2016 concludes that OPA charter may have engaged in fraud, misappropriation of assets or other illegal activities.
So other issues that we found were significant.
There have been notices of violation as a result of the FCMAT audit.
The district issued a notice of violation to OPA Charter on January 10th, 2017 stating that the district finds the violations identified in the FCMAT report are of substantial concern.
The district provided the charter school with the opportunity to submit a plan of definitive action by January 31st that would correct violations and prevent future violations.
The charter school submitted a response in writing to the district on January 31st.
Additionally, the other district, Capistrano, issued a notice of violation to OPA
I can't remember the acronym, to their charter school LPASOC on December 15th and that the district finds that the violations identified in the FCMAT report of substantial concern.
That district also provided the opportunity to submit a plan of definitive action from the charter school by January 2nd that would correct the violations.
Significant issues that are pending.
Accrediting Commission for Schools, Western Association of Schools and Colleges.
On February 1st, 2017, WASC issued a letter to OPA charter regarding the potential withholding of accreditation status.
The city received a copy of this letter via email on April 7th from the district.
The letter states that the charter school violated WASC policies around substantive changes, integrity of member schools, and disclosure information.
WASC offered the Charter School an opportunity to respond with reasons why accreditation should not be withheld by March 15th.
WASC reported to the CDE during a phone conversation that the Charter School did submit a response to the letter.
The letter responds to each of the violations identified in the letter and provides some additional documentation in support of their response.
WASC informed the charter school that it will postpone their decision until their June 26th, 27th meeting in the summer.
Another pending issue is Enlighten Learning Solutions.
Enlighten refused to provide financial and personal records to FCMAT even though there is clear evidence that Enlighten and OPA are affiliated and related parties.
This failure to disclose information prevents FCMAT from presenting all of the evidence of it related to OPA's fiscal practices.
Based on the information available, FCMAT identified again that management fees roughly $4.3 million plus another $450,000 from loans and rent bring the total revenues of $4.7 million to Edlighton from OPA.
FCMAT estimates that Edlighton has roughly $570,000 cash on hand as of June 30th, 2016 that should be returned to OPA.
Annual financial audits.
So FCMEC stated that the audited financial statements from 2012-13 through 2014-15 were misstated due to the fact that the charter school failed to disclose the complete, transparent, and true nature of the relationship between the charter school and Enlighten.
and recommended that the audited financial statements should be reissued with proper disclosure.
However, FCMAT notes that the auditor would not be able to consolidate financial statements since Enlighten has refused to make financial records available.
Furthermore, the independent audit for the most recent period ending June 30th, 2016 included a significant internal control finding related to financial reporting of related parties and conflicts of interest.
The audit finding states that OPA management concealed the use of $900,000 of unexpended funds from the auditors, governing board, the charter authorizer, and the state for purposes of conflict of interest and full disclosure reporting requirements.
At the April 5th meeting, ACCS meeting, OPA was asked about the status of Enlighten making financial records available for the audit.
However, the representatives were unable to confirm that.
And then lastly, the San Bernardino District Attorney investigation, again, pursuant to Education Code Section 47638 sub B, the San Bernardino County Superintendent of Schools shall notify the local district attorney if there's evidence that fraud or misappropriation of assets has occurred as our understanding that the FCMAT audit findings were provided and are communicated to the San Bernardino District Attorney and that the matter is still pending.
So to summarize, the CDE finds that after review of the FCMAT findings that OPA leadership failed to meet generally accepted accounting principles, engaged in fiscal and engaged in fiscal mismanagement.
Based on these findings, the CDE has serious concerns about the OPA leadership and Board of Directors ability to successfully implement the program given the history of fiscal mismanagement and lack of internal controls.
We would like to note that the Charter School has taken steps to address the FCMAT findings as noted in their cover letter to the CDE as well as to information that has been presented to both the ACCS and the State Board.
However, we find that these steps are insufficient in addressing all of FCMAT's findings since the actions to this to this date that we have found are not supported with a formal report by an independent organization with forensic level expertise and that all of the FCMAT findings have not been addressed and corrective measures and internal controls cannot be validated have been put in place without that independent verification.
With the level of severity of the fiscal abuse identified by FCMAT, we are skeptical that any corrective action addressing all of the findings could have been put in place and implemented in such a short time frame.
As such, the department is recommending that the State Board hold a public hearing
and thereafter deny to renew the OPA charter based on the finding that the petitioner is demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the program set forth in the petition because of the history of the petitioner's fiscal mismanagement.
They presented an unrealistic operational plan, and the budget cannot be deemed viable due to the potential of undiscovered contracts, transactions, extended liabilities, loans, and obligations, and the lack of valid audit reports for the last couple of years.
The petitioners, representatives from the district and or the county, and there's a representative from FCMA, in case you have any questions, are here to address the board.
Thank you.
Okay, this is the time for technical questions.
Okay, Board Member Rucker.
Cindy, all of us have received a letter from OPA related to today's hearing.
And what I'd like to ask you to do, because a lot of what you talked about is not addressed or reviewed in the letter.
I'd like to get, I don't know if you've seen this letter.
It was just delivered to us after, at some point, either just after lunch or during a break.
So I'd like to give this to you and ask if you could please just review it relative to the stuff that you talked with us about.
Because I want to make sure that what's presented here is actually addressed in the concerns that you raise.
Is that okay if I?
That's okay.
Yeah.
I took notes from what she talked about.
Legal evaluation.
No, it's not.
Oh, it's not a legal evaluation.
It's a four point letter from the attorneys representing OPA.
It's not a legal evaluation.
Did we get these two?
Okay.
Yeah, it's a four point letter that the attorney sent.
And while Cindy was making her presentation and going through the findings from FCMAT, one of the statements she made is that the organization agreed to develop a plan of correction
a plan of action.
That's not what's enumerated in the letter.
So I'm confused by what the findings were and the conversations that have happened between the department and FCMAT and this organization and what this letter says.
So I'd like to ask Cindy to review the letter.
and to help me understand the difference between what that letter is talking about and the conversation, she says, the organization is having in a genuine effort to try to address or fix and correct what was raised by FCMAT because that's not what I read in the letter.
I'd like to clarify.
I don't think that, I'm not sure if that letter is from OPA's attorneys.
I believe it's from Sue Roach's attorneys.
Okay.
It doesn't say that.
Is it?
I'll have to clarify.
It doesn't say who they're representing.
Well, that's why I gave it to Cindy to ask her to take a look at it.
I'm all.
So let's let them look at it.
But I'm also really leery.
We had this last time of people walking in with letters.
I mean, I.
I thought we, you know, we want to vet this stuff, not have last-minute stuff come in.
So I'm... It came in the mail today at one o'clock.
All the other letters that we received are in your Dropbox.
So there are letters from OPA's attorneys.
I think we need to set some deadlines on when we will consider something and not have handouts at the last minute that we haven't been able to read or study.
And asking CDE to read this on the fly.
I mean, this whole thing.
So I would request in the future we have some kind of hard and fast deadline and things not be
At the bottom of the agenda, it says that any, if they don't provide correspondence by noon on Friday before the meeting, then we won't, then they won't make it in the drop box that goes to you.
But you're right.
People often bring things to the meeting and who are unfamiliar with our processes and they often bring handouts to the meeting.
Okay.
Well, we'll talk about that.
So I want to.
Okay, go ahead.
All right.
I wanted to have the FCMAT person come up because Mike Fine, is he here?
No, this is a technical thing.
I don't think this will...
I think it's part of what Cindy did.
So in the pages of your audit 23, you say, because ELS did not cooperate with the FCMAA audit, many questions remain unanswered.
The following are major discrepancies and you list about 10 of them.
And then on, for example, I'm just picking out of the audit, because FCMAT's management did not make its books and because ELS management did not make its books and records available to the FCMAT investigation, FCMAT cannot confirm the disposition of the building's equipment and possession of ELS.
This is throughout there.
So in order to understand, I think what Cindy said,
there's still a lot unknown out there.
And can you talk about that in terms of what, you know, we have an audit report from you.
It says various things, but there's still this ELS organization, which is, you know, you were unable to obtain lots of things from.
So I'd like you to discuss that a little bit and then talk about the implications for the audit and its ability to be comprehensive.
Thank you, Dr. Kearse, members of the board and staff, Michael Fine, Chief Administrative Officer of the state's Fiscal Crisis Management Assistance Team.
As Cindy outlined very clearly, we were engaged by the San Bernardino County Superintendent of Schools to do an Assembly Bill 139 Extraordinary Audit.
As I think the board's aware, it is the exclusive right of the 58 county superintendents to call for such an audit.
And we are the agency that generally provides that with
reimbursement to the local agency so that it's not a financial burden to them.
In this particular case, reviewing the information that the district provided to the county office and that the county office provided us, we developed a scope.
And Cindy did a good job of outlining that scope.
But I think understanding the scope is important, Dr. Kirst, in part to your question.
There were three main scope points and I want to highlight
Two of those.
The first was determined whether the charter school engaged in related party transactions and if those transactions were conducted in accordance with established national and state policies, standards and procedures and were transparent in nature.
This goes to the district's concern that the charter organizations had not been transparent to them.
They were learning things on the fly as opposed to how they should learn them through their normal oversight process.
Subsections of that scope include conduct a review of plant property and equipment ownership and transfers of the charter school and any related party considered consolidatable.
This gets to account national accounting standards under the Financial Accounting Standards Board and Government Accounting Standards Board regulations.
And then also as Cindy highlighted to review independent annual audits for the period of time.
The second major scope point was to determine if expenditures made by the charter school are for legitimate educational purposes in accordance with approved contracts, purchase orders, and memorandum of understandings.
And Dr. Kirst, that actually is the point
that not being able to see the detail of expenditures that you highlight on page 23 from ELS is important.
However, we were, as the report shows, able to obtain a number of documents related to ELS and reach some conclusions.
What's important on page 23, that list of
unknowns items actually refer back to page 22, which is a summary of ELS's federal tax return, which was available to us through public sources.
And you'll see that they filed a return in August of 15 and amended it in June of 16.
And it was the amendments that we are questioning, the nature of those amendments.
And it gets to what were the expenditures.
There are a number of things pointed out as Dr. Kurtz has indicated.
Fees for service for non-employee, fees for services
for non-employee management travel and there were allegations with regard to where these funds being paid to individuals that were involved in the governance and management of OPA.
And so that's where the detail becomes important.
Was travel being, personal travel being paid for with these funds?
Was there additional
fees, stipends, salary, wages, whatever you want to call them, being paid to some of these individuals.
And that's where those details would have been important.
In part, we included this in our report really as a
in some respects as a path, a list of items that would be important for follow-up by law enforcement.
As Cindy cited to you, the Ed Code section that deals with our reports, when we determine based on the evidence available to us that there may have been fraud,
misappropriation of funds or other illegal fiscal activities and that's key.
The standard that we are to follow in the code is we determine there may or may not have been.
We don't prosecute as you're well aware of and we certainly aren't the judge in this case.
So we don't know that frauds occurred.
We believe there's sufficient evidence that there may have been.
That then triggers a reporting requirement as Cindy outlined that includes the local district attorney.
And so, in part, these would be things we would point to the local district attorney.
You need to develop your probable cause and work through this to get answers to these, whether that's in a cooperative manner with the parties or whether that's through their subpoena power, which we don't possess.
And Dr. Kirsch, did you ask about something on page 25?
Yeah, there's again ELS mentioned and you can discuss also I think why you can't obtain these things from ELS.
Yeah, I mean, why don't we have... So, certainly the code limits our reach as it does the county office and really kind of all of us to the charter school itself, right?
It doesn't go beyond that.
And as you've spent the morning and afternoon discussing these very complex
structures.
Eric has spoke about them.
We encounter these on a pretty regular basis.
There is a wall eventually that we hit.
In many, many cases the CMO or the EMO or whatever you want to call those other organizations are cooperative.
Many, many times they're cooperative.
In this case, ELS which was identified as the CMO was not cooperative with us.
And in fact we reached out to them and their attorney responded to us that both Mrs. Roach and ELS was not available to us and their records were not available to us.
What's important in our interpretation at this point is that OPA as we know it and ELS are one in the same.
They are the alter ego of
each other.
They are for all intents and purposes the same under the same control.
They're under the same basically functioning structure and so on.
And so to us they're one in the same and therefore we didn't interpret that wall as being where they interpret that wall.
That is that ELS should have under the code provided us
all of their documents just as the charter school would be obligated to provide us.
And so important on page 25 and this gets to the asset transfer issue and whether ELS is holding assets that actually belong to OPA and again Cindy identified some of those.
This actually goes back to page 19 and 20 where we reference a March 4th 2015 letter to the IRS by ELS.
Where ELS had applied for non-profit status to the IRS but they went further and asked that they be considered a school.
under IRC Sections 509 and 170.
And that's important because it gives them additional privileges, if you will, under the federal tax code.
And so in there, and I apologize for shuffling here.
I turned my pages upside down as I put them back in order.
In that letter,
their attorneys basically argued that
They weren't just a non-profit organization, but they were a school.
And they explained that they believe they qualify for the school exemptions pursuant to the integral part doctrine, which is a legal doctrine with respect to the tax code.
And they go on to cite some of that.
But basically, they are arguing to the IRS that they are, in fact, one in the same.
They exist for the same purpose, making our very point.
And this is actually the section we relied on.
The letter that was just distributed to you, I believe, actually says that we relied on, in our conclusions, on a memorandum of understanding with the district.
And in fact, it's the pleadings under penalty of perjury to the IRS in this March 15th letter that their attorneys wrote that we actually relied on to say that these are one and the same.
Because that was their argument.
The two organizations were one and the same.
That was their argument to the IRS.
And that's...
Important here because there's been a transfer of assets, as Cindy alluded to, including potentially modular buildings, furniture and equipment.
And they actually say this in their letter to the IRS.
Modular buildings, furniture, equipment and fixtures necessary for Oxford to operate.
And so if we have a charter school and we're concerned about its future and its ability to operate, which obviously is a determination you have to make, if some other entity
is in control of part of those assets that are needed, which was the argument to the IRS that these two are one in the same, then that certainly was a concern.
Just so you know, in a letter to the district less than two months later after the pleadings to the IRS, the OPA slash ELS disputed
that OPA and ELS in fact were one in the same and they disputed the fact that ELS held assets.
So, in May of 16, less than a year ago, they were still disputing that.
In fact, just about a year, you know, 13 months ago, they had argued to the IRS that in fact they were one in the same and that ELS held assets.
The significance here is that they've argued under penalty of perjury to the IRS that they're one in the same, alter ego of each other.
Therefore, the record should have been made available to us.
And so the non-cooperation, if you will, and I should clearly distinguish this.
OPA, as we know it as a charter school,
I would say fully cooperated with us and that's important.
ELS and its governance, the folks involved in its governance did not cooperate with us at all.
And yet, I think we interpret them as being at this point one of the same.
Consolidation of financial data then is also relevant here because to follow through with the accounting standards.
If you are, these two organizations are one in the same, they should be consolidated.
OPA in multiple documents argued that ELS was simply another vendor like all other vendors.
We just make payments to them when they bill us.
That's what they argued to the school district when the school district questioned them.
That's what they argued with us when we were doing our investigation.
That is actually not the relationship that they shared.
It was not a vendor-client, if you will, relationship.
Okay.
Thank you for that.
We ought to get some of this on the record and you'll be here in the rest of the time.
Other board member technical questions?
Board member Burr.
This is for Cindy, I think.
Thank you, Mike, for your presentation.
In our item, it says that on January 3rd, 2017, the San Bernardino County Office of Education approved a motion to not receive the renewal petition or establish a timeline for consideration of the appeal.
I did not know that the county office had the option to not consider an appeal.
Am I reading that incorrectly?
No, that was the same with Solarity.
LACOE or LA County Board of Education also did not consider.
They put it on their agenda, but then they don't hear it.
They don't, you know, they don't take an action on it.
So that seems to greatly diminish the ability of charter petitioners to get a fair shot at the local level.
And that's the whole process is supposed to rely on consideration of the district and then the county before they get it up here.
So, I just like to know what we can do about that to make them assume their responsibilities.
The legal question, yeah.
All right, Judy.
If that would require a statute change right now, the county board would have to prove to have the ability to choose to not hear it.
And in some cases,
It's in the agreement of both parties to not hear, and in some cases, it's that the CAF is to speak.
Okay, so that clarifies that issue.
We'll have to, it's a statutory problem from that standpoint.
Yes, we'll open the public hearing.
Okay, I will give 10 minutes each to each side and we'll start with the group of the petitioners for the charter.
That group, please come forward.
Go ahead.
Good afternoon, Board President Kirst, members of the State Board of Education, Assistant Superintendent Price, and staff.
My name is Denise Pasco, the Interim Executive Director of Oxford Preparatory Academy Charter Schools.
The graphs you have before you are last year's CASP results for our Chino Valley campus.
Our student results outperformed the local school district, the county, and state averages.
With a student population of Hispanic 49.5%, Caucasian 22.1%, Asian 13.4%, African-American 2.2%, Filipino 5.9%, and two or more at 6.9%, we were the number one K-8 school in San Bernardino County.
Good afternoon.
My name is Andrew Vestey, board chair of Oxford Preparatory Academy.
I appreciate the opportunity to update you on the action this board has taken over the past six months to restore integrity and transparency to our operations and governance.
Last November, when the FCMA audit was issued, our parents were devastated to learn what our founder, Sue Roach, had done.
It was her job to protect our children.
Instead, she used our children to enrich herself and her family.
It was wrong.
It was immoral.
It was unforgivable.
We knew we were about to lose something very special because of one person's greed if Oxford didn't fix the problem.
After all, we are Oxford Prep, not Sue Roach.
This is our school.
Parents, students, and community members came together to say enough.
They wanted everyone who was responsible for this tragedy out.
They demanded Barbara Black, the executive management team, and the former board chair be removed.
Three parents were now in charge of the board of directors.
While this was new territory to us, FCMAT provided a roadmap to recovery.
We hired experts to help us navigate the legal issues.
We hired new auditors and a back office provider, Charter Impact, to help us unravel the mess the previous administration had created.
We removed anyone who was in a position of authority that led to the fiscal mismanagement or culture that allowed it to happen.
The CMO ELS, gone.
Sue Roach, gone.
Barbara Black, gone.
The entire management team, gone.
The entire board of directors, gone.
12 people eliminated.
The only people left were teachers, chancellors, and classified staff.
and five strangers driven by one passion to save a school for 1,200 innocent children who did nothing wrong.
The new board put our skills to work to turn things around.
We knew we were starting from scratch.
We had to rebuild our budgets from the ground up.
We didn't even have access to all of our bank accounts.
The past management made all decisions at the top and tightly controlled everything.
Now we understood why.
Our renewal petition was due in less than three weeks at the county.
So we needed an interim management team who had knowledge.
Sorry, had knowledge.
of our educational program to lead our renewal efforts.
Our chancellors who had administrative experience and knew our curriculum were the best choices.
Let me be clear.
We carefully vetted our chancellors.
They were school level employees who had no authority over operational decisions or finances.
Three separate independent auditors agree.
The chancellors didn't even have access to their own budgets.
Again, all money and decisions were tightly controlled at the top.
Over the next six months, this board would hold 21 board meetings and approve 11 new policies and procedures to correct the concerns that led to the alleged fraud and misappropriation of funds.
We also hired an independent third-party financial management company to take over disbursements, budgeting, payroll, and bookkeeping.
In five months, we eliminated all conflicts of interest, put internal controls in place to ensure something like this can never happen again.
We also filed a lawsuit against Sue Roach and ELS to recover public funds.
But the board wanted another layer of safeguards.
We hired a state-approved auditing firm to complete independent monthly reviews to our finances and internal controls to ensure they were effective and our finances were clean.
Two monthly reviews have been completed and no concerns have been reported.
The ACCS recommended as a contingency of our approval that we also contract with a third-party fiscal service to ensure all FCMAT audit findings had been addressed.
We immediately contacted FCMAT, and discussions led to the selection of Christy White and associates to complete the verification.
We received this results slide from Christy White last Friday.
A score of one is best, indicating the corrective action had been implemented.
Four have been resolved, and three require minimal action to complete.
Number one, lack of internal controls.
All internal controls are in place.
This portion will be complete when the board and staff complete their ethics training, which is currently underway.
Number two, failure to disclose related party affiliates and transactions.
This was an issue with Oxford's financial audits.
We just received the draft of our reissued audit showing related party affiliates.
Once the final audit is submitted, this will be complete.
Improper use of public funds on personal expenditures.
We are in the early stages of litigation against Sue Roach and ELS.
Once public funds have been recovered, this will be complete.
Oxford has 2,500 students in three schools with three different authorizers.
Chino Unified continues to say our board lacks transparency.
Our other authorizers disagree.
Capasana Unified and the Orange County Board of Education have not only acknowledged but commended us on our transparency and continuing dialogue.
Consequently, neither has moved to revoke our charters.
Same governance, different outcomes.
It has been clear since the beginning, Chino is interested in one outcome, closing our school.
Orange County wants to save them.
While we have done everything that has been asked of us, if this board decides additional changes are needed, we will accept any technical amendments or conditions to keep our school open.
The CDE believes the steps we have taken to resolve the concerns raised in the FCMAT report are insufficient and therefore we should be denied.
However, that was prior to receiving the FCMAT review from Christy White indicating all remaining concerns have now been addressed.
Let me answer the eight CDE questions that stands between Oxford and renewal.
We have one board member who was a founding parent and had nothing to do with previous board or management.
He has voted in favor of all corrective actions.
Two board members have finance experience.
One is CBO trained in budgeting and finance and has 14 years of clean audits with no findings.
The other has 25 years of experience in public and private oversight, auditing and accounting.
The organizational chart in our petition states that our chancellors will report to our executive director.
Currently, our chancellors report to the managing director.
OPA's nepotism policy allows too much latitude.
We agree.
We changed this at our March 27 board meeting.
The findings from three audits became our recovery plan, the foundation for our efforts to recover funds.
The board has attended fraud training, Oxford has no leased employees, and two signatures are required for approval of any expense over $10,000.
Those signatures are the executive director and board chairman.
As you can see, all eight of the CDE's remaining concerns have been resolved.
We have taken full responsibility for the actions of Sue Roach.
Please don't judge us today what she did, but by what we have done to restore integrity and trust.
Andrew Crow and I have been in support of a National School Lunch Program since we joined the organization.
To move forward with our plan, we have entered into a contract with School Food and Wellness Group to provide assistance in conducting and managing the administrative aspects of the National School Lunch Program, and we are on track to begin this at all campuses this next school year.
This has since been approved by CDE.
Our team and six independent financial experts, legal experts, and auditors have spent countless hours reviewing every transaction, contract, and correspondence to determine if there were any unknown obligations.
No new obligations have been discovered.
On April 27, 2017, our board voted to pay off our only remaining loan.
We are aware of exactly what our extended liabilities are, and we have ample cash reserves to meet all of our obligations.
We are projecting the school to finish the year with a surplus of over $1 million and with combined cash and public receivables of approximately $1.8 million and zero long-term debt.
The budget projections contained in the chart show a large and growing ending fund balance over the next five years.
The projected cash balance is 10.1% of projected full year expenses.
According to our financials, we are very strong in spite of all that is taking place, and we still have a wait list of students wishing to be admitted.
I'm Andrew Crow.
I'm the interim managing director.
Oxford Preparatory Academy is the only charter school in Chino Valley.
Our families come from three neighboring counties.
With everything in the news currently about social emotional issues, anxiety, and a lack of welcoming environments, the last thing we want is children as young as five years old to be forced to schools that don't want them and can't challenge them academically.
There are two paths in front of you today.
One path allows our students to continue excelling at the number one K-8 school in the entire county.
The other is filled with despair, stress, and underperformance.
Please don't force my kids down that path.
The majority of our kids, my kids, the kids I fight for every day, will be forced to homeschools that are drastically underperforming.
Our kids deserve the Oxford path instead of the alternative.
At Oxford, we are successful for all students because we use SDI strategies, teach ELA content standards through social studies and science, and set rigorous collaborative goals at IEP meetings.
Please take a moment to look at what will happen to our English learners, our SCS disadvantaged students, and students with disabilities if you close their school.
How can we set high expectations for our kids that need us the most when we are closing the school that serves them the best?
So for the 989 returning students and the 623 families that filled out intent to enroll forms for a school that might be forced to close, their future depends on you.
Please vote in the best interest of our kids.
Thank you.
Okay, now we have 10 minutes for the opponents of the petitioners.
Good afternoon, honorable members of the State Board of Education.
I am Stephen Archadish, your counselor for the Chena Valley Unified School District.
My superintendent, Mr. Wayne Joseph, is here today also.
Today, the district asks that the board adopt the CD staff recommendation.
to deny the Oxford Charter renewal based upon CD's finding that the Oxford petitioners are not likely to successfully implement the program set forth in the petition because of Oxford's history of fiscal mismanagement and because Oxford has presented an unrealistic operational plan
And because OSHRA's budget cannot be deemed viable due to the potential of undiscovered contracts, transactions, extended liabilities, loans and obligations, and the lack of valid audit reports, we believe the CDE, we ask
Not because our district is anti-charter.
In fact, our board voted twice to unanimously approve OPHNO in 2010 and again in 2012.
And we ask not without concern for Oxford students.
Instead, we ask because we have statutory oversight over OPA's fiscal condition.
And as you have heard from Mr. Fine, FCMAT found that the Oxford Board Administration staff and Oxford's culture permitted Oxford's founder and former executive director to divert over $4.7 million of public funds.
We asked also because we see the parents of Oxford students' reaction.
Our perspective on their reaction is that our district has accepted 129 Oxford student transfers this school year.
And additionally, our district has 449 Oxford student transfer requests for the 2017-18 school year.
Coincidence.
One year ago today, in a letter dated May 11, 2016, Oxford wrote, as for how and when funds have been spent by Enlighten, just like our other vendors, contractors, and service providers, Enlighten is a separate entity with separate records.
OPA cannot document, and it is unreasonable for the district to ask OPA to document how and when all funds were spent by the separate entity.
As you have heard at page 10, the CED notes that ELS has refused to provide financial and personnel records to FCMAT even though it is clear evidence that ELS and Oxford are affiliated and related parties.
What a difference a year makes.
Now, Oxford says a new Oxford Prep Board Administration along with staff and parent community are fully committed to restoring integrity and trust throughout the Oxford organization.
Isn't it interesting that Oxford admits its integrity has to be restored?
Why is that?
Maybe because the FCMAT audit stated this report provides sufficient evidence that affiliated and related party organizations were intentionally created to divert and launder funds from Oxford Preparatory Academy and conceal the use of those funds from the Oversight Agency, Chino Valley Unified School District, Independent Auditor of Oxford Preparatory Academy, and all others that relied on the financial statements and independent financial audits.
Members of the State Board, please note FCMAT's use of the word intentionally.
All this was no accident.
Oxford's board, management, and employees set out deliberately to deceive their oversight agency and Oxford's own auditors.
When I was a child, I always wondered, once someone starts lying to you, how do you tell when they stop?
Please remember that the CD states that OSHRA's current governance structure is essentially the same as it was when OSHRA's leadership engaged in fiscal mismanagement.
Again, that's what CD believes.
District acknowledges that the Oxford Board of Directors was replaced, but notes that the current Oxford Board members were unilaterally appointed by the outgoing Oxford Board implicated by the FCMAT audit.
And as the CD states, the change in executive leadership are not completely unrelated parties, as they served as school leaders within the organization when the fiscal mismanagement occurred.
At the March 2nd, 2017, Oxford board meeting, Oxford employees seized, redacted, returned, and then seized again and tore out entire pages of financial information regarding severance payments of public charter school money to Oxford's former executive director, Barbara Black.
From a board meeting packet that had already been distributed to members of the public,
in attendance at the March 2nd Oxford Board meeting.
This was done under the direction and the presence of the new Oxford Board and with the consent of Oxford's new back office service provider, Charter Impact.
More recently at the April 5th Advisory Commission meeting, Oxford seemed unaware of and failed to explain two $1 million loan agreements between Oxford and the California Credit Union
signed by then-Oxford Executive Director Barbara Black on August 31st, 2016, which had not been discovered by the district until March 24th, 2017, raising doubts regarding Oxford's claimed strong financial position and still more doubts regarding Oxford's supposed transparency.
Now, August 31st, 2016 is an interesting date.
Because why?
Because the Oxford
Oxford FICMAT audit was in progress.
So FICMAT is coming around and talking to them and investigating them.
And Barbara Black is signing $1 million loan agreements.
It's amazing.
At the April 5th Advisory Commission meeting, Oxford's Management and Charter Impact representatives were unable to adequately explain the two $1 million loan agreements.
While Oxford Interim Executive Director Denise Pascoe informed the Advisory Commission that Oxford has a $1.3 million line of credit, at the April 11th Oxford Board meeting, Oxford Board Treasurer Naveen Adly stated it was a $1.2 million loan.
The fact that even after the FICMAT audit, Oxford's governing body and management are unaware of the amounts and terms of Oxford's existing financial obligations is almost beyond belief.
Now let's talk about students, hungry students, because
After over seven and a half years of operations, Oxford still does not offer, may begin to, we've heard, free or reduced price meals in our district, where 46.4% of students are eligible for free or reduced price meals.
And in a neighborhood in which 72.5% of students attending an elementary school very near Oxford are eligible for free or reduced price meals.
The impact of Oxford's policy on the enrollment of socioeconomically disadvantaged students
as Ms.
Chan said, is clear from the smaller percentage of Oxford students eligible for free or reduced price meals, only 24.7% in my statistics, not much more than half of the district's free or reduced price meal eligibility of 46.4%.
At page 12, under enrollment barriers, the CD states that
The advisory commissions opined that the lack of a free or reduced price meal option at Oxford would prevent some families from enrolling at Oxford.
I wonder how that was.
We note that the San Bernardino County Board of Education raised the issue of Oxford's lack of a free or reduced-price meal program over 11 months ago at its June 10, 2016 meeting, but somehow Oxford still does not have a free or reduced-price lunch program.
For all the above reasons, Oxford's attempts to address the concerns originally raised by the district 14 months ago in March 2016, a lot of activity lately, hasn't there been, are much too little and much too late.
The April 6, 2017 Oxford response to the Advisory Commission staff report states, well, former administrators of OPA may be accused of improprieties by the district,
The former employees no longer work for the organization, nor do they have any say in the ongoing operations or governance of Oxford.
In other words, Oxford admits it has terminated former Oxford administrators who participated in the proprieties.
I believe you saw their chart.
But the district believes it is an odd consequence for Oxford when Oxford also admits it has paid over $212,000 in public charter school funds and settlement payments to four terminated former Oxford administrators.
For the State Board to renew Oxford today when the CDE finds after review of the FCMAT findings that OPA leadership failed to meet generally accepted accounting principles and engaged in fiscal mismanagement
And despite Oxford's exclusion of socioeconomically disadvantaged students and despite Oxford's failure to have taken sufficient remedial measures regarding its governance internal controls over five months after the FICMAT audit, according to CDE, is the district believes for the state board to send a clear message
that there are no real consequences for OSHRA's illegal acts.
For these reasons, the district respectfully requests that the State Board adopt a CD recommendation and deny OSHRA's Charter of Renewal Appeal.
Thank you.
Okay.
Ten minutes are up and we now have a list of public comment.
Close public hearing.
Would the following speakers please line up?
Jenny Blatner, Philip Vanderclay, Annie Ingridswood, Grace Park, Liz Penzik, Sandra Chen, Janelle Rooley, Eric Premack, Michelle Lynch, Spencer Stiles, Deborah Tarver, Naveen Adly, Vivian Sanchez, Sarah Marinko, Gavin Diaz, Brandon McNair,
Thank you for this opportunity.
My name is Jenny Bladner, and I'm going to try and put myself in your shoes and ask if this is a top performing school, why are we still in this situation?
I believe for a couple of reasons.
Your parents?
From Oxford.
OK.
OPA.
Do I get more time?
Yeah, you get more time.
Okay, we'll start again.
Please identify yourself as you come up.
Okay.
Again, thank you.
Jenny Blattner from Oxford.
And I try and put myself in your situation and in your shoes and ask if this is a top performing school, why are we still in this situation?
And I believe it's for a couple reasons.
First, it's critical that we're aware of all the changes.
However, at the hearing on April 5th, the district said the school's governance was essentially the same.
But I sent each of you a chart and it showed that there was nothing the same.
They also accused the new administration lack of transparency and said the line of credit was just revealed on March 24th.
However, it was actually reported in the first interim report on December 23rd.
The superintendent had a 35-year collegiate relationship with the former founder, Sue Roach.
And after she betrayed his trust, the new board and interim staff has suffered from less communication and openness to move forward.
Given the chance, they will rebuild your trust.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, Mr. Chair and members.
My name is Philip Vander Kley.
I'm a staffer for Senator Connie Leyva.
Senator Leyva would like me to convey her support for Oxford Preparatory Academy, Chino Valley, and their charter renewal.
This high-achieving school is located in the Senator's district and serves over 1,200 students with very positive educational results.
Though the previous fiscal conflicts and mismanagement were very troubling, OPA CV has since made significant changes to its structure and leadership in order to address those conflicts.
The proposed ongoing fiscal oversight and auditing is certainly appropriate because the proper use of public funds should always be insured, especially when dealing with our children's education.
The Senator has spoken with many of her constituents regarding their great experiences at OPCV, and she recognizes how the school's closure would disrupt their families' lives.
With these considerations in mind, Senator Leyva asks for your support of this charter renewal.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Board President Kurst and members of the Board.
My name is Ana Inglesrud.
I'm the Director of Special Education for Chino Valley Unified School District.
Oxford should not be renewed because Oxford has a history of failing to provide sufficient services to its special education student population and counseling out students with special needs that require and request additional services.
As already mentioned in regards to disparity of socioeconomic levels, I have concerns when I look at the students with exceptional needs within Oxford.
As a district, we average for 2015-16 school year between 12.1% and 12.2% of our students on IEPs, whereas Oxford is serving a student population of 7.5%.
I had a parent from Oxford approach me with serious concerns regarding Oxford's failure to provide additional services to her children with special needs.
The parent was given the choice of her child being held back or leaving Oxford.
As an LEA, Oxford is responsible for providing a continuum of placement in a setting that will meet the individual need of the student.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Grace Park and I'm the Assistant Superintendent of Curriculum Instruction with Chino Valley Unified School District.
Oxford, also known as OPA, should not be renewed because even after seven and a half years of operation, the school's demographics does not mirror the district's.
Neighboring schools from OPA have a socioeconomically disadvantaged Latino population that ranges from 85 to 88 percent.
Oxford, 62.9 percent.
Even more concerning, English learner enrollment at schools neighboring less than two miles away from OPA ranges from 25 to 43 percent.
Oxford, 8% are English learners.
OPA perpetuates a culture of excluding underserved populations and therefore should not be renewed.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Liz Pensick and I'm the Director of Business Services with the Chino Valley Unified School District.
There are a number of reasons why Oxford Preparatory Academy should not be renewed.
Number one, Oxford's consistent lack of financial transparency.
Number two, Oxford's failure to meet generally accepted accounting principles.
And number three, multiple violations of the 2012 fiscal oversight MOU between the district and Oxford.
Oxford also consistently omits and misstates key financial information in their budgets.
An example of this occurred as recently as March 24th, 2017, when the district was informed for the first time that on August 31st, 2016, Oxford had entered into a $1 million loan agreement with California Credit Union.
When asked to explain the $1 million loan agreement at the April 5th, 2017 advisory commission meeting, Oxford could not, and there was obvious confusion amongst their executive team whether it was in fact a loan or a line of credit.
To these reasons, among others, Oxford should not respectfully be renewed.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Sandra Chen.
I'm the Assistant Superintendent of Business Services for the Chino Valley Unified School District.
As mentioned previously, our office is responsible for the fiscal oversight of the charter school.
I would like to bring to your attention that since the FCMAT report was released in November of 2016, our district has had an opportunity to review two more financial reports submitted by OPA.
I want to bring one point to you today.
Based on what they submitted for the second interim financial report, OPA went back and recreated their cash flow projection, which was a required document to be submitted with its financial report.
What happened was they were actual expenses that incurred between the first interim financial and second interim financial.
However, when we received our second financial report from OPA,
OPA went back and recreated every single dollar amount which differed from the first period of reporting.
And that presents a huge concern to our district.
As such, we request that the board deny the petition appeal.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Board President Kurst, members of the State Board.
My name is Janelle Rooley.
I'm an attorney with the Law Offices of Young, Mini, and Core, here today urging you to approve this renewal petition.
I do want to make it very, very clear.
There's no more sole statutory member structure here with Oxford.
It doesn't exist.
It did.
It does not anymore.
Not as of July, I'm sorry, June of 2016.
So ELS, when they said ELS is gone, that's what they mean.
There's no more sole statutory membership here.
From the moment that the FGMAT audit was released, Oxford Prep has been in nonstop action mode.
The entire board was replaced, the entire administration was replaced, the books were turned over to a reputable financial services firm, and all of this work has been double and triple checked by state-recognized auditors.
I know the CDE didn't think that Oxford could get somebody in enough time after the ACCS meeting to check through the FICMAT report, but they did.
Oxford got it done.
We got the final report at 1230 today.
Good afternoon, Michelle Lynch on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
To continue on what John was saying, they got the final report today.
You saw a summary in their PowerPoint presentation of the implementation of the concerns of the FCMAT audit.
The final report came out and says the same thing, that they have gone through many steps in the short time since the FCMAT audit came out.
I think one of the ECCS commissioners stated it very well.
We're watching this roll out in real time.
And in watching it roll out in real time, there might be some messes, there might need to be some clarifications, but they are doing everything they can to ensure that they have turned over the organization, turned over the leadership, terminated relationships with ELS, with Sea Roach, all of the people listed in the FCMAT audit, and do so without disruption to the students because they are serving so many students so well.
So today we do ask that you approve this renewal.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Spencer Stiles, and I'm president and CEO of Trevor Impact.
As you heard from all of the FCMAT findings, obviously there is the decision to begin working with Oxford Prep starting January of this year was not taken lightly by our firm.
That being said, I'm very happy to say that with this new management team and with the new board of directors, it's actually been quite a pleasure.
We've also been, as you've heard, very much scrutinizing the books both historically, current budgets, and prospectively.
Even our office, in addition to reviewing the school's historical financial statements that were prepared internally, have been audited and are actively being reviewed by two separate and independent CPA firms.
So, all of which have been very supportive.
There have been no real material findings and all recommendations made by all external parties have been taken by OPA's board.
That being said, I am available as follow-up for any financial questions you may have.
Thanks.
Good afternoon.
My name is Deborah Charver, member of the Oxford board and CEO, founder of two successful charter schools in San Bernardino County.
I also serve as council member of Desert Mountain Selva.
I accepted my position on the board after seeing the lives of children and families torn apart when they were denied their charter renewal.
As a board and administration, we have committed ourselves to correcting the mistakes of the past administration and have worked diligently around the clock to fix what was broken.
We have done everything to make sure this can never happen again, and we guarantee.
The children and families respectfully ask for a second chance, and it is my prayer that you will grant this to them.
We are willing to meet any conditions you place upon us, but please, from the bottom of my heart, please allow OPA to continue to operate and give these children the opportunity to remain in the school they love and call home.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Naveen Adly.
I'm OPA Board Treasurer and Chair of the Finance Committee.
I am here to read to you a letter that we received on May the 4th from the Orange County Board of Education, one of our Orange County authorizers.
This was addressed to Denise Pascoe, Interim Executive Director, and Andy Stern, Managing Director of Charter Impact.
Dear Denise and Andy, thank you for your timely submission of the 2016-17 second interim report and accompanying certification.
We have completed our review and analysis of the second interim report.
We are pleased to inform you that the school is in good standing to meet all financial obligations
for current and subsequent two fiscal years.
The ADA is projected at 585.8 with ADA rate of 98.8%, resulting in projected LCFF funds of $4.6 million.
Overall review is projected at 5.6 million and overall expenditures are projected at 4.9 million, thus the net profit, 693, 3% of first interim report.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
My name is Vivian Castro.
I'm the mother of Eva Sanchez-Castro, a second grader at OPA.
Before getting into Oxford, my husband and I requested an intra-district transfer for another elementary school.
When checking on the status of that request with the school district, we were asked, Sanchez-Castro, are you sure you want to transfer to that school?
It has very high standards and expectations.
Somehow, my daughter's last name was synonymous with lower achievement, and she'd be better off at a place with lower expectations.
While at that same school and an activity, a parent asked, oh, you speak to her in Spanish?
When they heard me talking to my daughter.
Worried by her tone, my daughter asked, mom, is that bad?
Thankfully, my daughter's name was called from the OPA waiting list a few weeks later.
In her three years as a champion, Opa has learned that languages such as Tagalog, Korean, Hindi, Farsi, Spanish, and many other languages are spoken at home and at our school.
It's a beautifully diverse student body at Oxford where cultural differences are embraced.
Why do we love Opa?
In large part because this entire school community knows that every single child is capable of amazing things, each in their own special way, and that diversity is something to be celebrated.
Please work with us to save this truly exceptional school.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Sarah Marenko, and I'm a parent and teacher at Oxford Preparatory Academy.
We have an ongoing commitment to maintaining a supportive role in our surrounding communities.
Service learning is embedded in our academic program, and our students, staff, and parents unite to support various philanthropic causes on and off campus.
In fact, the CDE has recognized OPA's model of community development, and we were honored to receive the 2016 Civic Learning Award from the California Department of Education.
OPA leadership took the commission's feedback seriously and moved quickly to implement a new procedure in a manner in which only a charter school can do so.
While OPA looks forward to implementing the National School Lunch Program next fall, our complimentary lunch ticket system is in place now to supply free hot meals to students who lack the resources or simply forget their lunch at home.
In fact, OPA's meal accommodations stand in stark contrast to CVUSD, who recently informed their families that they would no longer allow students to borrow or charge meals should they have insufficient funds in their account, but would be given a courtesy meal consisting of an unflavored milk and a piece of fruit.
OPA's meal program disallows this growing epidemic of school lunch shaming in America, and we will continue to improve on existing and new programs to help our students.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Kevin Diaz and I am a second grader at Oxford.
I want to share with you why my school is special to me.
When I was in kindergarten, I did not want to go to school because my teachers would not be patient with me.
When they got fresh with me, it made me want to quit.
Then I started going to Oxford and my teachers at Oxford take their time with me.
Even I have a speech teacher who helps me feel confident when I speak to people.
My mom drives really far for my brother, sister and me for that we can go to a good school.
Please don't make me go back to school.
That made me feel like I want to quit.
I have friends and teachers that believe and care and who care and believe in me.
Thank you.
Hello.
My name is Ben McNam, and I'm a 2013 graduate from Oxford Preparatory Academy.
I currently attend Chinoo's High, and I have a sister and two brothers that graduated from OPA right now in college and high school, and they're currently succeeding in what they're doing.
I believe enrolling in Oxford was a great decision in my life that helped me go into the career I am right now and just helped me succeed in life.
My time at OPA offered me a wide range of opportunities and experiences, and it got me involved in track, music, and French.
And these are things I'm doing still today.
For that, I'm now in a band, and I play at multiple venues.
I was able to participate in three Junior Olympics representing seven Western states, and I came back from France last winter.
And with all this, I believe the most important thing about OPA is the teachers and the professors there.
Because of them, I've had this confidence and I feel like it's a place where you could go and there's people who really care and trust, you could really care about and trust.
And I just believe that the professors there really care about the kids and I just want to make sure that other kids have the same opportunities and experience that I get to have and just be able to succeed in life and have a great future.
Thank you for listening.
I'd like to call some additional speakers.
Jennifer Fong, Stephanette Graham,
Lauren Odo, Troy Stephens, Gavin Stephens, Seth Torres, Deanna Campana, Sandra Garner, Nya Brown, Teresa Lewis, Audra Donovan, Lorraine Richards, and Michelle Lynch.
Good afternoon board members.
My name is Jennifer Fan and I'm here to tell you a story about my son and my daughter who are both students at Oxford Preparatory Academy.
I will tell you that our journey to Oxford was one that was a little difficult because my son is a special needs student.
We searched through hundreds of schools four different counties looking at venues and programs.
I spoke with a ton of medical experts and a ton of educational experts all to secure the best education I could for my son.
So with that being said, I would like you to know that we drive 62 miles each way in order to attend Oxford Preparatory Academy.
Our IEP team has been smooth and collaborative.
The special education team is amazing and they work together with us.
They are not set by a time limit where they have to leave a meeting at 3 o'clock.
They finish and they get results.
Dominic is doing extremely well.
He is you know he has proven results.
His receptive and expressive language has greatly improved.
I ask you to please look at the proven results and know that to not renew our school would be a travesty and a devastating thing for not just my son but the over 100 school education students there.
Please consider that.
9.5 percent of the students are special ed.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Stephanie Graham and I'm an eighth grade teacher at Oxford Preparatory Academy.
The minute you step on campus at Oxford Prep you can immediately feel the positive school climate.
There is a diverse population of students and staff who help all help the school emulate aspects of tolerance and respect for everyone.
At OPA diversity is one thing we all have in common.
Simply put we are a group that has come together from all different walks of life to accomplish one goal.
We want to provide the best education for our students.
If you ask any student on campus what they like about OPA, many of them will say they feel like they can be who they truly are at a school without having to worry about the judgment of others.
It does not matter your race, ethnicity, gender, language, culture, religion, mental, physical ability, class, or immigration status.
At OPA we are all one.
We are a blended family who celebrates each other's differences by having programs like World Language and incorporating International Day into our curriculum.
This doesn't happen everywhere.
Our school provides an environment that is not replicated often.
I ask you today to please keep our school open and show the world of education how valuing differences matters.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Zarda and I'm a second grader at El Paso.
I'm here because I'm very scared that my school might close down.
I want to ask you a question.
If you shut down our school, where will you send us?
Will you keep us all together or will you break us up?
I hope you didn't have to be scared like us about your school closing because it's very scary.
Please don't take away the choice to go to the school I love and to be able to stay with my friends.
Maybe the school we'll have to go to won't know about Rachel's challenge of kindness we have at Opa.
Please don't take away my school and make me worry that I'll be bullied like some of my friends who went to other schools.
I heard someone call us collateral damage.
Maybe he didn't know he was calling us collateral damage.
Maybe he didn't know he was being mean and hurting our feelings.
I really hope he wasn't trying to be mean to us on purpose because we're not just collateral damage.
We're kids who just love our school.
Thank you for your time and please please save my school.
Good afternoon.
My name is Troy Stevens and I have two boys that attend OPA.
My youngest son who will speak following me is in a full inclusion program in a mainstream classroom, something we always wanted for him.
This is the same kid that Chino Valley Unified made an offer of FAPE to five years ago that included busing him 15 miles out of their own district for services they could not provide.
This is a crazy world we live in and we have to remember we are role models to these kids.
And as role models, you the board, by promoting today,
not to approve the school which show these kids that is okay for one person to demolish an entire structure because of what they did.
These kids should not be punished for what one person did but yet rewarded for never giving up.
Please show these kids that there are still a lot of good in this world and still good things happen to good people.
Believe in
Still a lot of good things happen to good people.
Believe me when I tell you these are great people.
Just look at the faces of the few kids that are here today.
Imagine and imagine the hundred back at home.
Now ask yourself before you vote, what if these were your children?
Wouldn't you fight for what's right and what you believe in?
Believe me, I wouldn't be standing here today if I didn't believe in what these people behind me have done to make our school great.
There would be no greater reward than to reward these kids with five more years.
Thank you.
He's going to read Braille, so you might need a little more than that.
Good afternoon.
My name is Gavin Stevens, and I am in second grade.
When my older brother started here at Alba, I knew I wanted to go there, too.
I was so happy when I started kindergarten.
I couldn't wait to play on the swings and start my cane training.
I couldn't wait to put it on the screen, sorry.
Sorry.
Opa teaches me braille inside my class.
I don't go to another class to learn braille.
God makes us all different, and I think he made this school for me.
I don't want, if you close Opa, I will lose everything I love.
If you close Opa, you will ruin my life and hurt my heart.
I never made bad choices, so please don't punish me for what I did.
Thank you.
Hello my name is Seth Torres.
I'm the ASP president and eighth grader at Oxford Preparatory Academy.
I have an IEP for my special ability abilities.
The teachers at OPA adapt to the way the students learn.
This makes a huge difference especially with students like myself.
They have given me the tools and confidence to overcome the many obstacles I face each day.
I'm thankful for the teachers at our school that I've always seen my potential and never given up on me.
My little sister Jada also attends OPA.
She's in the fourth grade.
Please don't close our school because I don't know where my sister will go.
As a backup plan to OPA, she was registered at the neighborhood school.
Yet we have been told the school is overcrowded and if there is no room, she will have to be bused to another school.
Jayda asked the other day if the other school will have Chinese, science lab, chess club, and cheer.
The answer to her questions was no, they don't.
Jada is activating these classes and activities at OPA.
Jada does not want to go to another school but OPA.
I don't blame her.
I wouldn't either.
No other school in the district provides what OPA provides to our students.
I would love for her to become fluent in Chinese over the next several years.
We need OPA to stay open.
Not for me because I have had the chance to go through the program for the past seven years.
But for the kids like my sister who want the opportunity to continue participating in these classes and activity.
OPA has prepared me well for high school.
I ask you to please give our younger students the same opportunities that I have had and vote for approval.
Thank you.
My name is Deanna Campagna and I've been a teacher for 28 years.
I'm here to represent the teachers of OPA.
Despite everything that has happened, the teachers have continued to do what we do best, teach our children.
The children are and always have been our priority.
Even though our world is falling apart around us, we continue to educate, protect, and love our students.
Given the reality of what is going on, one might expect that the teachers would leave mid-year for the stability of another job.
Not one teacher has left.
The school has continued to thrive despite everything.
There is no doubt that bad things did happen.
What was wrong has been corrected.
I cannot understand how the innocent children and the teachers continue to be punished for the acts of one individual.
When all is said and done, is this the life lesson that we want our children to learn?
I hope not.
I pray that our children learn that if they are
Honest, correct their mistakes and work hard and do the right thing, OPA, they will succeed.
OPA is not an individual.
OPA is a program with over 100 faculty and staff, 780 families and over 1,200 children.
Please do not punish us for the sins of one.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Lorraine Richards on behalf of California Teachers Association.
CTA is opposed to the petition but mostly for the two reasons of local control by the district and understanding what all those students need as services.
Secondly is the plan of fiscal responsibility which is public funds that is a byproduct of this charter.
The other piece is we've heard a kind of a familiar theme here with servicing of students, but also the financial piece that goes along with the responsibility.
So there is a lot of hard work that goes in on behalf of the students and the teachers, but there is also that second piece of financial responsibility to make sure that they continue to get those services.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Sandra Garner, Vice Chair of the OPA Board.
When the FCMAP audit was released, two authorizers ran toward the problem, one ran away.
Capistrano and Orange County never turned their backs on us.
They knew their students were thriving.
They wanted to help.
They answer questions, they give advice, they provide guidance, and that's why our Orange County schools are going to remain open.
With Chino, it's different.
When the district met with our parents in December, we were told there was nothing Oxford could do to save the school.
Nothing.
We hadn't even implemented one reform.
Their minds were made up.
It didn't matter what we did or how we did it, the district wasn't going to give us a chance to succeed.
We teach our children that redemption is possible.
If you do something wrong, you accept responsibility, you fix it, you move on.
But Chino refuses to move on.
Unfortunately, they can't look at us without seeing Sue Roach.
But we're not the past.
We're absolutely the future.
That's why we are grateful to be here today with fresh eyes to look at the truth.
Thank you.
Hi my name is Nala Brown and I would like to share my story when my mom took me out of OPA and put me into a new school.
My teacher was very mean.
She didn't even know my name.
All she said was just number 29.
I felt like I was invisible.
Sometimes I'll go to the bathroom when I really didn't have to and just cry.
My tea.
I really like my OPA teachers.
They make learning so fun.
Like Mr. Raven, he makes music fun.
Like Ms.
Provenzano, she makes learning fun.
Please don't close my school down because I don't want my friends to go through what I went through.
Hello, my name is Teresa Brown, and I have two daughters that reintegrated back into OPA two months ago.
After being betrayed by our school founder and feeling pressure from the Chino superintendent, we transferred out of OPA.
We felt that this was our only choice.
After all, the superintendent had made it quite clear he had no intentions in working with our school, even though year after year we ranked number one in San Bernardino County.
While attending a new school, I was approached by parents daily asking how they can get their kids into OPA.
And this made me realize that we had something special and that I had made a mistake.
Because you know what?
OPA has the most kind, hardworking staff you'll ever meet.
And the second you walk into the office, you're not greeted by an employee, you're greeted by family.
OPA Pride not only connects us, it allows us to learn and believe in something bigger than ourselves.
Our school has value.
It's our home, our contribution to the betterment of not only our city, county, and state, but to society itself.
So I humbly ask you today to take us under your wings and vote yes for our dynamic school.
You see, OPA's motto is always a champion, forever a champion.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
We were originally somewhat skeptical given the severity of the allegations here, but have been very impressed by the dramatic turnaround with the complete purging of the board, complete turnover of all the executive staff, etc.
We think they've taken all of the steps necessary to correct the actions that needed to be corrected.
We've also gotten to know the new management.
They've participated in our painfully rigorous charter business officer training program, have hired two external audit firms that we had suggested to look at their
ongoing transactions from two different directions.
And we can't imagine what more they could possibly do to make right.
We've been to both or to two of their schools.
The school culture is very tight, very intense and incredibly supportive.
And we urge you to grant the appeal.
Thank you.
That ends the public comment.
And so we're ready now for board member discussion.
Eileen Strauss.
So I'm interested from the Chino Valley team, just a question.
I don't know if you will be able to answer my questions, but I've heard anywhere from 989 to 1200 students.
But I also heard a family story of driving 62 miles and that they take from three counties.
So my question is, obviously, this is really serious and egregious behavior.
And we've clearly heard the teams tried to turn it around.
But this should the school close?
What options has Chino Valley considered?
And I don't know how much of the student body is your resident, are your resident students and how many come from neighbors?
I'm just thinking that since this is May, you may have already thought about the options for all the students who are there.
And I'd be interested in hearing that.
Yes, ma'am.
As you heard, we have taken transfers this year.
We're planning for the 449 transfers next year.
I believe my superintendent can speak to that.
Mr. Joseph, please.
Good afternoon.
I'm Wayne Joseph, and we have 20 elementary schools, K-6, and we have two K-8 schools.
So we have more than enough room to accommodate the OPA students and parents.
Now, we may not be able to give them the school they want.
Let's say if they live, if they're living in one area, they may want another school.
You know, that school may be full, but we surely have enough schools to be able to accommodate all of their population.
Other board, Ortiz-Lacon?
This question is actually for the petitioner.
Yes, ma'am.
Thank you.
So I'm looking at the structure and I want to say that I think you've made all the changes you possibly can and I think that the presentation has clearly walked us through that.
But I still have a question about the current governance.
So the OPA board of directors oversees the three schools in the three different districts?
Yes.
And the executive director and the managing director are the same for the three schools across the three districts?
Yes, ma'am.
Now, the financial management team, which is your independent team that is looking at your forensic files and going through all that, the finances, if renewed, how long are you committed to having them as your external reviewer?
this team, the financial management, because I'm assuming that if you get renewed, there may still be things that come up.
It sounds like there is that possibility.
So what is your commitment to keeping them on?
So currently, we have Charter Impact as our financial management team.
But in terms of the second audit firm, we have Gilbert Associates.
And that's a monthly review of our finances through the 17-18 school year.
That's our current contract.
In terms of transparency and creating trust, we're more than willing to continue that on past the 17-18 school year.
I'd like to ask Mr. Fine to come up again from FCMAT.
So I think we've heard claims that they're in good financial order in some ways and budgets are balancing and so on.
But how can that be if we don't know what the charges are from ELS and what some of the unknowns were when you audited them?
I don't see how they can put in their budget things that are unknown that are still pending with ELS.
Dr. Kirse, I think that's an excellent question and would encourage you to ask the petitioners that.
Because what we know about the organization is up to the date of our report.
And we are very confident in our findings and our report and the work that we did there.
What has transpired since that point, we have not been involved.
In fairness to them, they have actually, they reached out to us to say, would you be part of our cleanup partner?
That's obviously a role that we do on a very frequent basis in school districts and charter schools.
But in this case, there are multiple active follow-up investigations going on of which we are
part of those conversations and so to avoid a conflict of interest, we've declined.
But with respect to what ELS may owe them, as you heard earlier from the petitioners they have, and they can speak this far clearer than I can, they have current litigation going on in an attempt to recover that.
They've done some forensic
whatever that really means, audit work to identify some of that.
So I think they're in a better position, sir, to probably answer that question.
Can you comment on these investigations that are going on?
Do you know of any of them or are those past your period?
So very common when we do an AB 139 extraordinary audit and if we reach the threshold where we believe there's sufficient evidence to say something, as the board's aware, the county superintendent has a responsibility to notify local law enforcement.
Most of the time then we provide support to those, to the local district attorney or the state attorney general's office.
It's becoming more common to also provide that support to the U.S.
attorney general's office and other federal investigative bodies, all who have an interest.
In this particular case, given the nature of the findings, there are a number of control agencies that have an interest in what happened.
And I think it's really important here from my perspective, I'm speaking up to the date of our report, what happened up to that point.
I cannot speak to the work that has or has not been done up to, you know, since that point.
there are a number of agencies that have a high level of interest in this particular report and the previous activities.
Okay, so I'd like to ask then the district people, how do you know, since FCMAT did not know a lot of ELS's expenditures and financial, how do you know?
I really want to ask the Oxford prep, then I'll ask you.
Okay, I'll ask you afterwards because I think... How do you know what they did?
If FCMAT couldn't find out and they didn't get any information, how did you get the information?
Pardon?
Go ahead.
Good afternoon.
Brian Hedman from the law firm Theodore Oranger.
We've been retained by Oxford to pursue litigation against Ed Leighton and Sue Roach.
I think what you're referring to is the ongoing litigation process and the discovery process through that litigation, which we will be undergoing.
So the school is aggressively pursuing recovery of funds from Ed Leighton and Sue Roach.
When that discovery process begins, we will be demanding documents from Ed Leighton.
And we want those documents as much as anyone.
And once Discovery opens, we will be demanding them.
They don't have.
So, you know, we have a list on page 22, 23 of the audit.
So you don't have payroll taxes and all these things that they enumerate.
So you're beginning a process.
So we're proceeding not knowing what's out there with ELS.
That's my point.
And you're saying you're working to recover that, but you have no... Those aren't in your financial projections and your financial person can't know those.
The school's potential recovery from Ed Leighton is unknown.
However, all of the school's liabilities are absolutely known.
So when we talk about uncertainty, we're talking about what will the school be able to recover through its litigation from Ed Leighton and Sue Roach.
That is the only uncertainty.
Liabilities are not uncertain.
OK.
I don't know.
Okay.
I'd like Mr. Fine to comment on that at the time of the audit.
I don't, I don't, I mean, I can't get at, I don't see how you say you know it all and you're just suing somebody to get back reconciliation.
How do you know that and he didn't know it?
You got something that he didn't know.
Is that, go ahead.
You go, Mr. Fine.
Dr. Kirsch, I don't want to put words in their mouth, but I think it's fair to say neither of us know all the details at this point.
What's different about our approach is we ultimately got to a wall and couldn't go further.
We issued our report based on everything we knew, including
some additional information relative to ELS that was available to us but not provided by ELS.
An important standard that we follow in an extraordinary audit or any kind of fraud audit.
It's a standard of our certified fraud examiners that are on our staff.
We triangulate information.
One piece of information is not adequate for us to reach a conclusion to write a report around.
We look for multiple pieces of information from multiple sources.
Clearly without ELS cooperating that
that became problematic.
I think what I understood and counseled just to say was that they've initiated litigation and so they've initiated the discovery process and a court will ultimately oversee that process and force the other party to produce just as if
the district attorney or some other law enforcement issues a subpoena, they will ultimately get some of this information which, as I indicated earlier, in part is why we listed.
The missing information, it was to make it easier to the follow-up parties, in our case law enforcement, to kind of know quickly what to ask for.
Thank you.
Chino Valley, do you want to comment on this?
I think it's important here, Dr. Kirsten, to remember that CDE and FCMAT have said what?
That they intentionally deceived their own auditor.
Their own auditor estimated the money that Enlighten had at $900,000.
And Mr. Fine has said that FCMAT doesn't conclude on one or two pieces of information, but they look at as much information as they can.
I think that we had a comment earlier about county boards not hearing appeals.
Oxford's first appeal from our first denial in March was denied or not heard, I should say, by the San Bernardino County Board of Education on the grounds that
Oxford exiting its sole statutory relationship with Enlighten was a material revision.
And you can't make a material revision while an appeal is pending before the county board.
I would also like to add that as superintendent, I could not in good conscience at this time go to my board and say take over Oxford not knowing the unknown liability.
We don't know what's out there.
Mr. Fine alluded to the IRS.
We don't know where that's going to lead.
We don't know where anything really is going to lead at this point.
Thank you.
Board Member Rucker, I think was next on the list.
My question is for Mr. Fine.
Okay, so first of all, I do want to thank you for the explanation that you gave.
It's very rare that I can talk to an accountant or a numbers guy and actually follow the conversation past the first sentence.
So my question to you is, I understand the, I think, I understand and I will ask the attorney for
OPA the same question.
I understand that they are going through this discovery to identify what the liabilities are.
But are they, even if they identify the liabilities, is there any way of knowing that they're going to recover whatever funds that they're able to get?
In your experience, is that something that's also able to happen that they can be made whole by recovering the funds?
Member Rucker, I'm not in a position to answer that.
We really know very little about ELS.
At the time of our report, and our report reflects this, and the department's staff report reflects this, there was roughly, we believed, about at least a half a million dollars of assets that they were holding.
that belonged, in our opinion, to OPA.
Whether those are still in their possession, whether there's additional, we have no way of knowing.
Okay, thank you.
And then I'd like to ask a couple of questions to OPA.
So as you're walking up, I just want to say, you know, during the holiday season, we had a family gathering.
And one of the people who came for the entertainment was what was called a parlor magician.
And these are the people who walk over.
These are performers who walk around groups of folks in the room.
they're able to perform magic tricks right in front of you rather than at some distance on a stage.
And the idea behind how they work is, you know, while they purposefully distract you to look in one direction, they complete
the magic trick itself.
And you go, wow.
So while it was very clear that you had a number of people who probably were parlor magicians who did all these horrible, horrible things, the issue in front of us is not whether or not the students at your school like the school.
And it's not whether or not the school itself is performing.
The issue is what the adults forgot to do.
And so the question I have for you is really a rephrasing of what our board president has asked.
You identified that during the lawsuit, during the course of your discovery, you believe you will find out some things.
The FCMAT report enumerated a number of items that only the former entity, ELS, actually has information on.
And so you're relying on the idea that through this discovery, you will find out this information.
And you, what is your basis for believing you're going to fully recover all of those liabilities if you really can't enumerate what exactly each of those numbers are that's in the FITMAT report that's not known right now?
So thank you for your question.
This is a common circumstance with all civil litigation.
A litigant files a lawsuit based on the pleading standard in California and we then discover, we enter the discovery process and we learn and we propel our claims forward.
So, what OPA is doing here is exactly the same as what occurs in other civil litigation.
The discovery process is robust in California.
We have substantial rights to discover and to demand documents, depositions.
We have subpoena power, and we will exhaust those opportunities.
We are going to demand the books and records of Enlightened so that we can feel confident that we understand exactly what we are owed.
We have an idea, and the FCMAT report gave us a good framework.
But the discovery process compels a lot more information than FCMAT was able to.
Okay.
And so I just want to say, the word discovery is a legal term of art.
Not like Columbus discovered America, he bumped into an island and he didn't know it was there.
That's not what you mean when you say discovery.
Discovery is really an inquiry, right?
It's a formal investigation that is empowered by our civil litigation system.
It's got the power to demand documents, whereas FCMAT only had the power with regard to Ed Leighton to request.
We're at a stage in the litigation when we get there, we get to demand them.
And if Ed Leighton continues to refuse to produce them, we then go to the court and we seek the court's order that Ed Leighton produce them.
And the reason why I'm asking that is because the impression that you gave me, and I'm overstating the impression because I really do want you to correct me.
The impression that you gave me is that in the process of discovery, you already know what you're going to find.
Is that correct?
No, that is not correct.
What we do know is what we're looking for.
Okay, do you already, as it relates to each of the items that FCMAT has enumerated that cannot be determined, do you have an idea or an estimate of what those dollar amounts are?
whatever we discover through this litigation and recover will just be added to the school's reserve.
Okay, but you're talking only about recovering dollar reserves.
We're still talking about obligations as well that were identified by FCMAT that cannot be known.
So my question is, there's two types of, there's two sets of pieces of information that seem to not be clear to us that you understand.
that there's obligations that were identified by FCMAT that are currently not known and there's money or assets that the company seems to be holding that you're seeking to recover.
Are you only filing a lawsuit to recover the assets or are you also doing discovery to identify any other obligations?
We are seeking discovery of what Oxford Prep is owed.
Oxford Prep already has a firm understanding of all of its liabilities.
And I would turn that discussion over to Charter Impact.
But through our litigation, we will be seeking the discovery of information regarding what additional funds Oxford can recover from at Leighton.
It is not an inquiry into unknown liabilities because there are not unknown liabilities.
Well, that's the point that our board president made that if FCMAT says that there's some unknown liabilities, there's a difference in perception about what you say that there are no unknown liabilities.
And FCMAT is saying that there are some unknown liabilities.
That's my concern.
I think that the thrust of your inquiry goes to all of the investigation internally at OPA that has happened since FICMAT, hundreds of hours of time piling through the books and records.
But the OPA is very confident that it understands the totality of its obligations.
OK, thank you.
Yeah, I have.
Go ahead.
Yeah, Bruce.
Next.
Before you leave and then Mr. Fein.
So you have confidence that you are not going to find in this discovery process any further obligations for OPA.
I'm sorry.
I'll rephrase my question.
When you do this discovery process, when the ESL books are open, it's your opinion that you will not find any further obligations.
Is that correct?
When we get a look at Leighton's books and records, they will reflect what money could be owed to OPA and potentially reflect what money Ed Leighton owes to others.
Ed Leighton's books and records, though, should not and will not shed light on any new liabilities on behalf of Oxford PrEP.
And so during this time period after the FICMAT report and through all the hundreds of hours that you just said, you have scoured your books, you've looked through, you know, this mention of a million-dollar loan that was taken out and these other things.
You've got all of that in hand.
You know exactly what your liabilities are at this point, and you know what your reserve is, what's in the bank right now today that you can write a check on.
Those things you are very clear about.
Is that correct?
Crystal clear.
So, thank you very much.
Mr. Fine may want to comment on that.
I was calling him.
Sir, thanks for coming back up.
So, are you aware of, at the end of the FICMET report, did you have a sense that there were outstanding liabilities that potentially could impact this organization?
Member Holliday, I think it's important to put where the very first question Dr. Kearse asked with respect to this list of items on page 22 and 23.
Those are revenue and expenditure items that were filed as part of ELS's tax return and an amended tax return.
They really don't speak specifically to assets and liabilities per se, although in that same tax return are assets and liabilities.
But this list, our expenditure items and what we were looking for in concert with our scope was money that was transferred from a public charter school to Enlighten.
And how was it spent?
Did it end up back in the pockets of the same people that we had concern about that were part of our scope?
And so, our focus was on expenditures.
We believe based on information that we had, there are some cash balances, there are in the filings with the IRS, they clearly say they hold assets for OPA.
So, that was our focus.
I'm going to go back though and make sure that you recall our concern in all of this.
One of our concerns is that ELS and OPA at the time were basically one in the same.
And so has ELS entered into any obligations that OPA is unaware of and you've heard them speak to that and they're the ones that would know that.
that somehow bound OPA.
That would be the unknown.
That was not something that we were privy to.
Are you going to continue?
I want to follow up on this point.
We're, and I don't know whether you should answer this, Mr. Fine, it may be our lawyers, but in a number of areas, a lot of areas today that I don't get fully grasped, but there's a possibility of criminal charges here.
Would you say in your experience that's even feasible?
Because I don't know, maybe... I just want to answer, is there some way the school could be held or sued if there are criminal activities and criminal convictions?
You know, it seems to me there's at least a chance some of this activity is illegal.
by the former administration.
And is that a lie?
Would that be a potential liability that they cannot account for?
Often when somebody's convicted, not often, but I've read in the paper, when criminals are convicted, then some people sue behind it, you know, in that regard and sue for various things.
So,
Can the legal counsel talk about that?
I think that's... I think there's just so many unknowns.
We can't say what any... because everyone's been saying... I'm not saying whether you know it.
Is it a possibility?
It probably is a possibility.
I think we don't know about what any liabilities might come from the board, the former board, not this, the former board that was, you know, approving and had employed Sue Roach.
Okay.
Do you have a comment?
Yeah.
I would only add to it.
Again, if it's determined these are all one in the same, that there could potentially be tax, federal and state tax liabilities related to what was established as a not-for-profit corporation that ultimately was determined not to qualify for that.
As not-for-profit or as for-profit?
With regard to law enforcement, they certainly are looking at a whole host of penal code sections.
I couldn't speak to how that flows down to the corporate entity from the individual.
at this point.
Yeah.
I'm not asking in this case.
Is this even possible within the realm of possibility?
Nobody knows, I guess.
But sometimes I've seen that.
And that's all I want to know is people.
Yeah.
Board Member Williams.
The petitioner and the attorney to the petitioner.
And is it, who's your capital impact?
Charter impact?
Who's, if you'd bring them.
So back to the question of are all liabilities known?
And I'm hearing yes.
But I heard that that capital, is it capital impact?
Charter impact.
But I heard that you're the one that would know that.
So in the context of this discussion, what the attorneys have been talking about in the unknowns is the amount of assets that were transferred from OPA to ELS, which the school is now trying to claw back.
And so from an accounting and management perspective, typically if somebody owes you money and they don't want to pay it, they're quiet and you don't know about it.
That's the process that they're going through to try to, the discovery process to claw it back.
If an organization owes somebody else money, let's say there was another bank loan out there somewhere, usually at some point people are going to start asking for that money and asking for payments.
In our process, when we've scoured through the books, we found no evidence of that whatsoever, with the exception of the single line of credit that was with California Credit Union, at which point, as of today, has been paid back.
So there are no other liabilities, long-term liabilities, whatsoever on the Chino books at this point.
And we're still projecting on ending with a very big fund balance, as well as $780,000 of cash in the bank.
Okay.
Thank you.
Board Member Holliday.
Well, that is what I've been thinking during this whole process.
I mean, if there are liabilities, if money is owed out there to somebody, if they haven't been involved in wrongdoing, they're going to raise their hand.
And certainly by now, they would have raised their hand, especially with all the news and all the information that's been going on and say, wait a sec, guys, you owe me and would have come straight to OPA.
I can't imagine that they wouldn't do that.
So I tend to believe that there are no further obligations, loans, liabilities out there.
I tend to believe that.
What I'm still wrestling with, and I'm sorry, this is not really a question for you.
It's more of a question for, I guess, our counsel, Judy.
I mean, this seems very basic and naive of me, but at the same time, I really am wrestling with, you know, did the school do wrong or did an individual do wrong?
And I'm still wrestling with that.
And I need to feel as though whether or not there is an opportunity for an organization, a nonprofit, an institution, a charter school, to have moved away from an individual and still be the charter school.
You know what I'm saying?
I think the one thing I haven't heard is any talk about the former board.
They said they got rid of the former board, but the former board, we haven't heard that the former board did not approve some of the contracts, and it seems that there was a failure of this individual and a failure of the former board, whether it was
Failure as a there was there was a lack of oversight by the former OPA board clearly So that that seems to be pretty clear because the board is the governance board and accountable for over fiduciary oversight but but
If we're now talking about an entirely new board and we're talking about new management and in terms of distancing oneself from the, from Sue Roach, you can't distance yourself much more than file a lawsuit against somebody.
That tends to, you know, the relationship doesn't work well after that.
So, I'm not sure I feel at this point like there's no obligations.
There appear to be no unseen obligations.
What's unknown is whether or not they can recover anything from Sue Roche.
And I'm not sure what the question, if there's a legal financial question about the former board, like whether they could be, even if they were the focus of some of the
criminal oversight looking at investigation.
Even if they were the focus, how are people wondering how it's connected to the current board?
Board member Rucker, I think was next.
Okay.
So, you know, whenever I drive down the street in my old neighborhood and I see these signs that say under new management, you know, I see all the things that they've done to put themselves under new management.
But what remains is the residual from what was going on with the old management.
So when I look at the documents and I look at the page 22 and 23, even if you are under new management, those things remain.
Even if you're under new management, there are some contracts that the previous board entered into for this charter that the new board may or may not be liable for and that remains an unknown.
There are some obligations that the old board may have created that the new board may or may not be obligated to.
And that remains an unknown.
What I have heard is that the new management is actively pursuing recovery of some assets.
But I have not heard them clearly state, even if they think they know everything that's owed, they did not talk about any continuing or existing obligations that have been created for them
by the previous management, that was not clearly known and clearly explained by them.
So I have great concern when I look at the FCMAT report and I look at those two pages and the list of unknowns, those lists of unknowns, while they may have been done by the old management, the new management has to take on responsibility for addressing those obligations.
And I didn't hear that.
So I have great concern about that.
Why did I hear it?
That when they said they've looked, they've got charter impact, they've looked, they don't have any obligations that they're not aware of.
Yeah, let's...
Well, so one thing about unknown obligations, I just want to pick up on from what Mike Fine said, and that has to do with our friends at tax agencies, like the IRS and FTB, that if they were in fact one and the same entity and those tax agencies go, now, oh, you lied on your tax reports, you got a big problem and you have a major financial obligation potentially, which I think is what, and so I kind of want to ask Cindy and Nick,
about that because we're in an untenable situation.
Let's put it out there, folks.
We do not want to do anything to harm these lovely children who are having a fantastic educational experience by their testimony and by the evidence we have.
But we have a clear-cut case, as evidenced and documented well by FCMAT, of financial mismanagement and potentially fraud, which is a statutory basis to get rid of a charter.
So we're stuck here with, oh my God, have they actually corrected it?
And I don't, not that I distrust anything people are saying here about what they've done and they've uncovered, but we don't have that in front of us.
We still have a recommendation from the department that, and no recommendation from ACCS essentially, that says we're worried about this.
We don't think there's a potential they won't be financially viable.
So at the risk of making everybody unhappy, I wonder if a two-month delay in the action on this might actually reveal some things.
We heard that they just got an audit today at 1230 that might in fact clear all of this up and we'd have the information in front of us on which to make an action.
Because I, just like we were with Solarity, I am just so struggling with this notion of throwing a bunch of kids out on the street and having them find another school.
So I just would like to put that out there.
First, I want Cindy, though, to answer the question.
Given what we've heard here, which seems like it's a whole bunch of information since you guys actually last did your analysis,
and submitted the recommendation to us saying, gee, we're worried about loans, we're worried about this, we're worried about undiscovered contracts, lack of valid audit reports.
If we had a little bit more time to say, in fact, there is additional information that would support one way or the other, we'd ultimately have to make a decision, would that be worth considering?
I think, and I don't want to put Mike on the spot, but I mean, I know both of the audit firms that they hired.
And the report I heard just came in, so we haven't seen it.
I know who that audit firm is, and they're very reliable.
The issue is FICMAT spent over three months in their work.
This audit firm spent less than three weeks.
I don't know, even seeing the report, if the level of work would be able to go in and, I guess, look at what they've done in terms of what FCMAT found.
I mean, you kind of know my background.
This audit report is horrific.
I've read hundreds of audit reports.
So, I mean, coming from my
experience and expertise.
I just, I am skeptical on how quickly, it looks like they've made efforts, but it's just been too short of a time.
The former CEO just resigned in December and then this new board came in.
I think what I was kind of agreeing with Mr. Fine is that if there's a consolidation,
I think, you know, when they're talking about liabilities, yes, they know the school's liabilities.
We don't know anything about this other organization.
It's this sort of unknown sort of landmine that could be stepped on.
And I think that's where we're concerned.
That's where we're uncomfortable.
It's in the best interest of the board.
I think what we don't want to see, what's harder than denying a school and allowing them to open, what's even worse is during the
term or even mid-year having them to close.
It's just we've seen that happen through other charters that is worse than not allowing them to move forward because they have time to plan and transition.
Mid-year closures are just a nightmare for families in the community.
That's what we want to prevent because we just don't know what's going to happen in the future with all of this sort of a mess with the organizations and the audits and
who knows out there what other liabilities.
So I don't think we're comfortable.
I don't know if there's enough time in two months.
When does their charter run out?
I mean, we can't delay forever.
I'm not sure we can hang on the July agenda with due diligence.
June 30th is the end of their term.
Yeah.
So they would then term out.
You would want to
recharter them?
That would be your proposal?
No, no, I just wondered whether additional time.
I wasn't paying attention to the termination date.
But I do think, I mean, I think the point that Cindy's making is while we've been asking all these questions about what do you know, what do you know, there's still, it's like this big black box of this ELS which FCMAT couldn't get at, they can't get at, they don't know it, and so that's the big
black cloud, if you will, that's hanging over the school that I think makes it tough for us to move forward.
Yeah, board member Holliday.
And the school's in just a terrible situation here because of timing.
You know, if this happened two years ago or something, I don't know exactly what the timeline would have been, but if it happened earlier, a lot of this would already have come to light and we would have been able to get the facts.
So, you know, their back's up against the wall and that's a real shame.
Okay.
Are we ready?
I think we're ready for a motion of some sort at this point.
Do we have a motion?
Anybody?
I'm supposed to make a motion, but I'm not going to make it.
I can't make that motion.
So somebody else have to make a motion.
Anybody else want to make a motion?
We're done.
Go ahead.
Anybody else want to make a motion?
Pardon?
Yeah, so we can just not, not take action.
If that's what people want to do.
Pardon?
Yes, it would be the same as a denial.
We should say that to the... I don't know.
I'm asking for a motion.
Yeah.
Do you want to adjourn?
I mean, adjourn or have a recess?
Okay.
Ten minute recess.
We'll come back at 4.05.
Thanks, Mr. President.
Okay.
The board will reconvene.
Mr. President, I apologize for the delay.
I sincerely do.
I was
During that recess, I spoke with SBE staff because I needed a handout to be copied and passed out to everyone.
I did not speak with anyone else.
This motion that I'm going to make is my motion.
stemmed from my feelings and my heart and it does not come from anyone else.
Just make it clear this is my choice in this matter.
I believe that, pardon me, I believe that this is a
a group of teachers, parents and kids who are benefiting from this charter school.
I believe that wrongdoing did take place, but I also believe that there has been an enormous effort to clean house and I trust that that has taken place.
There may be another shoe that drops down the road.
I have a feeling that the parents and children of this school would prefer to take that risk than to have this school be closed today.
And as a result, I would like to move that we as SBE approve the renewal of OPA with the following conditions, and they are lengthy.
So I asked for all these conditions to be passed to the board members and if you have in written form.
So if you have questions, you may certainly do so.
I assume for record I have to read all of these out loud.
Okay.
Number one condition.
OPA will contract with an agency approved by the CDE for a comprehensive management audit
OPA will provide CDE monthly updates from that auditor on the status of the audit.
And upon the day of completion, OPA will provide CDE with a copy of the auditor's final comprehensive report.
Within one month of OPA's receipt of the comprehensive management audit report, OPA will provide CDE with a plan approved by a governing board to resolve any audit findings.
Upon CDE's request at any point during the term of OPA's charter,
OPA will contract with an agency approved by CDE to verify that the findings identified in the comprehensive management audit have been and continue to be adequately addressed.
Condition two, OPA shall disclose to CDE any contracts between OPA and a charter or education management organization and shall obtain prior approval from CDE before entering into or approving the revision of any such contracts.
Number three, OPA shall disclose to CDE any entities affiliated with OPA and any related party transactions entered into by OPA within the last fiscal year.
OPA shall obtain prior approval from CDE before entering into any future agreement with any such entity or any other related party transaction.
Should CDE approve an agreement between OPA and affiliated entity, CDE may also request that OPA obtain prior approval from CDE before any loan or transfer between the entities.
All OPA affiliated entities shall agree to respond to any inquiries from CDE.
And number four, OPA will make reasonable efforts to participate in the National School Lunch Program and shall provide CDE with regular updates regarding the status of its application and its outreach efforts to notify all demographic groups within Chena Valley of their right to apply for admission to OPA.
And that is my motion.
And with a heart full of gratitude to my colleague, Bruce Holliday, I second that motion.
Okay.
Board member discussion of the motion.
Board member Sandoval.
I really appreciate the heart, the passion of the educators, the students, the volunteers, the board members of this organization.
And I also am grateful for this option that's being presented by Member Holiday.
But I still believe that there are too many unresolved issues that have yet to be addressed, too many unknowns and
Even with these conditions that are being proposed, I still don't feel like I can support that new or the motion.
Board Member Rocker.
like Board Member Sandoval, while this attempts to address a couple of things and the school lunch issue was a very important to me, but I still think that there are too many unresolved fiscal issues.
I now, if we approve, if the Board approves this appeal, we become their authorizer.
I'm not even sure if there's now any liability that falls to the Board.
by being their authorizer that we will inherit.
And so I don't believe this motion addresses or indemnifies in any way us from those obligations that we don't know about.
So I remain concerned that as the authorizer,
we would be inheriting something that through no fault of the parents and the children in this room that become, this becomes our mess if we become their authorizer and this motion doesn't address it.
And I don't feel I can support this motion either.
Yeah, I don't see how this audit addresses what CDE talked about that the budget cannot be deemed viable
due to potential of undiscovered contracts, transactions, taxes, extended liabilities, loans, obligations.
You can't, if these are, to me there's, to be the authorizer, you would have to have much more than have an audit.
Audit doesn't solve problems to me.
You seem to think that it, you know, makes these go away, but I don't quite see that.
Moreover,
I think we're getting awfully deep.
The board has to think about how deeply we want to get involved in running these charters.
I mean, this has the CDE.
It's a major policy change for the CDE to be so deeply embedded in all of these, of all of these operations.
And it seems to be the way we're drifting that we're not only doing oversight.
We're actually, in effect, an adjunct fiscal agent.
And so,
I can personally, I don't see this as appropriate as a motion I can support.
Any other comments?
All right.
Call the roll.
Bruce Holliday.
Nikki Sandoval.
Karen Valdez.
Olivia Sison.
Trish Williams.
Mike Kirst.
Eileen Strauss.
Sue Burr?
No.
Feliza Ortiz Licon?
Yes.
Patricia Rucker?
No.
Okay.
The motion fails.
There's only four in favor.
We need another motion.
We need a... Does anybody want to make another motion?
Well, that's another motion.
I don't think we ought to try and amend this motion.
Unless, you know, one can make a motion to amend it.
Okay.
Hearing no other motion, then we have taken no action.
All right.
So we're now on to the next charter.
20.
New West Charter.
Hold a public hearing.
Again, Cindy Chan with the California Department of Education.
So item 20 is the last of the four renewals that you have before you today.
It's a request to renew New West Charter, a charter school currently authorized by the state board, with a charter term that expires June 30, 2017.
Current law requires a State Board of Education authorized charter school seeking renewal to submit a renewal petition to the authority that originally denied the charter.
New West Charter submitted its renewal petition to the Los Angeles Unified School District, which was denied on December 13th.
If a school district governing board denies a renewal petition for an SB authorized charter school, current law allows the charter school to submit the renewal petition directly to the state board.
So in this case, New West did not have to go to Los Angeles County office.
It can go from the district and then straight back to the state board.
New West submitted an appeal on December 14th.
Based on CDE staff's review of the appeal documents, the CDE recommends that the State Board hold a public hearing and thereafter approve with technical amendments in one condition, the request to renew New West's charter under the oversight of the State Board for a five-year term, effective July 1, 2017 through June 30th.
2021-22.
The CD's recommendation includes the following condition.
New West Charter must revise the homeschool agreement and enrollment agreement to remove all language that conflicts with education code section 49011 subdivision B.
As noted in the CDE's January 20th, 2015 fiscal management advisory 15-01 and also education code section 47605B5H and 47605D2A.
Revisions to the homeschool agreement and enrollment agreement include
Clearly indicating that parents are not required to provide any volunteer hours such as participating in school projects, events, and classroom activities, overseeing community service projects, or attending orientation launch meetings, back to school nights, open houses, or school-wide events.
Removing any language requiring payment of fees for after school athletics, field trips, and rental of musical instruments.
Removing the traffic monitoring and mitigation policy slash pupil transportation and parking policy from the homeschool agreement.
And four, removing language that places conditions upon admission and continued enrollment at New West Charter such as mandatory requirements of parents, consequences for noncompliance to the homeschool agreement including loss of enrollment,
at New West Charter and the requirement that parents and pupils sign the homeschool agreement as a condition of enrollment at New West Charter.
In addition, the CDE recommends that New West Charter be allowed to include a preference in Element 8 admission requirements so that admission preferences align with Education Code Sections 47605D, 2B, and 47614.5.
That would be preferences, number one, existing pupils of New West Charter.
Number two, pupils who currently are currently enrolled in or reside in the attendance area of Brockton Elementary, a public elementary school where New West Charter is located in which 55% or more of the pupil enrollment is eligible for free or reduced price lunch.
and three, pupils residing in the district.
Additional preferences beyond these may be permitted by the state board as the chartering authority and only if consistent with the law.
And the reason why we're allowing this other preference, it is allowed in the statute and it has to do with the charter school facility grant program.
The counter statute for that program requires this sort of special carve out of the charter school
of the admissions and so we're allowing that to be added and the charter school is actively a participant in that program.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools considered the newest charter renewal petition at its April 5th meeting.
The ACCS voted to recommend that the State Board approve the CD staff recommendation with a change in enrollment preferences contingent upon the CD staff ensuring that the change in enrollment preferences is compliant with Education Code Section 47605.
the motion passed by a vote of six to one.
And I think there was, the discussion on that was the fact that we, in the ACCS item, we didn't acknowledge the other preference.
I think we didn't realize that that was in there and that they were a participant of the Charter School Facility Grant Program.
Most of the time you don't see that in the petitions we bring because most charter schools are eligible on their own counts, in this case,
the charter school has to rely on LAUSD, which is a sort of a plan B for that eligibility program.
So the discussion was as long as we found it to be compliant, then they would approve that.
And the votes passed, the vote passed, or the motion passed by a vote of six to one.
So give you a little bit of background and then what we looked at in terms of this petition.
In December 2001, the State Board approved the New West petition.
New West opened in September 2003, serving pupils in grade 6 through grade 8.
New West Charter was renewed by the State Board in 2007 and again in 2012.
Beginning in 2012, New West Charter added one high school grade level per year.
The school currently serves 824 pupils in grade 6 through grade 12 and is proposing to expand by adding 400 pupils, including an independent study program.
The New West Charter mission is to provide an academically rigorous, highly individualized education for 21st century pupils in grade 6 through grade 12.
Again, the first thing that we looked at was the academic achievement of the school as that's required for a renewal, and whether there were increases in that academic achievement.
So we looked at both criteria, the standard criteria for renewal, and we found that the newest charter has met three of those five criteria, and has thus demonstrated increases in people academic achievement.
We also looked at what LAUSD reviewed and that was the alternative measures that New West Charter proposed in its renewal petition based on the Smarter Balanced assessments data.
New West Charter met or exceeded the performance standard for both English language arts literacy and mathematics for resident schools and New West Charter pupil subgroups maintained or achieved positive growth in academic performance.
Therefore we find that the charter school met standard criteria for renewal and also even though it was a necessary the alternative measures as well.
So in our review of the renewal petition and all the documents submitted
We have found that the newest charter petition is consistent with sound educational practice.
The petitioner has the capacity to implement the program, which includes a review of the financial statements and their operational plan.
The multi-year financial plan is sustainable and provides for projected operating surpluses and adequate reserves.
The petition also provides a reasonably comprehensive description of the multiple required elements, noting that there are some that require a technical amendment.
Then I'll talk a little bit about admissions and that is the basis for our condition.
The newest charter petition includes an element for governance, a section that describes the newest charter homeschool agreement.
The CDE has serious concerns with the language in this section and specifically this agreement which include that it must be signed as a condition of enrollment before the beginning of each year or whenever a new student is enrolled.
It includes a number of parent requirements such as parent volunteer hours, mandatory participation in the transportation mitigation monitoring program.
that includes options, one that may result in a cost to the pupil, such as the pupil having to take the Metro line, bus or rail.
Parent requirements also include attending an annual orientation meeting, participating in the election of parent representatives to the Board of Directors,
Attend all scheduled parent teacher conferences annually.
Attend back to school night, open houses and other school-wide events.
Participate as a family in extracurricular school events such as book fairs, plays, talent shows, festivals and fundraising activities.
And self-report compliance with the homeschool contract.
In a review of the homeschool contract and enrollment agreement, there are additional requirements and conditions of enrollment that the parent and people must agree to by signing the required contracts.
For example, they're required to purchase school supplies, pay for activity fees, such as after school athletics, field trips, and rental of musical instruments.
Reimbursed the charter school for food when the child does not have a lunch and one is provided for by the charter school.
And a mandatory uniform policy that requires the purchase of newest charter logo apparel.
We find that the homeschool agreement does not belong in the governance section.
of the petition, and more importantly, includes requirements as a condition of enrollment that are in conflict with legal requirements, including the California Constitution that promulgates a free public education system.
Pupil fees requirements of people enrolled in a public school shall not be required to pay a pupil fee for participation in an educational activity pursuant to Education Code Section 9011.
and charter school admissions.
A charter school shall admit all pupils who wish to attend the school.
There was a little discussion about this at the ACCS meeting and I believe that the petitioner had said that they had confirmed that they had not denied enrollment for any pupil because of this, but I think the commissioners had commented they were more concerned about those parents that were
that turned away on their own because of the information that was in there that maybe they hadn't enrolled and that was a little more of a concern.
So accordingly, the department is proposing a condition that New West Charter revise the homeschool agreement and enrollment agreement to remove all language that conflicts with statute.
The specific recommendation is included in our recommendation on pages one and two of the item.
So to summarize, we recommend that the State Board hold a public hearing and approve the renewal petition for newest charter with our proposed condition and technical amendments.
Representatives from the Charter School and I believe LAUSD may still be here to comment.
Okay.
Thank you.
We'll have technical questions first of Cindy, Board Member Williams.
Could you just repeat what the enrollment preference situation is?
Was this, remind me, is this the charter that had elementary school nearby that they were?
Yes.
And also that they could keep the enrollment preferences that we've approved before or was that a different charter?
I'm not sure what was, we'd have to go back and look what was approved before.
And even if it was, I think in the last few years we've been very consistent with the kids of the charter, kids of the district.
We are allowing this one because it is in statute to allow them to give a preference for the Brockton Elementary because
because it's legally allowed, but also because they are actively involved in the Charter School Facility Grant Program and they would not be eligible because they cannot serve the free and reduced price on their own.
So they need that preference to maintain their funding in that program or eligibility in that program.
Board Member Holliday.
I'm sure you will in the hearing hear from the petitioners to explain this.
But in the ACCS meeting it was made very clear that this is not just about money.
This is not just about the grant money.
This is about a really successful viable way of creating diversity in the school and serving the most needy students in that community.
And it's working.
And I highly thank
the CDE for investigating this, making sure that it's all legal, but at the same time it's working for the right reasons.
Anyway.
Okay, if there's no more technical discussion, then I'll open the public hearing.
Each side has 10 minutes and so we'll first take 10 minutes for the petitioners for the charter.
Thank you to the California State Board of Education members for allowing New West Charter the opportunity to give a brief presentation today.
My name is Sharon Weir and I'm very proud to be the Principal and Executive Director at New West Charter since 2005.
I appreciate the members of the State Board have numerous informational documents related to New West and in respect of your time we will only highlight the most critical points of our renewal request.
New West is fortunate to be an established state approved charter school in our 14th year of operation.
As an SBE authorized charter school, we take both our role and responsibilities very seriously.
We work diligently and in harmony with both our authorizer and oversight agent, the California Department of Education, to ensure we not only comply
with all charter school operational and fiscal requirements, but we set very high standards in our academic expectations for all of our students.
In addition, as a public school, we proactively seek the opportunities to be leaders in the charter school environment and the local and wider non-charter community.
Over time we have grown and developed our programme from a 230 student middle school serving 6th through 8th grade to become a thriving middle and high school programme serving 825 students.
We focus on career, college and the lifelong opportunities for the young people in our school.
to ensure every student has a secure and optimistic plan for future success.
Here to highlight some of the critical markers of our success is Dr. Tanisha Barnett, Assistant Director of Middle School.
New West is known for its academic rigor.
Our challenging curriculum that emphasizes teaching to students rather than the test has helped our students achieve tremendous results.
By every measure, whether API, AYP, KC, CST of the past, SBAC, PSAT, SAT, ACT, and dashboard of the present, New West students consistently achieve above the local, state, and national averages.
and it's getting noticed.
On May 3rd, we were notified that we received a full six year accreditation from WASC.
In the last month, newest students have admitted to every campus of the University of California and every campus of the California State University system they apply to.
Along with big names like Stanford, Harvard, Princeton, Columbia, Cornell, Northwestern, Pomona, Yale, Harvard Mudd, Johns Hopkins, Brown, Berkeley, UCLA, USC, Dartmouth, Tums, and the University of Pennsylvania.
And we're still rolling in.
We're proud of our students' academic accomplishments, but we know they're not the greater goal.
NUBAS doesn't just measure its success by the percentage of students it graduates, number of college admission earned, or amount of scholarships won.
We measure success by how well we prepare our alumni to thrive in their university's career and personal lives.
Long after they cross our commencement stage, as a result, our students themselves are the hallmarks of our success.
Since our last renewal in 2012, the SBE provided us the opportunity to expand our program from a highly successful middle school by supporting the vision of New West to open a new public charter high school.
It's noteworthy to mention that New West opened the first new public high school in West Los Angeles in almost 50 years.
But what is even more interesting is that the opportunity of a new academically rigorous high school program is not restricted to any physical attendance boundary in LA.
Given our doors are open to everyone, our population is both economically, racially, and geographically diverse, and the New West community welcomes families from over 73 zip codes over a sprawling urban landscape.
Word about the expansion of New West quickly spread throughout LA and since our last renewal has resulted in almost 10,000 people attending our open houses, all desperately seeking admissions to our school.
As a result of our reputation as a high quality public institution, New West is the longest wait list of any public school in LA County.
Although New West is proud of the reputation it has gained as a successful public charter school, our success is a direct result of the endless hard work of our team and the tireless analysis of what makes and sustains quality in public education.
We are delighted that the CDE staff are recommending renewal of our long-standing charter and appreciate their thoughtful and encouraging suggestions in our plans for further expansion.
In addition, following the recent ACCS meeting held on April 5th, we were very appreciative of a 6-1 majority recommendation by the commissioners to also renew the New West petition.
Furthermore, following the ACCS meeting, we were granted permission to meet with Ms Chan and the staff of the CDE and come to a greater understanding and agreement on the proposed technical amendments recommended for changes to the New West Home School Agreement.
Overall a central tenet of our success is the new West Home School Agreement which is a direct link between home and school and has proven to be enormously successful in keeping alive the connection between parents, school and students.
We have tried and tested data that proves that New West families proactively participate in the homeschool agreement and this successful practice has only generated closer relationships between home and school.
As a school we must proceed with caution with requested changes to alter the homeschool agreement as there are significant economic impacts related to this provision in our charter.
New West is situated in a facility with a rare 30-year lease.
We have occupied the 1905 Armacost site since 2012 and have invested over $4 million in creating an amazing school for both our middle and high school students.
However, the building is located in an industrial zone that requires a variance
with a very specific conditional use permit issued by the LA Department of Building and Planning.
We can only occupy the Armacost site if we agree to comply with traffic mitigation measures that are part of our homeschool agreement.
Fortunately we have an excellent relationship with the LA Department of Building and Planning who gave New West the opportunity to design a creative traffic mitigation program called the TMMP.
which works for every family at our school and does not impose unworkable traffic mitigation measures upon anyone.
Not only does our current TMMP alleviate local congestion, but it contributes to the overall LA City plan for traffic reduction.
In essence, it's a win-win for everyone.
Simply put, the new West Homeschool Agreement is vital if we are to be permitted to continue to occupy our school building as a condition of meeting the specific requirements of the covenant agreed upon in the CUP.
We look forward to continuing to implement the homeschool agreement in compliance with the conditions we have negotiated with the CDE.
Finally, we would like to highlight our remaining concern with the technical amendments suggested by the CDE as it relates to admissions.
In 2011, the SBE approved a short list of purposeful admissions preferences for New West.
Most critically, the admissions preferences previously approved by the SBE enabled us to achieve two important goals.
The first admissions preference, after continuing students, offered students who are most economically disadvantaged a first preference in our lottery.
Since our last renewal, New West was able to establish an incredibly successful admissions preference with a local elementary non-charter local school district called Brockton Avenue Elementary.
The vast majority of students who come from Brockton Elementary to New West are socioeconomically disadvantaged and many will be the first to attend college.
It's taken multiple years of careful and respectful outreach to get to the point where 100% of the students and their families from Brockton Elementary accept the admissions preference into New West.
This is a life-changing opportunity to place disadvantaged students at the front of the admissions line and can
that can be over a thousand students long and place them on a secure path to college and career success.
The second admissions preference that's been previously permitted by the SBE relates to siblings.
Almost 100% of the siblings who come to New West live in the local district but are given a preference that allows families to stay together.
Siblings at New West make up for almost 35% of our incoming sixth grade class
To deny local district students the opportunity to stay with their older brother or sister at New West is counterintuitive to supporting families and schools.
These two specific admissions preferences that were previously approved by the SBE directly comply with both current law and relevant statute.
Nothing has changed in the past five years.
It's unquestionable that the current preferences as they appear in our previous and new charter petition support increasing diversity and keeping families together at New West.
We respectfully request that the SBE allow New West to continue with their previously approved list of admissions preferences as described in the renewal petition presented today.
Overall we truly hope the SBE will support our charter renewal and expansion and carefully consider the significant impact of so many technical amendments on a very well established school.
In closing we would like to add that we are both very excited and genuinely looking forward to continuing on as a role model school and would take great pride in further approval if granted by the State Board of Education.
Thank you sincerely to the State Board of Education
of state board members for your time and listening to my Scottish accent.
I appreciate that.
Okay.
Thank you.
And now the 10 minutes is up and now the opponents have 10 minutes.
No opponents.
Okay.
All right.
I'm declaring public hearing closed.
And now we're ready for public comment.
We have three speakers, Angela DeRamos, Eric Premack, and Janelle Rooley.
Please line up.
Eric Premax, CSDC.
We support the approval of the appeal with the elimination of the fee-related provisions of the parent agreement in support of their traffic plan.
Thank you.
Good afternoon again, Janelle Rooley with the Law Offices of Young, Many, and Core here in strong support of New West Charter.
New West has been proud to be a state board authorized school since its inception.
The charter school appreciates and values its positive relationship with CDE staff.
As you're considering this renewal, we ask that you approve the admissions preferences in the proposed charter renewal petition.
These include existing students who are exempt from the lottery, the SB 740 preference that we've spoken about, district siblings, in-district students, and children of employees.
CDE staff have already changed their recommendation regarding the SB 740 students.
I'm sorry, preference.
The statute's clear that charter schools may give a preference for, I'm sorry, must give a preference for-
Good afternoon, Michelle Lynch on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
We too are in support of the renewal today with those preferences included.
Thank you.
Hi, Angela Duramos with California Teachers Association.
The California Teachers Association is opposed to the state board overturning the decision of local control district of local control local school district in denying charter school petitions.
The locally elected school board is directly accountable to the community and clearly operates with that in mind.
The same cannot be said with stated authorized charters who are authorized by appointed members as opposed to elected ones.
If we as a state believe in local control policies as evidenced by LCFF, then let's be consistent in our goal of being responsive to communities.
Thank you.
Okay.
Is that the end of the public comment?
That's closed.
Board member.
I'd like to ask the petitioners to come back up, please.
I have a couple of questions.
So it appears as though.
Previous state boards and current CDE and ACTS are very supportive of your school and the work that you're doing.
We want to be very careful about these conditions that the CDE is recommending and make sure that we're all in agreement about these and that each of these conditions is appropriate, you know, for the situation.
So please articulate carefully which... Do you agree with the CDE recommendation for renewal with the technical amendments and conditions as written?
Okay.
I'm getting there.
Let's start with the basic.
So no, you do not.
Okay.
And so specifically, which ones do you disagree with?
So I met with Cindy Chan a few weeks ago and we went through the admissions conditions.
And my request was that the conditions as they were written in 2011 should be repeated now.
And those conditions, as Miss Shirley had indicated, were continuing kids.
There were SB 740 preference, then there was in-district siblings and then we had other preferences beyond that.
So I'm asking for those preferences to remain.
What was initially proposed by the CDE was simply returning students and then students of the district.
They've also mentioned subsequently that we can keep the SB 740 preference, but we're also going to have two sites.
So it's going to be Brockton Elementary and Richland Elementary because there's two school sites that apply to this.
The other point that I want to mention is the TMMP.
We have a signed covenant that CDE was involved in when we took on this new site, which requires us to have a TMMP programme.
It does not cost a single penny for any kid to participate in that, but it's a requirement of occupation of this site, so we're asking for that TMMP and families to be asked to participate in it to remain.
Let me ask you a specific question about, I understand the preferences now.
Let me ask a very specific question about this TMPP or whatever.
That is an agreement that the school has made with the city, correct?
That is not an agreement that the parents have made with the city.
There are lots of ways
of helping parents understand the value of supporting the school in this agreement without having them enter into a signed agreement.
Would you agree?
Yes.
Thank you.
Board Member Rucker.
Okay, so I just want to make sure I understand on the admissions requirements that there's a packet of information in your admissions packet that I want to make sure is going to be corrected.
the admissions packet that you had requires some financial commitments from the parents as well as some volunteer hours.
Are you disagreeing to take that out of your admissions packet?
Absolutely not.
In actual fact, that's already been changed.
Okay, I just wanted to make sure I was clear on that.
And then as it relates to the admissions preferences, can you explain to me why
You need, you feel you need to hang on to that.
How many families at your school are actually impacted by that right now?
By the sibling preference, 35% of our incoming sixth grade students are siblings.
Most of them are in the district, about 95% of them are already in the district.
And can you tell me what the diversity is at your school right now?
About 50% Caucasian students, 50% minority students.
Okay, so when you say 50% minority, could you break that down?
Sure.
I'm answering every question.
No, that's okay.
Oh, I don't mind who answers.
First of all, let me just say I'm from the South.
And when you're from the South and you have a Southern accent, they lower your IQ 20 points and look at you sweetly.
So I wish I had your Southern, your Scottish accent.
So it doesn't matter who.
So it doesn't matter who answers the question.
That's just fine.
But the question I asked was, could you break down the 50 percent minority?
Sure.
So, roughly speaking, we're looking at about 26 Latinos.
26% Latino?
Yes.
Okay.
Based on that preference of the SBC 740.
It really helps us with our diversity breakdown.
We have about 11% African-American.
We have 6% Asian.
And I'm not sure what the remaining percentage is.
About 7%.
Give or take mixed groups.
And then within that, there's the client estate.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you.
Any other questions by board members?
If not, are we ready for a motion?
Board member Williams.
I move that we approve this renewal and but to keep the enrollment preferences the same as were approved in 2011.
Cindy's going to come up here and correct me.
Yeah, you can sit down.
Yes.
Yeah, you may return to your seats.
So, I mean, none of us were here in that year when it was approved.
But when we go back and look at the item and the minutes for that renewal, it looks the same as what we're proposing.
All it mentions is kids of the charter that are returning to the school, kids of the district and then the preference for the 740.
Yeah, it's not in the item nor in the minutes.
You're saying it's not in the item or minutes from 2011?
Yeah.
So we looked at it because we just weren't sure because none of us had been here during that other renewal.
So that doesn't look like what was approved back in 2011.
So I just want to clarify that.
And then in terms of just to make it easier, when we look at the conditions as a whole, if they were to keep that homeschool agreement as is with all of those conditions of enrollment, mandatory thing, that's what makes that traffic policy a problem because it looks like they're required.
if they remove and clean up the homeschool agreement, then that's more of a policy that's in there.
It really should be separate, but we are worried that there might be some harm done to the facility.
So they need to remove that language.
I mean, we're more concerned with not allowing pupils to attend.
That's part of charter law.
So that's why we propose that.
That is a legal requirement.
So what, in essence, what this motion that was just made by Member Williams is identical to your recommendation, except for the sibling preference.
Is that correct?
What we, it looked like what we proposed and what was passed in the renewal is exactly what we're saying in this one, which is.
No, I'm not talking about 2011.
I'm talking about now.
Right.
So Member Williams, I believe,
We don't have siblings.
We haven't.
I know that.
But your recommendation for renewal, right, is identical to what Member Williams said, except for the sibling preference.
Is that correct?
In other words, I was approving everything that you that you have in there except for the adding the sibling preference.
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I just want to make sure I'm clear.
I just want to make sure I'm clear on your motion.
Yeah, I just want to make it on this point.
All of the other conditions proposed by the staff you're saying need to be part of the renewal.
The only thing that you are adding is based on the request and the explanation from the charter that they be allowed to continue the enrollment preference to include the siblings.
Okay.
And that I will second.
So we have a motion and a second.
Further board discussion?
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay.
That one carries.
So we're getting the final item, which is the Paramount Collegiate Academy.
One more.
Okay, six of six.
Okay, last item of the day.
So again, Cindy Chan, Charter Schools Division at the California Department of Education.
So this is the only material revision that we're actually bringing to you today.
Item 21 is a request for a material revision from a current State Board of Education authorized charter school.
Paramount Collegiate Academy was originally denied by the San Juan Unified School District and the Sacramento County Board of Education.
Paramount appealed to the state and was approved by the state board in May 2015 for a five-year term to serve up to 200 pupils in grade six through grade nine, adding an additional grade level each year, expanding to 800 pupils in grade six through grade 12 by 2019-20.
Paramount is currently in its second year of operation.
Paramount's original petition was budgeted to begin its first year of operation, 2015-16, with 200 pupils.
However, Paramount began instruction with a total enrollment of 56 pupils, a decline of 72%.
By March 15, 2016, Paramount's second interim report reported current enrollment at 61 pupils,
and projected an ending fund balance of $9,600 with a 0.84% reserve.
As a result of the significant decline or actually not able to make that enrollment target in Paramount's then current enrollment and projected enrollment for the subsequent school years,
The CD issued a letter of fiscal concern requiring Paramount to submit a material revision to the PCA petition, revising its multi-year budget and cash flow statements to align with the lower, more realistic pupil enrollment.
In addition, the CD requested that the material revision also address the proposed actions that the PCA board will take to ensure pupil enrollment growth.
On November 1st, the CD received PCA's request for a material revision to its charter.
to reduce projected enrollment from its original enrollment plan of 800 pupils by year 5 to 140 pupils in grade 6 through grade 12 by 2019-20.
Based on a review of the petition documents, and again we do a full petition review, the CD recommends that the State Board hold a public hearing and therefore
thereafter approve with technical amendments the request for a material revision of the Paramount Charter.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools considered the Paramount material revision at its April 5th meeting and unanimously voted to approve CDE's recommendation that the State Board approve the Paramount material revision with the technical amendments proposed by the CDE.
So we reviewed the entire PCA material revision petition.
We find that it meets the standards and criteria requirements and provides a reasonably comprehensive description of the multiple required elements with our few technical amendments.
For your consideration, the two primary components of the material revision are the recruitment and outreach plan and the budget, which I will summarize as follows.
As part of the material revision, Paramount has made pupil enrollment and recruitment its number one priority.
Paramount is now partnering with the California Charter Schools Association to address enrollment growth through its multifaceted recruitment and outreach plan.
The Paramount founder is here today and can more fully present to you with details on what those efforts are.
We performed a thorough review of Paramount's revised budget and multi-year fiscal plan as the material revision proposes to significantly reduce the original enrollment.
We note that Paramount ended fiscal year 2015-16, so its first year, with a negative ending fund balance of $131,000 that was carried forward to the current year.
Paramount has revised its current expenditures in response to the decline in revenues due to the lower enrollment.
This includes adjustments to salaries, benefits, and professional consulting services.
To cover monthly negative cash flow, Paramount received a low-interest five-year loan.
Both the loan proceeds and annual repayments have been included in Paramount's revised financial plan.
The multi-year budget submitted by Paramount with the mature revision includes reduced revenues and expenditures across all years.
Paramount is projecting a modest growth in enrollment of 20 pupils each year through fiscal year 2019-20, which will increase local control funding formula revenues accordingly.
Paramount is also projecting expenditure reductions to salaries and benefits, book supplies, services, and other operating expenses.
We find that the paramount adjusted multi-year financial plan to be reasonably sufficient as the charter school begins to rebuild its reserves beginning next year.
So I want to, it sounds good, it all sounds good.
But the current year budget, I'm going to be really straightforward, it's not robust by any means.
It is not where we would like to see one of our schools.
They have had negative monthly cash flow for the first six months of the year.
But it's looking like they're projecting to end the year with positive cash flow each month.
So they did have a cash balance, which is what they're kind of operating off of.
They're dependent on that cash until they can get that enrollment up and they're monitoring it closely and regularly and with the expenditure cuts which we did question because we want to make sure the cuts don't hurt the program because they had to make such significant cuts.
The recruitment efforts it has and will continue to implement are, I mean, that's the whole thing for them.
It's so important that they get their enrollment up.
They're dependent absolutely on the enrollment growth.
In our opinion, they cannot afford to make any additional budget reductions without impacting, we believe, their educational program and their operations.
So in summary, we recommend that the state board hold the public hearing, thereafter approve the request for a material revision of the charter with our recommended technical amendments.
So I know the school's here, they have their students and they're gonna present to you.
Any clarifying questions for Ms.
Chan before we start?
Okay, so I declare the public hearing open.
So all those, will the petitioners come forward, Paramount?
You have 10 minutes.
Good afternoon, State Board.
As you heard in the presentation, PCA was approved by the State Board in May of 2015.
And in the reports that we've provided to the CDE, we explained that in our opening year, we started off with a late start, which carried into this second year.
And it critically affected our enrollment in year one.
The other obstacles that we had to overcome in year one was that when we acquired a facility that had been abandoned and we made major renovations to that building.
The building was not ready until September.
So in year one, we started the school year late
And we put a lot of money into the renovations of the facility.
Going into this year, in working with the CDE, we did make extensive cuts in our budget.
We made over $125,000 cuts in salary and benefits.
And we made nearly $40,000 cut in our lease, which was renegotiated.
So where we've focused on this year after we balanced our budget, and actually as of our last budget report, we're currently close to $50,000 in reserve above the 3% reserve that's required, which is about $110,000 in the positive.
And that's as of March.
So we've recouped about $250,000 in this school year.
We've turned things around.
And we focused on enrollment growth.
We've spent a lot of time this year just all of the things that are listed in the report here that we provided to CDE.
We've done all of those things and we continue to work on enrollment.
We've already met our target for the next school year and we intend to exceed that target to continue enrolling students.
We have not capped out any of our enrollment at any of our school grades.
We're already opening up a second class of seventh and a second class of eighth grade students and we're going to continue to enroll through the summer.
Kind of just going through all of the different enrollment campaigns and things.
We've held extensive social media campaigns that we continue.
And we're working on right now getting ready to reissue out an extensive Facebook, Google, AdWord, and website campaign.
We're continuing to hold parent meetings and tours
that continuing this time of the school year and into the summer.
We also are participating in recruitment activities at local festivals, at the upcoming county fair, and summer festivals that are located in the Arden Arcade area.
And we are preparing online summer resources for students and incoming students that are requesting additional resources for mathematics.
We're responding to a lot of parent requests and we've partnered now with two other K-8 charter schools in the Sacramento region that we're articulating with and we're getting a lot of enrollment
from one of those charters in particular as we just continue to grow.
And like I said, we're just continuing to just really have a keen focus on enrollment.
Okay.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
All right.
So, the opponents are... Is there any opposition to this item?
for ten minutes.
If not.
Not that I'm aware of.
Okay.
If not, I declare the public hearing closed and we're ready for public comment.
We have Jesse Aguilar and Andra Donovan signed up.
And Michelle Lowe.
Lynch.
Sorry, I forgot to grab the sheet before they took it away.
Michelle Lynch on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
I just wanted to say we are working closely with the school.
We have a parent team that goes out to help schools get more parents in and basically just, you know, expand on the efforts that they're already doing.
So we are very hopeful that we'll be getting some more enrollment with the school and we'll be working closely with them.
And right now we do ask that you support this mature revision today.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
It's Jesse Eagle with the California Teachers Association.
CTA is deeply concerned that the request for a material revision from 800 pupils to 140 pupils signals deeper ongoing problems.
We believe that the educational program has been significantly affected and we urge the board to deny.
Thank you.
Public comment closed.
I believe we may have one or two students planning on making a public comment.
If you have not been called and you wish to speak, please come forward.
Hi I'm Tatiana.
I started middle school at PCA last year and didn't like the idea of leaving all of my friends and teachers.
The first day at PCA I was nervous but immediately changed my mind when I met my amazing teachers and friends.
Some of my favorite classes are Spanish, student government and math.
What I like about student government is how involved it is.
We do campus beautification and lots of fun activities like our school dances and walk-ins.
My mom offered to move me to a different school, but I declined because I didn't want to leave.
I enjoy attending PCA and feel other students should experience the school.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Jadida.
I started going to PCA in middle school.
I started the same day as Tatiana.
I love the way that there were people welcoming me to be their friend.
Something that is amazing about PCA is the way that teachers help you individually to raise your grade or with your homework.
I also love the way that there is a lot of technology and that we get our own tablets to help us out.
Last of all is the way there is classes like coding, student government, Spanish and more.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Alyssa.
I was one of the first kids at PCA and I immediately liked it.
PCA has amazing classes like math, science, Spanish, and student government.
Coding is one of the classes and my favorite.
I really love it.
The teachers push us to excel in all of our classes.
They want us to succeed.
My school has homework, help for kids who need it.
We do many fun activities like dance,
dances, games, and walk-ins.
PCA is an amazing school and I want other kids to experience it.
Thank you.
Hi, I'm Vlad.
And personally, I like PCA because we get to learn a lot of cool things.
For example, we'll learn how to code on computers.
We do awesome science experiments.
We also have building block.
And in building block, we have different clubs.
Some clubs, for example, sports club, scratch coding, music club, and the best of all, homework help.
A lot of our teachers take out their time to stay in school and help us with our homework.
Most of our homework is done on computer, which makes things much easier.
Overall, I think PCA is a great school.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Rebecca.
I am on PCA's robotics team.
Last summer, I found out about PCA.
My mom told me all about it.
And the second I heard about it, I couldn't wait to go, especially when I heard about the robotics and the engineering and the coding.
Since then, I got really good at coding and 3D modeling.
What makes this school special is that they have engineering for sixth grade and up.
They have students compete in regional competitions, like when we went to the competition at NASA this year.
Also, we have homework help and small classes so everyone can get help and has the ability to pass.
This is why I love PCA.
Thank you.
Okay, that closes the public comment.
Now we're ready for board public discussion.
Board member Holliday.
So I think we heard about the couple issues they had when they first started up that affected their enrollment.
The building not ready, having to start after the regular schools started.
That can be a
disastrous thing for startup charter school, of course.
And it sounds as though they have their enrollment at the projected figure for this coming year.
I certainly hope that there's no further cuts because it will impact the program that there are further cuts.
But it sounds as though working with CCSA and with all of their outreach efforts that they're on track to be fiscally solid.
I think we should give them a second chance and I would move the staff recommendation.
Board Member Williams.
I would second that recommendation and I would encourage the school to use, I really liked hearing all of the students and especially the females be interested in coding and computer science.
And I would, I think it could be a real recruitment tool for you to make sure that students that you're recruiting know that that's available.
Any further board discussion?
Not.
We have a motion and a second.
All in favor, raise your hand.
Okay, that carries unanimously and the board is adjourned.
Thank you, Cindy.
Yes, bravo, Cindy.
Amazing.
Thank you, Cindy.